WELCOME EVERYONE ASSEMBLY LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING- DUE TO THE CONTINUE
STAY AT HOME ORDER REFER FACT
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL%
DISTANCE YOU'RE THE- ANTHROPIC
BUILDINGS WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING IN THE HEARING. ROOM
IN PERSON OR ALSO FIND THE
MATTHEW WARNED AND FISCAL
DISTRIBUTING TAMED BUT ALL OF
NUMBERS THE A TEST WITH YOU
HERE IN THE ROOM VIDEO
CONFERENCING SO. DO NOT HAVE.
YOU I'M- YOU KNOW FOR MEMBER
CENTERS THE MAYBE STE ORTEZ WE
YOU KEEP YOUR MASK ON UNLESS OF
IT DURING YOUR TESTIMONY DURING
IT YOUR COMMENTS YOUR LIKE TO
GET OFF THAT'S OKAY BUT IF YOU
CAN OTHERWISE GREAT AS WELL.
ONE OTHERWISE YOU'RE SPEAKING
AT A GREAT YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT ON WHAT TESTIMONY
TODAY. OF FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF
WITH A NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC CAN
MEET. YES WE CAN MEANS. THE SIX
SPEED PLACING. PHYSICAL
DISASSEMBLER THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM IF
ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A
BILL A PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
AT THE TIME. IN A PERSON. I
HAVE TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONES PLAY GOOD POLICY IN
GENERAL. EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU'RE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. IS BE SURE
TO OBSERVERS GO DOESN'T UP ON
THE IN THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. IF YOU'RE
CALLING INTO BY PUBLIC COMMENT
YES IT'S THAT YOU STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. WE ANTICIPATE A
HIGH CALL VOLUME TODAY SO JUST
AS IF YOU WERE IN THE ROOM AND
WE'RE NOT ONE OF THE- DEEMED
WITNESSES TESTIFYING. UP YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND
POSITION ON THE BILL THE CALL
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR. THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIN THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY LABOR
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN THIS EMULATOR
CAN WEBSITE. AS A L. B. R. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV. A. L.
B. R. AS AN ASSEMBLY LABOR SO
IT'S A L. B. R. DOT ASSEMBLY
DOT CA DOT GOV. FOR CALLING
EMPLOYEES TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFIED TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. OPERATE ON THE
LINE WITH YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN Q. BASED ON
WHAT DO YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
ABOUT. FOR CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOURS
ARE DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED IF YOU'RE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDED. BEFORE
AGAINST A BILL YOU'LL REMAIN ON
A LIVE LINE AND WILL NEED TO
MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THIS. CALL
THE COMMITTEE. AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
ONE. AGAIN THAT'S NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
ONE AND MY STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW THE- TING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL. ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE ALSO
HAVE AN EMAIL ADDRESS SET UP
THAT YOU CAN USE TO EMAIL US
YOUR TESTIMONY. THE EMAIL IS A
BR. DOT COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT GOV. JENNIFER LIKE TO
EMAIL COMMENTS ON ANY OF THE
BILLS. A. L. B. R. DOT
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV. THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH
US AS WE IMPLEMENT MATHIS
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS THAT WE
ALL FACE SO AT THIS TIME OF THE
CAN HAVE. A BALL CALL AND IN
ORDER TO ESTABLISH QUORUM. HERE.
TRY IT. FOUR NINE DON'T ATTEMPT.
FLORA CORREO. DEEP GONZALEZ.
JONES SAWYER PRESIDENT
THREE OF US. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISHED AND
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND DO THE
BILLS AND FILE ORDER STARTING
WITH SB YOU SEVENTY FIVE
SENATOR PAN. DOES SENATOR OF AS
THE FIRST ONE UP WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY LET US KNOW AND I
AND I BELIEVE YOU. HAD A TEST
FINDS MET. WITH SCA CALIFORNIA
MY PHONE AND- GABRIEL MONTOYA.
BUT AS YET YOU YOU H. W. ALSO
BY PHONE AND THIS IS GOING TO
BE FOR ALL WITNESSES THAT
ALWAYS HAVE. TEST MY TO. EACH
AND CAN BE DIVIDED UP ANYWAY I
AM THE AUTHOR AS WELL SO GO
AHEAD- SENATOR PAN AND AGAIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU CHAIR KALRA AN MEMBERS AND
PREACHY YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND PUBLIC HEALTH THE- FOCUS OF.
WHEN A RESPIRATORY ILLNESS
CAUSED BY CORONAVIRUS SWEPT
ACROSS TAIWAN THERE WAS A
SUDDEN SUPPLY SHORTAGE OF
SURGICAL MASKS AND NINETY FIVE
RESPIRATORS AND OTHER PP. THIS
STARTED HIM MASS AND RETAIL
MARKET TRIGGERED PANIC BUYING
THE PUBLIC IN IN FRONT LINE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AFRAID TO
GO TO WORK BECAUSE I PP
SHORTAGES. I'M LIKE THE STAR OF
ABOUT THE NINETEEN BUT ACTUALLY.
THIS IS THE STORY OF SARS IN
TWO THOUSAND AND THREE IN FACT
IN RESPONSE TO THIS SARS
EXPERIENCE TAIWAN ESTABLISHED A
STOCKPILE STRUCTURE FOR PT TO
HELP TAIWAN HAVE WON THE BEST
TRACK RECORD THE CONTAINING
COVERT NINETEEN WENT OVER%
NINETEEN ARRIVED IN TAIWAN WILL
WORK SOME SHORTAGES OF PVD.
FACILITIES WE'RE ABLE TO
CONTAIN P. E. L. AND FOUGHT
VERY VALUE TIME TO GEAR UP
THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS. SB TWENTY
FIVE FOLLOWS TAIWAN'S EXAMPLE
BY ESTABLISHING BOTH THE STATE
STOCKPILE WITH A NIGHT
EMERGENCY SUPPLY PP FOR ALL
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WILL BE
RAMPED UP OVER THE COURSE OF
FIVE YEARS AS- I AM IN. POLLS
HAVE SHOWN. IN ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL WOULD ALSO INCENTIVIZE A
DOMESTIC SUPPLY PP BY REQUIRING
25% OF THE STATE'S STOCKPILE TO
BE MADE IN CALIFORNIA. NOT
WANTING KNOWLEDGE THAT WE'VE
HAD MANY ROBUST CONVERSATIONS.
WITH VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS ON
THE BILL AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS THEY HAVE RATE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH OUR GOAL WHICH IS TO
HAVE A BILL THAT PROTECTS EX
ARE WINE. WORKER JOHN PAUL. AND
IS ALSO MANAGEABLE OUR ALL
PARTIES NO THE POINT OUT THAT
THIS IS THE PORTANTINO OF THE
PREPARATION BIGELOW BUYS
VALUABLE TIME TO THINK ABOUT
THE PANIC HAPPENED WHEN CALLED
NINETEEN CAME. IN THE- HEALTH
CARE WHAT. EVEN GARBAGE BAG TO
TRY TO PROTECT THEM. RIGHT BUT
THE THING IS THAT IF THE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WHO ARE
USUALLY AT THE TOP OF THE-
PRIORITY LIST FOR PVD CAN'T GET
IT YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT'S GOING
ON FAR THAT ON THE CHENEY.
ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE HAD. NO
THIS EIGHTY. THE BILL CLEAR
THIS YEAR EIGHT TWENTY THEN BY
SIMILAR RIDE. AND WHICH
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND WE'VE
HAD NUMEROUS CONVERSATIONS
WITH- THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
CNN AND CERTAINLY ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM TO
ENSURE THAT ALL WORKERS PROTECT
EQUIPMENT THEY NEED A- ROACH. I
AM COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE OLDER AND IS A MEMBER BONTA
HIS IF THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
TO REACH AN AGREEMENT THOUSAND
SURE THAT WE ARE BETTER
PREPARED THIS SURE AND THAT WE
ARE YOU TO. KEEP SAFE AFTER IF
WE TO GET FROM. WHEN WE WILL
HAVE TO CONFRONT ANY FUTURE
OUTBREAKS AND PANDEMICS WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK ME I VOTE
YOU HAVE REPRESENTS AND AS YOU
ARE YOU ON THE LINE SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. IT THANK
YOU. AT JERRY MEMBERS THIS IS
THAT MY NAME IS MATT WAS A I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS AT CSU
CALIFORNIA THE CROWD SPONSOR SB
TWO SEVENTY FIVE. CALIFORNIANS
HEALTHCARE EMPLOYERS FAIL TO
PREPARE FOR CRISIS OF THE
MAGNITUDE A CUP IN NINETEEN
ENDEMIC. THESE EPIC WITH AN
ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF PP LEFT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS BOTH ONE
FACTION DEATH- SUMMERS. TO YOU
P. LIKE BANDANNAS AND TRASH
BAGS ARE ALL MADE. AS OF JULY
TWENTY SEVEN LOCAL HEALTH. ME
TO REPORT IT. YOU TO STOP FOR
CASES THE COPING OF HEALTH CARE.
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY THAT STATE
WIDE. WE BELIEVE SB AT TWO FIVE
ENSURES THAT WORKERS WILL NOT
GO WITHOUT. HER THROUGH THREE
CAN. ON IT'S A DOCTOR CAN
MENTION THE FIRST IS THAT-
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT. STOCKPILE WHICH WOULD
IMPORTANT BACKSTOPS SUPPORT
HEALTHCARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
DURING A TIME ABOUT- A PANDEMIC
OTHER HELP THE BIRD THE- SECOND
IS TO. INCREASE THE- SUPPLY
HEALTHCARE EMPLOYERS BY
REQUIRING THAT NINETY DAY AND
THAT MAKE LOCALSUPPLY A P. P.
FOR ALL WORKERS- INSURING THAT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS HAVE WHAT
THEY NEED IMMEDIATELY. AND THEN
THIRD TRY TO BUILD A MORE
RESILIENT- SUPPLY CHAIN OF PP
BY TRYING TO ENCOURAGE MORE IN
STATE MANUFACTURING WILL BOTH-
ALSO HELP US TO QUICKLY RAMP UP
PRODUCTION OF P. ONE IS IN HIGH
DEMAND DURING A PANDEMIC CAN
ALSO. CALIFORNIA THE WORK. UP
TWO SEVENTY FIVE IS BOTH A NOT
BECAUSE THE PROBLEM JUST BE OF
ACROSS ISSUES WOULD NOT PROVIDE
WORKERS WITH PP BUT ALSO
BECAUSE THIS IS THE IMPACTING
MEET TYLER REPRESENTATIVES.
JOBS AND I'M STUBBORN CORE.
HIGH INFECTION RATE WHICH IS
REALLY WORKING AGE LOOKING TO.
THREE COMPACTION ARE CLOSE 220%
HIGHER THAN THEIR SHARE OF THE
CALIFORNIA RELATIONS. IN
CLOSING UP THE ARE YOU
SPONSORING SB TWO SEVENTY FIVE
BECAUSE OF OUR MEMBERS DEMAND
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH PP SO ALL
WORKERS. WILL NEVER GO OUT THE
NECESSARY. SIMPLY PUT WILL HELP
SICK BY. FOR THE THREE I URGE
EITHER ON IT TWO SEVENTY FIVE.
I'M HAPPY TO SAY ON FOR QUITE
BUT WITH TODAY ROMAN. BUT MY
TONE. I FEAR YOU REMEMBER ONE
OF OUR HEROES. THANK YOU MISTER
JERRY. AND APOLOGIZE OR
MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME EARLIER
AND MISTER A MENTALLY ILL
PLEASE CONTINUE. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE CHAIR KALRA AND
MEMBERS. ABLE ON PLAY AND I'M
BRING STEVEN TECH AT THE
PERMANENT PAY COUNTY MEDICAL
CENTER FROM THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC DID TODAY I THINK
FIRST HAND HOW THE BEER THE PP
SHORTAGES ARE AND THE IN THE
SHORT THE CARD THE BALLOT HOW.
OUR PAY. I THINK PEOPLE TODAY
RUNS COUNTER TO EVERYTHING I'VE
BEEN TAUGHT MY ENTIRE CAREER
OPINION TEAM PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC WHEN WE WENT INTO A
PATIENT'S ROOM AND YOUR LIFE
THE FACE SHIELD GAL ARE NINETY
FIVE MATH. DONE DURING THAT.
AND WE CAN. THREE WAY WHY THEY
WERE CONFIGURE CONTAMINATED NOW
WE KEEP THE MAP ON OUR FACES
FOR TEN TO TWELVE HOURS A DAY
NOT ONLY PUTTING OUR PATIENTS
AT RISK FOR CONTAMINATION BUT
ALSO PUT. BY POP GETTING THIS
IN OUR MOUTHS ARE I AS YOU PUT
ON AND TAKE OFF THE MASK
THROUGHOUT THE DAY ALSO. THERE
ARE SHIPS WE MATH IN AND THEY
ARE RE PROP BETS ARE CLEAN
HOWEVER BECAUSE THE BILL WILL
GIVE WE CONFIDENT THAT THEY. I
WORRY ABOUT AFFECTING MY LOVED
ONE. FOR EXAMPLE I HAVEN'T
CAUGHT MY MOM SINCE EARLY MARCH
ARE EVEN BEEN IN THE SAME ROOM
WITH HER WHY BECAUSE I AM
CONFIDENT THAT RE YOU ARE LOWER
LEVELS OF PP PROTECTING FROM
PACKING THAT BELONG TO HURT
BECAUSE I'D- BE EXPECTED. I MY
HUSBAND TO. HOME BECAUSE I
DIDN'T TRY. AT WORK
ADDITIONALLY IT'S NOT A NOT TO
ONLY PROVIDE PP TO DOCTORS AND
OTHER HIGHER PAID WORKERS
REPEATING PP E. R. HIGHER LEVEL
PP SHOULDN'T TOO BY THE LEFT
BEHIND YOUR NAME ARE HOW MUCH
MONEY YOU MAKE. YOU SHORTAGE.
ECONOMIC JUSTICE KOBE NINETEEN
IT'S ALREADY DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTING LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY INADEQUATE
PP SUPPLIES COMPACT ANY QUALITY
BECAUSE OPTED WORKERS OF COLOR
OR FORCED TO GO WITHOUT THE-
ONE FIVE EQUAL WE PROTECT ALL
THE CLOCK INCLUDING THOSE WERE
PAID LOWER WEIGHT. AND BUILD
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
BLACK AND BROWN WORKERS. GOING
TO COLLEGE HEALTHCARE HEROES
PLEASE TREAT IT LIKE HEALTHCARE
GIRL BY MAKING SURE WE GET THE
PP WE NEED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. YOU THIS MONTH. NOW
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR THOSE THAT
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL- AS
WE JUST ASK THAT YOU SEE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL LAST THE ROOM AND
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC DOES YOUR VERY FEW
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM TO COMPLY
WITH THAT APPROACH THIS IS AN-
BUT I'LL JUST. MOVE UP. COMO
TESTIMONIES ASIAN. AND THEN
WE'LL GO ON TO- ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL IN Q. ALREADY. WE
WILL GO FIRST TO. ONE MOMENT
LINE SIXTY THREE. WELL JUST A
MOMENT. FIND SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE SIX EIGHT
STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION.
WILL MOVE ON WHAT ONLINE NINETY
EIGHT ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CHEN
MEMBERS BENJAMIN TREND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOING OUT TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
TWO ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M SORRY LINE ONE
SEVENTY TWO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE YOUR COMMENT. WANT TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY TWO ONE EIGHT TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON NOVAK BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL THE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF OUR
ESSENTIAL FARMWORKERS UNITY
DROPPED THE STATE. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE FOUR NINE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE A LINE OF. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT RECORDER WTH
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION CALLING AND TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION AND WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORT IN THIS ROUND
AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR FOR
COMMITTEE TO HELP MITIGATE THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN THIS BILL
COULD HAVE PLACED. ON SMALL
DENTAL PRACTICES WE LOOK FOR
JUST BEING SOME OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS IN PRINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY FIVE
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S THE PROGRESS
CALLING AND FOUR AT THE- BELL.
THANK YOU. I AM THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MY NAME. FROM
YOUR I AM WITH THAT YEAH YOU
LOCAL ONE. I AM BOTH IN THAT DO
WORK WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL- IT WAS THAT LONG ON MY
MEMBERS THAT IS STATE IS VERY.
PROTECT THEIR BUILDING BUT- TO
GET THEM HE HAS BEEN. AND WE
THAT DOES HELP TO PROTECT
WORKERS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE ONE AWAY ONE ZERO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GONNA GO DOWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS. HERE WITH
THE SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
INTENTION OF THE BILL AND TO
ENSURE THAT ALL ESSENTIAL
WORKER AT EIGHTEEN WE DOES THAT.
MAN THAT. CALL OUT FARM. I WANT
TO BE ACCIDENTAL WORKER WERE
LISTED ON THE BACK TO BORDER
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTAIN A
CONVERSATION WITH THE ALT POP
THEM. THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY ONE
NINE FIVE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY LET MY AND MEMBER JACQUI
STERN ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
IN COURT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY. TWO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS EMILY ROSE
AND I'M WITH- MEDIA CRIED AND
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE FOR
ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FIND ONE OH NINE ONE
ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH I MIGHT
ADD HE I YOU YOU H. W. AND I OR-
II. AT. SEVEN I AM NOT SURE WE
DO HAVE SEVERAL MORE WILL GO
NEXT TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT LINE
EIGHT EIGHT GO AHEAD. NUMBER
TAYLOR JACK VAN CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION- I APOLOGIZE
FOR THE GROUND NINE- ABDUCTOR
AND- LAID OUT VERY WELL OUR-
LEGISLATION OF TO THE TOP WHILE
THE WITH CAPITA EARLIER THIS
YEAR. WHERE PROGRESS. IN OUR
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
TOPIC THAT. BOB THIRD LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING IN THAT
PROCESS AND- THAT ISSUE BECAUSE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT TO CNA AS
YOU KNOW MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE DIED DROPPED IT BECAUSE
LACK OF ACCESS. THANK FOR YOUR
AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO GOING
TO WORK WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE ZERO THREE ON OFFER
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
BRADY I WORK IN THE BIG
THROUGHOUT THE ALISON COOLEY
MAKE AND I'M WITH THE AIR YEAH
YOU AND YOU WHICH I DON'T. I'M
MORE WITH THE- FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE ONE ONE ONE TWO
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
ARE DOWN BUT BROWN ON GLOBAL IN
THE MEDICAL DEPARTMENT MENTAL
HEALTH WORKER AND I'M SUPPORT
OF IT. TWO SEVEN FIVE. BECAUSE
I AM TIRED OF GET UP EVERY DAY
HOPING THAT I'M NOT SICK BUT A
LACK OF PP WE HAVE I'M ALSO
TIRED OF SEEING ALL. THE
MICHAEL WANTED TO THE BOARD OF.
THANK YOU. LINE FOR NINE FOUR
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS DAVID T. SO I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF A MEMBER OF THE
CONGREGATION GET CHURCH OF
CHRIST I LIVE IN. IN PORT SB
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. BOB SIX FIVE ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY.
NAME IS THIRTY SEVEN HUMAN MAKE
THEM ACCORDING TO A GIRL NAMED
KATHY ON THE PHONE YEAH I'M
DAVE BURKE ON CHIEF LACK AND
THEN I TOOK. TO LINE THIRTY
THREE ZERO ALIGN AND OPEN.
CALLER ONLINE THREE ZERO ARE
YOU ARE YOU ON MUTE. WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE FORTY EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT I'M
A BIT REPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE EIGHTY ONE RURAL YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MARK HAS. THE
DIRECTOR AND LEGAL SERVICES
WORK AND TRUMP REPORT THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY TWO FOUR TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS ARE ON
THE HAVE OF THE CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS THE NATION AND THE
THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GREETINGS MY
NAME IS ADAM OVER TIME I'M
AFRAID CREATED ORGANIZER WITH
CLERGY AND LAY THE UNITED
CANONIC CHAPTER AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF OUR MICHELLE
pTYLER- WE'RE IN. DOWNEY AND-
ORANGE CAP. THE COURT AT THE
TWO SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
LINE ONE FORTY TWO ONE FOUR TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MARIA ON ONE
FORTY. HELLO. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. THERE ARE I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THE THAT GOT WANTED A MISTAKE
WORKERS BECAUSE AND- I HAVE.
WHAT WORK AFTER FIVE YEARS AND
I AT THE TOP OF THE SENATE
THANK. THANK YOU. THIS LINE IN
A STRUCTURE. WHAT LINE ONE
ELEVEN YEAR OLD. I'M SORRY LINE
ONE ONE ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
LINE ONE ELEVEN I GOTTA START
OVER. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARIA LAMB AND I'M A MEMBER
OF AT THE ARE YOU A LOCAL
TWENTY FIFTEEN. AND THAT HELPED
A WARRANT. EVEN I ALL UP AND
SHARE NAY I PUT THE SB SEVENTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I AM
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN A
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE SEVENTY SIX ONE SEVEN SIX
GO AHEAD. QUESTION. I'M SORRY
CALLER ONLINE ONE SEVENTY SIX.
CREATOR. GO TO LINE ONE FIVE
NINE ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SORRY LINE ONE FIVE NINE
OR YOU WANT ME. THE MOVE ON THE
LINE FIFTY SIX FIVE SIX YOUR
LINE OPEN. I MARIA ISABEL GREAT
YEAH RECORD THE PEOPLE. ORANGE
COUNTY I OR. AT FIVE THANK YOU.
LINE TO TALK TO TWO ZERO OF THE
NUMBER. NEW IN A LATER. I THINK
THE LAST. THAT'S NOT BUT I KNOW
THAT. IS THAT THE MOST. YOUR
THAT IT SAYS THAT THE HE WAS A
KID THE. ALL AROUND ONE SEVENTY
ONE ARE YOU I MEAN. MOVED ALONG
TWENTY TWO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS. WELL I
HAVE A- NUMBER. I AM A MEDICAL
ASSISTANT I HAVE IT RIGHT.
RIGHT I THINK THEY- AND I AM A.
THANK YOU. IN OUR FINAL COMMENT
IN ORDER STREAMLINED TWO FOUR
TWO AND TWO FORTY TWO. YEAH
THANK YOU CAN. REMEMBER MY NAME
IS THE CALIFORNIA ADVOCATE
ADVOCATING FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE HELD BETTER. ALTHOUGH
WE SUPPORT THE NEED FOR HELP
THAT AT ALL BUT YOU'RE ADEQUATE
YOU LOOK AT THE SEVENTY. CREDIT
FOR NOT RECOGNIZING THE I'LL
JUST NEED TO HELP BETTER AND
WITH BEST ON OUR HELP. ON DID
BILLION CASE MICHAEL THE PATH
THIRTY OUTLOOK FOR CONTINUED
BATTLE. BONTA THE BILL AND THAT
REFER THE FIRST OF DELIVERY BUT
SOME IF THANK YOU. MODERATOR
LETTER THE COMIC THIS AUDIT
OKAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SO
THAT'S A ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT
THIS MONDAY MISSION TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION KATHERINE'S THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL POSITION BY
PHONE. AND THE FIRST LETTER ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA SO XIN OF
HEALTH FACILITIES SO BY ONE AND
EACH WILL HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CAPITAL WITHOUT. THE STATION
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME AND WE
ARE OPPOSE THEM LEFT AMENDED TO
THE BILL- I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THE WORK WE HAVE BEEN DOING
WITH. THERE'S AN I WORK IN.
NOTHING IS MORE IMPORTANT IN
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
WORKERS AND PENSION THE
PROVISION OF ENOUGH FEED ALL.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF DESIRE OR
BUDGET BUT THE REALITY OF THE
MARKET. THE CARD WITH THE TO
THINK YOU'RE MORE FOR THE QUICK
MEANT FOR FRONTLINE CARE GIVERS
DURING. OUR. HE'S BEEN
FRACTURING SHORTAGES MOUNTAIN
BIKES AND DEMAND AN EXPONENTIAL
THE HIGHER UTILIZATION. THE
SHORTAGE DID MEAN IT DOES MEAN
THE HAWKS WILL ALLOCATE PEOPLE
BASED WORKERS WHO FACE THE
HIGHEST RISK IN THE WHL THE-
AND KILEY SHOULD BY THEN. THERE
ARE SOME PLACES WHERE WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THE
AUTHORS OF THE CELL AND FOR THE
CONTINUING THAT WORK TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS. AND THAT INCLUDES
BACK. AREN'T RELATED TO THE
NEED FOR SOME LEVEL OF
AVAILABLE PPD INVENTORY WITH
BIRTH AND- WORK THREE AT.
ORCHARD AB TWO LOOK AT HEALTH
CARE WHERE LABOR ACTS. WHAT
TOGETHER TO DETERMINE THE.
EIGHT L. IS THE PART TWO INCH
THE- NEEDED TO. ACQUIRE SHOULD
THAT THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ONE A
DOCTOR. WHEN THEY AND OF. AGAIN
COUPLE OF IT THANK YOU IT OUR
CONCERN OF OURS THAT REMAIN IN
THAT IS RELATED TO TIME WE- I'M
TO MEET THE ONE TWENTY TWO.
NINE AND I WOULD INTO THE ON
HEALTH CAREERS. THE RAMP.
DURING AND THAT MIGHT THIS WILL
INCREDIBLE STE ON THE CHAIN. IN
TRADE THE BILL THE CREDIBILITY
OF RESOURCES. ALL FRONTLINE.
ADDITIONALLY WE THAT THERE TO
BE MORE. TO TALK WORK WORK ON
BEFORE THE REGULATIONS WERE
DROPPED KING OF OUR AND WE'RE-
FROM. THE REQUIREMENTS. KEEPING
OUT OF STOCK. IN A DAY WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE AND BY THAT HE
FORTY OVERSEE OF HOSPITAL CAN
BELIEVE DIRECTLY AND THERE WERE
ON I GOT KERN AND OUT GAVE THAT
OVERSIGHT AND OF COURSE AND
FIFTY FOR IRONMAN. THANK YOU.
WELL. FOR A IT WILL BE
IMPORTANT FOR TURN. THE AND
WE'VE WAITED AT AND AGAIN OUR
THAT. SHOULD BE HI OR THE P.
INVENTORY BECAUSE BY THE HOUSE
WORKS IN LAS WE THINK ABOUT THE
FINE I WE ARE CAN THAT IF WE
DON'T SPECIFIC ACROSS THE
ABILITY FOR I'M AND THE BILL
WOULD BE PROVIDE MUTUAL OTHER
BOOKS. AS WE ADDRESS THE BILL
WELL YEAH THANK YOU. IT SAYS
SNYDER YOUR CARE NUMBERS YEAH
HI THIS IS JENNIFER SLATER NAPA
CALIFORNIA CITY TO HELP
FACILITIES THAT WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER NOT GO. YEAH
BEFORE. FIFTY INTO. FOR THE
DISABLED AND CAP HAS OPPOSED TO
MY THAN THAT THIS ON YOUTH FIVE
LET ME SAY THAT WE GREATLY THAT
PART DIALOGUE WITH WITH ALL.
BOXER. THE LAST. DR I'VE DONE
AND CURING THE NAY PROTECTIVE
COULD FOR HELP WORKERS
APPRECIATED THAT PARTNERS AND
SOME AND LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONTINUE PARTNERSHIP THIS HAS
BEEN AND I'M QUITE PANDEMIC AT
FOR OUR- THESE. DOCTOR YEAH.
FROM THE WHAT THE AUTHOR IN THE
BOX EXCHANGE WORK VERY MUCH
MORE WELCOME OF ANOTHER A THE
FUTURE BUT WE DO HAVE A FOUR
REMAINING KEY CONCERN WE BY TO
CONTROL TO WORK WITH THAT JAPAN
AND THAT'S YEAH YOU. BECAUSE
THAT THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT IT WOULD BE ABOUT ONE
MILLION OR FOR HER FACILITY AND
WITH THE CORNER KIND EXTENDED
YOU EIGHT OUTSIDE STORY SO WE
EXPERT WILLINGNESS TO LOOK
THIRTY IS THAT SOMETHING WE
BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE TO FOR
REAL AT. HANDLE AND CHAIN AND
STATE. AND THEN. A SECOND RD.
THANK HAVE AN PROVIDED TERM
CARE RESIDENTS THEM WITH A
STICK THAT HOW. WE DON'T
BELIEVE SHOULD BE TO THE
REQUIRED THE BILL THAT CAN'T WE
BELIEVE. THE REQUIREMENTS THE
P. T. L. OCCUR AFTER. THAT MAKE
THEM IT SHOULD. GOVERNOR
HEALTHCARE NOW THIRTY CHALLENGE
CURRENTLY SHOULD BE WE ARE
CONTRA Q. CONTRA ON THIRD HE
COLDER PROCESS OUTLINED IN BILL
SHOULD BANDIT AND PROCESS ALONG.
HELP THAT. WELL REQUIREMENTS
BASED ON WHAT WE- THAT AND THEN
LASTLY THERE SHOULD BE A
RIPOSTE I THINK A ROBUST STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO PP BY
HEALTHCARE FIRST I WITHOUT THAT.
NURSING HOMES OR NOT BE
SUCCESSFUL THEIR STAFF AND OUR
PATIENTS AT THE SEVEN FIVE OF
THESE IMPORTANT ALLEN OKAY BUT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT
LANGUAGE. THE LAST ONE JUST
TOOK WORK PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OFTEN
SPONSOR AND KNOWING THAT
THERE'S MANY DETAILS THAT WE
MUST WORK OUT BEFORE SURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WELL TO PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
THOSE OPPOSED AGAIN TO STATE
YOUR NAME ONLY ASIAN A POSITION
ON THE BILL LET'S START WITH IN
THE ROOM IS RIGHT WHEN THE
WRITTEN THOUGHT TAKEN OPPOSITE.
ANYONE IN THE REMOTE. STATION
AND FINALLY FAR BETTER. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE. THANK YOU AS A
REMINDER ME PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
LEGISLATION WILL START WITH THE
ONE THIRTEEN ONE THREE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU OWN ON BEHALF
OF THE- EIGHT TEN IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY EIGHT TO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHURCH MEMBERS
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORUM WITHIN OPPOSED AND THAT
THE BEST THING. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE. ONE FIVE TWO YOUR- HI
MOLLY RIGHT IN WITH MY PARENTS
HAD A PHILLY AT THE CALIFORNIA
WE ARE NOT MANDATE. AND REALLY.
LINE. TWO THIRTY FOUR TWO THREE
FOUR AIRLINERS OPEN. SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE BAND THE CULT
NUMBER ONE THE UNIVERSITY
HEALTH OF THE ALLIES THE
CATHOLIC CARE IN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED BECAUSE. THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION- AND THEN
OPPOSE A LOT MANDATE BECAUSE
THEY SHARE AND Q. PRIMARILY
REMOVE THE PROVIDER MANDATES
AND CREATE A STATE IN GROUP
PURCHASING OUR- LOOK FOR IT YOU
CAN OUR ON THOSE ISSUES OF THE
AUTHOR AND. ONE HE NINE. BILL
THERE ARE MORE HELPFUL
CHILDREN'S ASIAN AND WE WENT
ONLINE OUR CONCERN THAT
HOSPITAL THE AND YOU THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY THREE ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PRICE
DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF THE CAL.
SURGERIES LOCATION. WE LEGENDS
BOTH ONCE AGAIN. WHILE THE
COMMITTEE NOT GOING. THANK YOU.
NINE SIX NINE SIX NINE ALIGN
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE DIDN'T INVOLVE
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S POSITION
GROUPS AND WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSING LOS MINUTE XIN
ASSOCIATE ARE CALM WITH OTHER
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. THANK NEXT WEEK MY
TWENTY SIX TO FIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CAME TO BE A
PHYSICIAN A CALIFORNIA OKAY
DISTRICT OF. AMENDED FOR IT
THERE A REASON BASED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIND TO BE TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER THREE
ANDERSON WITH THE ARK AND UCBCP
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSMAN WE DO
NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL
AT THE TIME THAT THE- ONE.
WE'VE OFFER TOP FOR WORKING
WITH THE PHONE. THAT INCLUDING
THE ACT PROFESSIONAL FOR PEOPLE
IBD- THANKS AGAIN FOR- LOOKING
AT THIS MOMENT. THANK YOU. FINE
TO SEVENTY ONE TO SEE ON YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PETER TELEVISION
BEHALF CAL. ATION FOR HEALTH
SERVICES AT HOME THEY HAVE AN
UP CLOSE LOOK PROJECTS NOT IS
THE TO THE CAN. THE CONCERNS
PARALLEL THOSE PREVIOUSLY X.
THANK YOU. AND FINALLY LINE ONE
NINETY THREE ONE NINE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GERMAN NOT
BACKWARD BEGINNING THE OPTIC
ABOUT THE POSITIONS OF SURGEONS
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO HAVE AN
ABOVE LEFT. IN THAT POSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q.
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL THE COMMENTS AND FROM
THE TESTIMONY WILL BRING ABOUT.
THE COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR MOTIONS YES
AMERICA RIO. MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU THINK OF A COMMON
QUESTION. THANK DOCTOR PAN I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE- LIKE THE
TO ANCHOR BILL MONTHLY WHO IS-
ON THE CALL IN THE VERY
BEGINNING OF PRESIDENT OF
HIGHLAND PARK HOUSE EIGHT
LITTLE A SIMILAR. AMOUNT ONLY
ESPANOL IT UP FOR YOU BUT IT.
GET OTHER FOR BUT IMPORTANT
THAT. IN ANOTHER THEY WOULD
ELICIT ON A THAT THE LOT THAT
BUT THE SEA BUT AND DEMOCRATS
THE STUFF. I DO QUESTION FOR
YOU DOESN'T THE A POINT OF FOR
IN. ON THE LOW THE FINE. HE IS
THE- BELL FOR LATE INNING UP.
THIS IS A THINK THE QUESTION
THE ALL OF US WITH IN TRYING
TO. ONE THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
THROUGH THE BACK OF THE CASE
ACROSS STATE THAT AT ARMS ARE
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
FRONTLINE STAFF IN WAY. AND
WOULD LOVE SOME FOR US
DIFFERENCE OF. DATES BE TO
NINETY FIVE SURGICAL MASKS AND
WHAT IS OFFICE IN WHICH- WE CAN
THINK ABOUT ONCE WE GET CLOSER
TO OPERATION EIGHT. HASN'T USED.
WILL IT THEN BE ROUTED OR USE
THAT WE'RE NOT UP. TALKING UP
TO SUPPLY MAY POTENTIALLY USE.
I THOUGHT THAT THANKS MUCH OF%
ONE FOR THAT C<c.cyan>. IT'S A THE</c>
THIS MODEL THAT ACTUAL DAY BASE
ON WHAT HAPPENED AND WHAT WE
FOUND OUT WHAT TIME WHAT WAS
FOUND THAT. THAT THEY SEE WHAT.
WASN'T NO WAY BUT WHAT A
FIGURED OUT WAS IS THAT WHAT
YOU DO IS YOU HAVE TO BE COMING
EN ROUTE YOU PER. SH FOR TIME
AND YOU MOVE AT. AND WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE DIFFERENT PP IN
WHAT EXPIRED. I MEAN IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT PERISHABLE ITEM LIKE
FOOD SO OF THREE AMPLE THE
PLASTICS ON THE AND FIVE. THAT
YEAH JUST WHERE THE END AND IT.
AND IT AND WEEKS OR SOME I CAN
WEAR A WHILE SO THE IDEA IS
THAT YOU WOULD BE ACTUALLY
PURCHASED PP. YOU'RE GOING TO
STAY AND THEN YOU MOVE OUT THE-
LIST BARBARA STILL NOT EXT. IT
THE OTHER WERE LOW WELL IF HE
HAVE TO HAVE A SPACE ON WHAT
YOU CURRENTLY USING SO WE'RE
NOT EXPECT PEOPLE TO PP. THAT
THE NORMALLY YOU ANYWAY
BASICALLY EVENTUALLY WHAT
HAPPENS YES YOU DO HAVE TO
BUILD A STOCKPILE BUT THEN
EVENTUALLY WHAT HAPPENED HE
COMING. GOING OUT AND SO IT'S
NOT ASIDE FROM THE STORAGE. WE
SHOULD FACILITIES ARE READY TO
RIGHT NOW. CURRENT TV THE
PROBLEM WE RAN INTO IT THAT
BECAUSE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
STOCKPILES WHEN YOU'RE- WHEN
THE SUPPLY COLLAPSES ENOUGH.
NOT BRING THINGS IN. THEN NO
ONE HAS ANYTHING. LEARNED AND
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID OKAY EVERY
HOSPITAL IT FEELS WILL HAVE TO
HAVE YOUR LIFE BY THE TIME SO
YOU'RE NOT PANIC. JUST CAN'T
GET YOUR EVERY TRYING TO
SUPPLY. IS THE TOP FOR THE
ELITE STILL PROVIDE THE
PROTECTION WE DON'T HAVE TO
PANIC BUYING WE DON'T HAVE
BOTH. MORE SO I CAN RUN A LOT
OF LESSONS LEARNED FROM.
WORKERS THAT I'VE SPOKE WITH
ASKED. HOT HAD. PULLED OF P. BY.%
I WAS MAKING SURE THAT THAT
SUPPLY WAS BEING DISTRIBUTED.
WHATEVER LENGTH OF TIME AND YOU
KNOW HAVING. AND THAT MOVE AND
SO I THINK NOT ONLY WAS THERE
SHORTAGE BUT THOSE THAT DIDN'T
HAVE A SHORTAGE COULDN'T USE UP
AVAILABLE. WHICH THEN WE
THOUGHT YOU KNOW NURSES. TRASH
BAG UNIFORMS AND IS THE YOU
KNOW AN UNFORTUNATE THING THAT
WE ARE AT THE WE ARE SEEN- SO I
WAS JUST CURIOUS AS TO HOW LONG
AND TYPE OF P. CAN BE STORED
AND WHAT WOULD THAT PROP LOOK
LIKE THE NET YEAH YOU CAN DO IT
SMARTER LIKE FOCUSED. PP THAT
FOR A WHILE SUMMIT AND WE
SHOULD THINK. MAINTAIN A SUPPLY
THAT ACTUALLY WITH ANIMAL COPS.
THAT THEN ALSO CANCEL BE SURE
TO BE RE REPRESSION REPLENISH
THE SUPPLY. AT ALL THERE IS
THAT IT THINGS ARE JUST EXPERT.
THANK YOU. THIRTY COMMENT
SUBMERGENCE LATER YES IN A AND
I WON THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IN AND- A DEADLY
GUNS. GOING TO SUPPORT BY THIS
BILL AND- WHAT WHAT I REALLY
AM. EXCITED ABOUT IS NOT
NECESSARY TO WHO DID WHAT TO
WEAR OR EVEN THE WIND BUT WE
REALLY NEED TO HAVE A SERIOUS
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE HOUSE.
RIGHT AND A NIGHT IN DEATH BUT
I MIGHT BE ABLE TO HELP NINE
NINE THAT WOULD SUGGEST THAT
YOU WOULD. LIST SOME OF MY HELP
I JUST BE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS COORDINATOR FOR
THE CITY OF LA. I WAS INVOLVED
IN THE JUST EXCISED SANDBAGS
OKAY THAT WE NEEDED FOR FLOOD
NOW WE HAVEN'T HAD A FLOOD. IN
QUITE SOME TIME IT'LL SAM SAID
I. KEPT IN KEY NO I WOULD
NINETEEN NINETY. PROBABLY
AREN'T ANY. DON'T MOVE THEM OUT.
AND RESUPPLY. AND SO IT'S
REALLY ABOUT CREATING HOLD.
CHAIN SYSTEM GOING STORAGE BUT
WHAT I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN
IS THE- IN STATE MANUFACTURE IT
AND YOU KNOW I THE MANUFACTURER
IN MY DISTRICT RIGHT NOW WHICH
IS NOT A VERY GOOD. FACTOR TO
GETTING BETTER NOW AND IT
PULLED IT OUT. DOING WELL BUT
TO THEY SAY THE DATE GONE FROM
DOING CLOTHING TO A MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF. A MASS A
MONTH- THAT'S IN MY DISTRICT SO
THINK ABOUT THAT YEAH MY
CLINICS. WHICH DIDN'T HAVE ANY
SUPPORT WHATSOEVER WHEN IT
COMES TO PP. LEAST THEY COULD
BE PROVIDED IN MY DISTRICT WITH
ENOUGH MASS AND WILL PROBABLY
ALSO COULD HAVE A CHANCE TO.
PROBABLY UNIONIZE A LOT OF
MANUFACTURING IN MY DISTRICT
WHICH PROBABLY WOULD ALSO HELP
WITH MAKING SURE THOSE PEOPLE
AT WORK IT INTO. ADDRESS IT. SO
DAY I'M LOOKING AT HOW. THE
STATE. PRODUCED TO THE PPVS
THAT WE NEED SO WE DON'T HAVE
TO GO OUT OF STATE OR OUT OF
THE COUNTRY TO DEPEND ON THAT
WE DO IT INTERNALLY AND AUTUMN
THE USER RESOURCE THE MONEY IN
THE STATE OF GUITAR WILL WORK
WE DO NOT. STOCK WE DO NOT KEEP
A STOCKPILE OF PLANES WE TURN
FORD AND THE OTHER INDUSTRIES
AND TO TANK MAKING THINGS TO
FOR IN A MAJOR WAR A RAMP UP
AND SO WE SHOULD BE DOING AT
THE SAME HERE WITH PPVS AND I
WOULD LOVE WITH YOU ON HOW WEAK
IN TURN. GREAT JOB. TOPIC WHEN
THE BUT IMPORTANT UP WE CREATE
A SYSTEM WHERE WE BECOME SELF
SUFFICIENT AT THE END OF THE
DAY AND WE DON'T HAVE TO RELY
ON IDAHO ALABAMA OR SOME OTHER
STATE- TO REPLENISH OUR OURS.
ALSO A GREAT. IS A BOND YOU
MOVE THAT STUFF OUT TO THE DOES
BECOME PERISHABLE BAND WAS LEFT
PANDEMIC IN THE TWENTIES.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY SO THE
NEXT ONE IS NOT UNTIL TWENTY
ONE EIGHTEEN I WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE READY BY NOW WITH THE
AROUND BUT I'M GONNA MAKE SURE
WHERE. TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN THAT
WE'RE- THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN THE
FUTURE- ARE ABLE TO DEAL WITH
IT COULD BE MUCH WORSE FIFTY
YEARS FROM NOW TWENTY YEARS. WE
DO WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO BE
SELF. IF ANY THING I CAN DO TO
HELP WITH THAT WOULD BE CORRECT.
THANK THANK MISTRUST BECAUSE
SOMEONE NEAR SANDBAGS HE- SAID.
THE CENTER DOES ALL. GEN CON.
OUR SERVICE. WHAT IT WAS I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL THE COMMENTS
AND DR GRANT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE BILL IT WAS MENTIONED-
SUMMARY WE GET BILL. IN ARENA
EARLIER AND HAVE A CHANCE TO
BEAT HIM AND I KNOW YOU'RE BOTH
WORK CLOSELY. TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE WORKING IN CALL AS
COMPLEMENTARY. GOALS BUT MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY I APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT YOU AND WITH MY
STAFF. ON THIS- AND WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF CONVERSATION I KNOW THE
SPONSORS. IN A UP. FOR MAKE
SURE THAT. ALL THE AS A MEMBER
OF THE BOARD. IN THE NIGHT WE
DON'T WHEN WE'RE GONNA BE THANK
AT THE SAME TIME WHATEVER NEXT
ONE TIME TO BOTH. SO I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU AN END TO ALL
STAKEHOLDER TO PUT A LOT OF
TIME IN TWO YEARS WHERE WE ARE-
TODAY ON THIS AND YOU SAID IT'S
A REALLY A MATTER ENSURE
PREPARED. AND YOU DON'T PAY
ALSO SHOULD MAKE A TORY IS A
LARGE IN ORDER TO BE INTO IS
GOING BE ONE OR THE OTHER. THE
YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHEN WE'RE GONNA NEED IT NEXT
BUT WE KNOW WE NEED IT NOW AND
SO THAT'S WHAT IS IMPORTANT
BALANCE I APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS ON THIS- AND I DO HAVE
A THE DUKAN. RATIONS
RECOMMENDATION. PLEASE ENTER
PAN. YOU CHAIR KARA AND AGAIN I
WANT YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME AS WELL AS MANY
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS I REALLY
APPRECIATE SOME MEMBER DON'T
SLAYERS EXPERTISE I'M GONNA
LOOK TALKS MORE. TRYING GET A
AS THE MARKET. AS WELL SO THAT
WE WOULD HAVE ANY FOR. HERE AND
CAL. RECOGNIZING THAT IN THE
PANDEMIC OF THIS SIZE. NO
MATTER WHAT WE DO THAT I MEAN
THIS THAT WE WOULD IF WE HAD
THIS READY IN PLACE WE RUNS A
SUPPLY THE WILL BOB VALUABLE
TIME. THAT'S WHAT. IS A GOOD
TIME. TAMPA BAY. DUCKS AND WITH
THAT EXISTING YOU CAN DO YOU
YOU DON'T YOU ARE DON'T HAVE
CAN. SAYING SO THAT ACTUALLY
STABLE THE KID FROM. GETTING
PRESENT AT. AROUND IN ANY YEAH
BACK. ALL SORTS OF. OTHER
PROBLEMS AND AS WELL SO THAT.
MEASURE WOULD HOUSE BE BETTER
RESPONSE I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
WHAT I SAID LEARN. SEE I'M NOT
ACTED THE LAST PANDEMIC THE
LAST REALLY LARGE WILL NINETEEN
BUT WE'VE HAD OTHER HELP RIGHT.
AND DEMI RIGHT. YOU KNOW IT
AGING N. ONE THING. IT'S NOT
LIKE THE THINGS JUST GONNA BE
SEE THERE FOR A WHOLE SO IN WE
WON'T BE IT I AM VERY THAT WILL
HAVE ONE WERE AGAIN THIS WAY
HELP STABLE UP THE- SIR.
BECAUSE OF IT A BREAK OF SOME
DISEASE. AND SEE WHAT. ACTUALLY
IS BOTH. THE WORKERS OF ITS
WE'RE DOING THIS BILL BUT ALL
OF WITH ACTUAL I THINK MAKE OUR
STATE OF RESPONSIVE AND SAY FOR
EVER AND MAKE THAT CARE IT
MARKS A IN THE THAT AGAIN
REALLY PAY THAT THAT WORK AND
WE'RE GOING TO WORK WITH THE
STATE. AND I STRICTLY AS NOT
FOUR NINE BEHALF MYSELF MY ARE
COUNTY. VERY MUCH TWO OF THEM
ON THE- WELCOME CAN YOU
REMEMBER IS ALL. GONZALES
GONZALES I JONES SAWYER BY
JONES SAWYER HI THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I. GOOD GREAT THE
BILL IS PASSED TO- THE TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU DOCTOR
PAN. THANK YOU. BUT NIXON PILE.
ORDER IS SB SEVEN TWENTY NINE
CENTER PORTANTINO. OKAY THANK.
AND SO- YES THE SENATOR
PORTANTINO WHATEVER WHEN YOU'RE
READY MY- FOR MY DAUGHTER MY
DAUGHTER TOOK THE CLIPPERS TO
ME AND- SAID SHE DIDN'T ENJOY
IT CHECK THE GLEAMING ARRIVE.
WHEN SHE WAS DOING. CHAIRED IS
GOOD TO BE HERE THANK YOU
PRESENTING AT S. B. SEVEN
TWENTY NINE- WHICH WILL PROVIDE
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL FOOD
WORKERS SB SEVEN TWENTY NINE.
ESTABLISHES COVERT NINETEEN
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
FOR FOOD SECTOR WORKERS FOR THE
DURATION OF ANY LOCAL EMERGENCY
OR STATE OF EMERGENCY. RELIEF
OR CLAIMED UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
AGENCY SERVICES ACT AT SEVEN
TWENTY NINE ALSO PERMITS FOOD
SECTOR PLEASE TO WATCH HEY IS
EVERY THIRTY MINUTES SAYS SO
SIMPLE BUT VERY IMPORTANT. I'M
FOR DINNER THE CLEAREST
EMERGENCY OR TOBIN NINETEENTH.
FEDERAL ON MARCH EIGHTEENTH
PASSED THE FAMILIES FIRST.
PROVIDE RESPONSE ACT WHICH
REQUIRED PUBLIC IN OVER SECOND
PLACE WITH LESS THAN FIVE
HUNDRED POLICE. RIGHT UP TO WE.
SOME PAID LEAVE. HOWEVER IT
FAILED TO IN PLEASE EMPLOYER
AND APPLY FIVE HUNDRED OR MORE
WORKERS LEAVING THESE WORKERS
ARE PROTECTED GOVERNOR NEWSOME
ISSUED EXECUTIVE ORDER- AND
FIFTY ONE DASH TWENTY CLOSE THE
GAP IN COVERAGE FOR TO WORKERS
BY PROVIDING PROVIDING UP TO
TWO WEEKS COUPLE MENTAL
QUARANTINE LEAVE. RELATED
ILLNESS OR QUARANTINE BE SPENT
TWENTY NINE ESSENTIALLY WOULD
CODIFY THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER AS WE OWE A TREMENDOUS
I'M GOING RISK OF FOODS
WORKERS- LEVEL. IN GROCERY
STORES MEET PLANTS FOOD
PROCESSING FACILITIES FOOD
DELIVERY AGRICULTURE ALL KEEP
WORKING EVEN WHEN ALMOST EVERY
OTHER BUSINESS WAS ORDERED TO
CLOSE. PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL
PAID LEAVE NOT ALLOWING. THOSE
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
SACRIFICES BUT IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE FOOD HANDLING WORKERS
WHO ARE SICK ARE AND CONTAGIOUS
DO NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN.
A PROPER QUARANTINE AND GOING
TO WORK ACT TWENTY WORK HAPPEN
ON THE LINE SINCE START.
THROUGHOUT THE FORTY. RIGHT IN
RATES IN THE FOOD SYSTEM ARE
JUST BROKE THE AFFECTING RURAL
AND LATINO CAN. ROGUE COMMUNITY
WITH ME PLANTS HAVE AN
INFECTION RATE THAT IS FIVE
TIMES HIGHER ON AVERAGE THAN
INCOMPATIBLE SITUATIONS. SO THE
ACTED THE EXECUTIVE ORDER-
DOESN'T HAVE THE FORCE OF STAT
OR REGULATION AND SO THE STAKES.
TO RECTIFY THAT AND I KNOW WHAT
WE HAVE A PEOPLE ON THE LINE
FROM UFC DOUBLE JUST. GREW WALL
IN CUSTOM I THINK ARE ALSO HERE
TO. FOR SOME SPORTING CUSTOM.
Q. THANK YOU SENATOR. SO ONCE
AGAIN IT A EACH WAY OF BOTH IN
SUPPORT AND THEN THERE'S SOME
NOT WILL BE ABOUT TWO MINUTES
EACH HOUSE LITTLE LUCY GOOSEY
LAST TIME AND DIDN'T JUMP IN
TO- REMIND THEM THE FOLKS ARE
WHINING THIS TIME IT CLOSER TO
THE IT'S ALL JUST A QUICK
REMINDER TO. THE WHITE. GOOD TO
KEEP HERE. HEARING AND SO YEAH
YOU HAVE A JUST A GREAT OF YES
W. INCHING DUSTIN'S PLEASE
MEMBERS GET UP GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS MY NAME AT THAT THE
GREAT WALL AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN
STATES COUNT. YET THE W.
REPRESENT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS AND THE FOOD SUPPLY
CHAIN IN CALIFORNIA. WORKERS
BUT ON THE FRONT LINES AND
STARTED THAT PANDEMIC OFTEN
WITHOUT ADEQUATE PP. WHAT THE
THINKING BY BIRTH AND QUITE.
CENTER THAT CALIFORNIANS ACROSS
THE STATE ARE ABLE TO FEED
THEIR FAMILIES AND KEEP THE
REFRIGERATOR FALL. HOWEVER THAT
DOES NOT COME WITHOUT COST IN
HUMAN SUFFERING. NINETEEN HAD
THE AND BRED AMONG WORKERS. ARE
WORKERS WORKERS ON FARM. AND
WORK. NUMEROUS BUT HOW PARKS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR THE
RECORD IN THAT A LIFE OR DEATH
PERIL AND JEOPARDIZING RELIED
OF THE TEN ADDED FELLOW THAT
RED FACED WORKERS AND MARKETING
BETTER IF THAT'LL GETTING WERE.
RISING UP RIGHT I'M RIGHT THEN
I THINK THAT'S OUR DIFFERENT.
AFFECTING AND MY NEXT. THIS IS
WHY ARE HERE SUPPORT PRESS
THINK THAT. I SEVEN THANK THEM
PLAY CODIFY THE- APRIL IS THE
OR- WHICH PROVIDE COUPLE. PAID
SICK LEAVE FEEDBACK WORKER I
CAN BUT HUNDRED OR MORE AND-
YOU THAT THE L. STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT THAT YOU HAVE THAT.
DOES NOT SIMPLY AND ONE STATE
ORDER. I THAT LARGE SITE THE
BUYER CAN QUICKLY SPREAD I'M
THE WORK FOR. BUT IF I. OR FROM
AT THE BROAD FOX COMPLY AND A-
ETHICALLY. FOR THE FRONT LINES
THE FACT WORKER. THAT MARKED
WHAT CONGRESS AND HAVE GOTTEN.
IT'S PRETTY REASONS WE ARE WE
ARE THERE I BUT I AT SEVENTY
NINE. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY THAT
CAN HAPPEN. THANK MISTER CHAIR
MAY OF THE CAN SHANE GOSH I'LL
BE HOW OF THE CAL TO PUBLIC
AFFAIR COUNT INSTEAD OF THIS
AND BILL OUR MEMBERS WORK
VIRTUALLY EVERY LINK THE FOOD
SUPPLY AND LOOKS LIKE MANY
OTHER WORKERS MAY HAVE BEEN
WORKING. VERY BEGINNING OF THIS
CRISIS. PUT THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES AT RISK TO PUT
FOOD ON OUR TABLE. IT'S A
CRITICAL ENDEAVOR KEEP IN A
REALLY BAD SITUATION FROM
DEVOLVING INTO CHAOS. START WE
REALIZED THAT EMPLOYERS WERE
ILL PREPARED TO KEEP THESE
WORKERS SAY. EARLY ON WE HAD
OUTBREAK HIP SO THESE WITH
NUMBERS OF COVERT NINETEEN
CASES THAT WERE FRANKLY REALLY
SCARY. YET EMPLOYERS AT SOME OF
THE HOT SPOTS CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE IN SOME VERY UNSAFE
BEHAVIOR NO SOCIAL DISTANCING
INADEQUATE P. P. EVEN GET PLAN
FOR TAKE TIME OFF TO WHERE
WASHING AND OR EVEN WORKERS WHO
WANTED TO TAKE TIME OFF WHEN
THEY FOR FEELING SICK OR AT
CENTER. THESE TYPES OF THINGS
LED TO THE RAPID SPREAD OF KOBE
TO IN SOME WORKPLACES. AND
THANKFULLY IN RESPONSE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ISSUED THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT. MR
PORTANTINO REFERRED TO. AND IT
WAS VERY HELPFUL VERY MUCH
NEEDED. AND AT THE VERY LEAST
PREVENT WORKERS FROM SUFFERING
ECONOMIC PENALTIES- FOR DOING
THE RIGHT THING AND STAYING
HOME WHEN THEY NEEDED TO.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE FOUND THE
EMPLOYER CONTACT THAT I
MENTIONED CONTINUES. BUT EVEN
NOW AND EVEN IN THE BEST
SCENARIOS THIS DISEASE SEEMS TO
FIND ITS WAY AND SPREAD IN. THE
WORK ENVIRONMENT THAT'S WHY WE
NEED TO PROTECTIONS AND CENTER
PORTANTINO'S BILL AND WHY WE
ARE URGING HERE EITHER TODAY-
THANK YOU. THINK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY SO- WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AGAIN STATE NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
BILL AS OR ANYONE IN THE ROOM.
WILL MOVE ON TO REMOTE TEST I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE KNOWS
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION BUT
THERE IS OF THIS ONE HAD A THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. AND
IF NOT WE'LL GO ON TO OUR
MODERATOR. I DO WE HAVE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. HERE
AGAIN IF YOU AREN'T SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
GET MY FLYING. TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO TWO FIVE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRD CALLER ONLINE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINES OPEN. I AM IN A MEMBERS
MARK SHOCK FOR CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
EIGHTY FIVE TWO EIGHT FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. HI MY NAME IS
SANDRA HERNANDEZ NUMBER OF BIDS
AND HE DOES IT EVEN IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE AMERICAN
MARKET CONDITIONS. AND I HAVE
BEEN WORKING BUT THE MOVE
WORKING. FOR THE LAST THIRTEEN
YEARS AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
IT BEAT OUT FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. BUYING TO NINETY TWO NINE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN TWO
NINE ZERO ARE YOU WANT ME. I
WILL GO ON BLIND TWO EIGHT TWO
ONE TWO EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER SEVEN ENOUGH THAT
IT. REMEMBER THE MECHANICAL NAY
THAT THE REST LIKELY FROM THE
FINAL CUT OTHER THAN ALL THAT
THAT UP AND DOWN THE PATH THAT.
IT BUT IT'S NOT A PHONE NUMBER
THE PUBLIC IS SEVEN BUT THE
THEY GET THEY GET. THAT'S. FIND
SIX NINE TO SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LET THE SIERRA SIERRA.
I'M MEMBER NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WILL GET IT THE
NEED A PARTY WHAT. OUR NUMBER
AND I ALSO MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA OF THE MYSTIC WHAT
THE COALITION. I'M THE MISSING
WORKING A HAVE A HOUSE CLEANING
SOME OUR BABY SITTERS AND I'M
ARE GENERALLY SO FOR I'M VOTE
FOR AIR. FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
WHAT WE'RE HAVING A FOR FOLKS
IN ON SB TWELVE OF SEVEN MUCH
WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING IN A
COUPLE OF BILLS THIS IS FOR SB
SEVEN. TWENTY NINE SO IF
ANYONE'S ON THE LINE- CALL BACK
IN A COUPLE BILLS. UP WHEN WE
GET TO SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN-
THIS IS FOR SB SEVEN TWENTY
NINE BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
UFCW SPONSORED BILL SO PLEASE
MISTER MODERATOR CONTINUE IN
AND HOPEFULLY UP FOLKS GOT THE
MESSAGE AND- AGAIN THIS IS NOT
ON SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN WE DID
GET SOME OF YOUR COMMENTS ON
IT. BUT IF YOU CAN NOW CALL
BACK AT THE BILL'S UP YES
AMERICANS US. PERHAPS I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY HAVE BILINGUAL
HELP ON THE LINE BUT WE MAY
WANT TO REPEAT THAT IN SPANISH.
SOMEONE MAY WANT TO REPEAT.
SURE SOMEONE HELP ME OUT IT IS.
YES BUT I CAN REPEAT IT MANAGED.
OKAY ONE WHOEVER WHO SAID. OKAY
OR NOT BUT I WILL NOT CAN TAKE
IT DONNA BUT ON NOT A LOT OF
THE NHà BUT AS I FOUGHT FOR
YOU'LL ALLOW BUT IT THEY LAY
THEY SAID THEY WILL HANDLE WHEN
THEY YES THEY- I WANNA KNOW
SOMEONE FOR THAT IS. AND UNDER
THE BED AND THEY ARE GET
THEY'RE BUILT AS A LIKELY YOUNG
A THOUGHT AND DEMO AT THE BAY.
ALTHOUGH THINK OF THAT THE
LAFAYETTE. THE. HOME WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE TO NINETY SEVEN NINE
TWO NINE SEVEN YOUR MIND OF THE.
OKAY WELL GO ON TO LINE TO
NINETY NINE TWO TWO NINE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. REMEMBER
THERE ARE STOCKS CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT SB
SEVEN TWENTY NINE PORTANTINO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT BILL
FROM. CONTACT TIME TO SIXTY ONE
TWO SIX ONE YOUR LINE OF THE
OPEN. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JESSICA MARKKULA WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT AND IT DOES
THAT ARE YOU TWO NINE BY
SENATOR PART. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE THREE OH THREE THREE
HUNDRED THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH MARKET
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM IN SUPPORT OF
AT THE SEVEN TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE NINETEEN
ONE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
NINETEEN DID YOU HAVE A-
SUPPORT POSITION ON THIS
LEGISLATION. BONTA LINE THREE
OH ONE THREE OH ONE FOOTBALL AT.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN ANTS GO
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TO
NINE. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY TWO
FOUR TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THEY ARE ON THE OF THE COW
EMPLOYMENT WILL THIS IS AND-
THANK YOU. BOTTOM LINE TO FORTY
THREE ONE TWO FOUR THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN IF WE LOSE THE
FORCE OF MY CONNECTING ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHT I IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE THREE
OH EIGHT THREE ZERO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT A BAYARDO AT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE THREE
TEN THREE ONE ZERO YOUR INE IS
OPEN. ON TO OUR FINAL LINUS
LINE ONE EIGHT ZERO ONE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MARK AS
WITH WORK BASED IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MR SURE WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER LINE BACK IN Q. WITH
LINE THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SEVEN MEN
CAN WITH LIKE THE KERR PRODUCT.
IN SUPPORT AT SB SEVEN TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU. NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. AT THIS TIME OKAY
GREAT- LET'S MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION A SET OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY NINE WITH CAMERON
DMITRIEVA TECHNET FOLLOWED BY
THE TWO CIGARS HERE WITH THE
GHOST ASSOCIATION AGAIN KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES IF
YOU SOLVE TIME AS WELL EASIER
THAN- ME INTERRUPTING YOU SO
PLEASE- LET'S GO AHEAD THAT MR
MAJOR. AND SHARE KALRA MEMBERS
CAN INDIVIDUALLY WITH TEKE.
TECHNO HAS AN OPPOSING LESS
AMENDED POSITION ON SB SEVEN
TWENTY NINE. WELL WE APPRECIATE
AGREED WITH THE CALL OCTOR TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
WORKERS DURING THIS DIFFICULT
TIME. WE HAVE A FEW REMAINING
CAN CHANGE AT THE BILL. CHECK
THE BEGINNING OF THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC OUR COMPANIES
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO WORKERS. ALTHOUGH
THESE PROGRAMS VARY FROM
COMPANY TO COMPANY. MOST ARE
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN THAT WELL
THAT WAS REQUIRED THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER.
NONETHELESS WE BELIEVE SB SEVEN
TWENTY NINE COULD BE ENHANCED
BY INCORPORATING INDUSTRY AND
PUT. THE ECONOMIC REALITIES OF
HOW OUR BUSINESSES OPERATE. BY
THE BILL IS INTENDED TO PUT
INTO STATUTE GOVERNING
HOUSTON'S EXECUTIVE ORDER. IT
IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
THAT YEAH WASN'T DRAFTED TO
REFLECT THE NEW ON THE
DELIVERY. DRIVER WORK SUCH AS
BEING ABLE TO WORK ON. PLATFORM.
SIMULTANEOUSLY FIRST YOU TO
INCLUDE DAYS AGO. CRITERIA
DESIGN ENSURE. AND PREVENT
PROJECT BEHAVIOR. OUR PLATFORMS
ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO QUICKLY
SIGN UP AND BEGIN WORKING AS
DRIVERS WHICH IS MADE THEN. THE
USEFUL TOOL FOR PEOPLE TRYING
TO FIND INCOME DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WELL WE ARE PROUD OF
IT'S READILY AVAILABLE ACCESS
INCOME FOR CURRENT AND
PROSPECTIVE WORKERS. WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT.
BUT ALSO. MAKE TYPICAL
EMPLOYMENT BASED LIKE. OKAY.
SEVEN TWENTY AND- PERFECT FOR
THE PLATFORM. CURRENTLY THE
BILL WOULD ALLOW WORKERS SIGNED
THE CONTRACT HOURS CHRISTIAN
DAY TO OBTAIN EIGHTY HOURS A
SIX PACK. IN ORDER TO AVOID
SOME AREAS LIKE THAT'S WHICH
CREATED SIGNIFICANT RISK OF
FRAUD AND WOULD NECESSITATE
LIMITED ACCESS TO WORK MENTION
ABOUT. WE PROPOSE TO DOCTOR TO
INSTEAD USE LIMITED THRESHOLD
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR
WORKERS TO QUALIFY FOR SICKLY.
SWEET SECOND THE BILL DEFINED
HIRING ENTITY TO INCLUDE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES AND DELIVERY NETWORK
COMPANIES FOR PURPOSES OF THE
STATUTE. WE SUGGEST THAT THE
BILL BE AMENDED TO MAKE IT. THE
APPLICABILITY CLEAR REGARDLESS
OF WORKERS CLASSIFICATION
STATUS AND AVOID COSTLY
LITIGATION. SPECIFICALLY
INSTEAD OF USING A TERM HIRING
THAT CAN YOU WE URGE YOU TO USE
THE TERM COVERED ENTITY. AS
DEFINED FIFTEEN CATCH YOU. AND
WE REMAIN COMMITTED. TO
ENSURING THAT WORKERS WAS TO
THE HELP. REPORT OF A DOCTOR'S
TWO CREATE A STAFF. COKE AT
NIGHT. COUPLE PAID LEAVE FOR.
THEY HAVE OFFERED AMENDMENTS DO
JUST THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
THANK YOU. HI THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS WITH THE CIGARETTE SEE
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION. OF THE GROCERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE OTHER
SECTORS OF THE FOOD INDUSTRY
ARE IN RESPECT OUR RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
TWENTY NINE AND WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE
AUTHORS WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US- WHEN GOVERNOR YOU SOME.
THE STATE HOMEOWNER IN MARCH
MANY BUSINESSES WERE ORDER
ORDER TO SHUT DOWN IN ORDER TO
HELP TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF
COVER NINETEEN. QUESTION HOW
WERE SOME OF THE REMAINING FEW
BUSINESS IS SEEN AS THE CENTURY
AND REMAIN IN. THAT QUICKLY.
THEY QUICKLY AT TWO DIFFERENT
WAYS OF CONDUCTING BUSINESS ALL
WHILE KEEPING TO PUT IN THE
PUBLIC AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE IN
KEEPING CRITICAL FOOD. IS OPEN
FROM CALIFORNIA. BUT AND- SURE
YEAH COME TOGETHER WITH THE
ENCOURAGE OF THE GOV TO
SOLIDIFY THE SOLIDIFY FOR TO
FOR ALL WORKERS IN THE
INDUSTRY- WE CAME TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE UP TO EIGHTY HOURS OF
ADDITIONAL SICK PAISLEY FOR
EMPLOYEES TO THE END OF THE DAY
AT HOME ORDER. THE AGREEMENT
AND SUBSEQUENT EXECUTIVE ORDER
ALSO INCLUDED PROTECTIONS TO
KEEP GROCERY STORE EMPLOYEES
SAFE. FROM ADDITIONAL CONCERNS
ARE ON HEALTH AND SAFETY. LIKE
TOUCHING CUSTOMERS REUSABLE
ITEMS BEING ABLE TO WATCH HAVE
MORE FREQUENTLY. WRITING CLEAR
SPECIAL DISTANCING DIRECTIONS
WITHIN STORES AND FURTHER
ENSURE CAL OSHA GUIDANCE FOR
THE INDUSTRY HAS DEVELOPED IN
THAT. SB SEVEN TWENTY NINE GOES
BEYOND THAT DELIVERY AGREEMENT
AND THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND EXTENSIVE SICKLY
PROVISIONS THROUGH THE END OF
THE DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY
ORDER UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT. STATE
OF EMERGENCY FREQUENTLY LAST
LONGER THAN THE TIME OF THE
PRESSING EMERGENCY HAND IN THIS
CASE COULD POTENTIALLY LUCK
MONTHS OR YEARS LONGER THAN THE
STATE HOME ORDER. AFTER CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION OF SCIENTIFIC
DATA AND A SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
OR NONEXISTENT RISK OF
CONTRACTION WE ANTICIPATE THE
STAY AT HOME OR TO BE LIFTED
WHEN IT IS LISTED. OTHER
NONESSENTIAL BUSINESSES LIKE
BARS BOWLING HOURS BOWLING
ALLEYS- CONCERT VENUES WILL BE
REOPENED. THE SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
WOULD REQUIRE THE FOOD SECTOR
TO CONTINUE OFFERING THE
ADDITIONAL COVERAGE RELATED
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE.
WELL AFTER THE FULL RE OPENING
OF THE ECONOMY AND IT WOULD BE
THE ONLY SEGMENT OF THE ECONOMY
TO DO SO. AND SO FOR THESE
REASONS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU. BUT NOW WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT FOR THOSE
OPPOSED AND AGAIN STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION ON
THE BILL. START WITH IN THE
ROOM IS ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. OKAY HELLO BONTA ANY
OPPOSITION A AT A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. OKAY OR MOVE
ON TO OUR MODERATOR A DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE. AND IF YOUR POSITION
IS THAT IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
LEGISLATION WE PRESS ONE ZERO.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR TWO FIVE
FOUR LINES OF. I DID THIRTY
YEARS OF THE CALIFORNIA THE
PRODUCER THAT ALIGNING ARE
COMMENTS WITH THOSE THE GROCERY
BUSINESS THE AGENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LYING TO NINETY
EIGHT TWO NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AS CHAIR MEMBER
ANTHONY MILLION ON BEHALF OF
THE ALL MY LIFE TO CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA GREEN FEES
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL- WE HAVE. BEEN TALKING
WITH THE OFFICE STAFF REMAINED
COMMITTED TO TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE- PERMITTING THE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MACBOOK AUTO LINE THREE
ZERO FIVE THREE OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SENATE INCOME
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY THREE TO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
RYAN ELAINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR LINE THREE TWENTY ONE THREE
TWO ONE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHEN MEMBERS
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
ONE EIGHT ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KODI BOILED ME HAPPY CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL AND CALIFORNIA
PRESS FOR DISSERTATION WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. LINE ONE THREE
AND ONE ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. KATIE
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT IT SAYS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FIND THREE ELEVEN FREE ONE
ONE PLEASE. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MILLER OF THE CRY
A LITTLE FARM BUREAU. AND
MISSION BY OF THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FIND TWENTY SEVEN DID YOU
HAVE A COMMENT. I'D LIKE ABOUT
THE COVERAGE THE STATION WINE
GRAPE GROWERS- THANK YOU FOR
TALKING WITH YOU HAVE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE DO
HAVE ADDITIONAL LINE IN Q.
MISTER CHAIR JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. THE. FIND TWENTY.
927-792-0070 SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS PATRICK FOR
THAT WITH THE GREATER COULD
TELL A VALLEY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN
Q. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT BRING
BACK THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS MOTIONS. THE MOTION A
SECOND. IN MEDIA. FOR THE
COMMENT. OKAY WELL I'LL JUST
SAY THANK YOU- ABSENT FORTINO
ONE OH SIX TO THE GUY TO OUR
GOVERNOR OF FOR THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER AT THE TIME THAT IT WAS
PUTIN PLACE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR FOOD SECTOR
WORKERS AND THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO FOR YOUR QUICK
ACTION IN. MOVING THE BILL
FORWARD THAT FIVE SOME OF THESE
PROTECTIONS AS WE KNOW THE
THESE FOOD SECTOR WORKERS- AT
EVERY LEVEL- ARE ALLOWING SO
MANY CALIFORNIANS TO BE ABLE TO
STAY AT HOME WITH THEIR
FAMILIES FOLLOW PUMP CALPERS
PROTECT. AND PROTECT THE CUP.
AND IS BECAUSE OF THE WORKERS
OF ABLE TO DO THAT AND SO I.
YOU FOR THAT REFER RECOGNIZING
IT. ARE NOT- WITH A WITH A BILL
THAT GIVES THE APPROPRIATE TIME
FOR THEM. TO ACTUALLY WITH.
UPPER COVER IF THEY ARE
IMPACTED OR IF THERE'S A RISK
OF YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
PROTECT THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
THAT MEANS PROTECTING THE
WORKERS- AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION HERE A
LOT OF COMMENTS ON YOUR
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AND
I IMAGINE. I KNOW YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT ALONG WITH.
A SPONSOR OF THE SPONSOR OF CW.
SO SEPARATELY TO PORTANTINO'S A
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
AND YES WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATIONS I WAS. TAKING
COPIOUS NOTES AND RESPECTFUL
THAT'S RIGHT I ABOUT. THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR SUMMARY.
AND **** A SUMMARY REAL IN THE
MOST PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
YOU'RE WELCOME ON THAT PLEASE.
DO HI KALRA AYE FLORA. GONZALEZ
HI GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE THREE OF US
THREE OF US I THOUGHT ALL RIGHT
THE BILL IS OUT AND MOVING
UNDER APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU
CENTER YOU KNOW. UP NEXT FOR SB
ELEVEN OH THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WE'RE SORRY SENATOR HER TITLE.
YES PLEASE. SENATOR WHEN EVER
YOU ARE READY- PLEASE PROCEED.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS IT'S AN HONOR
TO BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY AT
I'M EXCITED AND HAPPY TO SEE
ALL OF YOU AND HOPE YOU ARE ALL
TO IT. I START OFF BY THINKING
THAT READY CONSULTANTS FOR
WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE ON
TECHNICAL AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
GIVEN THE COMPRESSED TIMELINE-
YOU KNOW WE LIVE IN A STATE AND
A NATION IT WAS BUILT BY
AMATEURS. AND WHO HAVE. A VERY
BUT SHE CAN BE A- CREAM. I
PERSONALLY HAVE A DOG. OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND OF IMMIGRANT
PARENTS I'VE SEEN AND
EXPERIENCED THE HARSH REALITY
OF HOW. EASILY IMMIGRANT AND
FAMILIES ALL TOGETHER CAN FALL
INTO POVERTY. AND POVERTY IS
SOMETHING THAT I ABSOLUTELY.
HATE IF THERE'S- IF I CAN AND
I'M ALLOWED TO HATE SOMETHING
POVERTY IS IT IN MY PARENTS
WERE ALSO AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYEES ON NOW THE RETIRED
BUT- THEY WERE ONCE ALSO GIVEN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE. A TBM
COUNTRYMEN. WE ALL WANT THAT
RIGHT WE ALL WANT THAT FOR ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM. SB NO THREE IS
A RIGHT INVESTMENT FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AS ARE
MOST VULNERABLE ARE IN DANGER
OF BEING PULLED FARTHER AWAY
FROM ACHIEVING. THEIR AMERICAN
DREAM. THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO SUPPORT
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS BY
COMPLETING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING PROGRAMS
THROUGH SUPPORT OF SERVICES.
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE
BOARD TO DEVELOP ADDITIONAL
EMPLOYMENT PARTNERSHIPS TO
ADDRESS NEW OPPORTUNITIES IN
PLACES LIKE THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FOR FARMWORKERS. DISCONNECTED
YOU OTHERS AND ALSO NEW
OPPORTUNITIES AND HEALTH CARE.
WE LEARN FROM OUR LAST
RECESSION THE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THE FIRST BECOME AN
UNEMPLOYED AND THE LAST TO
RECOVER AND WE MUST ACT NOW TO
ADDRESS THESE LONG STANDING
ECONOMIC DISPARITIES IT IS
CRITICAL TO PROVIDE. DOUBLE THE
ADDRESS BY MY MONEY NOBLE
POPULATION. OF YESTERDAY BUT
ALSO OF TOMORROW'S WORKFORCE.
WE KNOW WORKFORCE TWENTY
PROGRAMS ALSO HAVE A PROVEN
IMPACT ON. IMPROVING UPWARD
MOBILITY AND ALSO INCREASING
OPPORTUNITIES FULL FOR CHILDREN
LIVING IN POVERTY WHEN THEY
BECOME ADULTS. IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY EIGHT THE LIFTING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY TASK FORCE UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
REPORTED TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THAT THEIR PRIORITY
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO FUND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS TO COMPLETE
IMPLICATIONS JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS. HOWEVER CALIFORNIA
CHECK EARLY IN RULES VALLEY
MANY WORKFORCE PARTICIPANTS
PARTICIPANTS ARE NOT ABLE TO
COMPLETE THEIR JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS DUE TO A LOT OF
PORTABLE TRANSPORTATION. LACK
OF AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE.
LANGUAGE BARRIERS AND OTHERS.
AND WE WANT TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL PRIOR
TASTING THESE POPULATIONS WILL
HELP LIFT FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY AND INTO PROSPERITY AND
IT STARTS HERE WITH AT. ELEVEN
ZERO THREE. HERE TODAY HAVE
WILL ROOM. AB CONWAY COLLINS
WITH THE GRAYSON TO AS L. Y. OF
MY WAY. I ALL MY WORKER FOR SAY
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO BUT THE CAL
FORMER HYUNDAI TO. TEST THANK
YOU SENATOR TOTAL PENCIL HERE
FOR THIS EACH WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES WITNESSES WITH THE THAT
REQUIRE TRANSLATION GET UP TO
FOUR MINUTES THERE'S TIME TO
PROPERLY TRANSLATE. AND SO
WON'T GO AND START WITH CON WE
CALL. THANK CHAIR ONE MOMENT.
LANGUAGE BETTER HERE HELLO. AND
WE WANT TO CREATE A LOT OF THE.
BUT I THINK IT THANK YOU MISTER
COLLINS YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE
HUMANE PRESENT YOUR POSITION.
NOW OKAY. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GRAYSON
ORGANIZATION WAS THE PRIMARY
SPONSOR OF THE LEGISLATION THAT
CREATED THE LIFTING CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY
TASK FORCE THAT I CULTURE THE
TASK FORCE WITH THAN STATE
DIRECTOR OF SOCIAL SERVICES LET
THE DIRECT YOU TO THE FORCE WAS
TO DEVELOP. A PLAN AND DEEP
CHILD POVERTY IN THIS REDUCING
OVERALL BY AT LEAST 50% AND I
THINK IT'S COMMON KNOWLEDGE
THAT GOOD JOB PAYING THE WAGE.
THE BEST ROUTE POVERTY AND
BREAKS THE OF POVERTY FOR. TO
THE EDUCATION. SO WAS JUST
IMPORTANT IT WAS CHAIRED BY THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE STATE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TEN
ROUNDS. THE SUBCOMMITTEE
EMPHASIZED THAT PROVIDING
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES LIKE
CHILDCARE TRANSPORTATION
BLOWING COMPACT DEPENDS IS THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT CAN BE DONE IN THE WORK
FORCE AND TRAIN AREA TWO AND
SIX. OKAY TRANSPORTATION
BARRIERS TO PARTICIPATION AND
ALLOW COMPLETION OF THESE
PROGRAMS TO THE BOTTOM LINE IS
FOR JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL TRAINEES NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO AND FROM WORK.
HAVE RELIABLE CHILDCARE. AND
HOUSING SHOULD. CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING FARMWORKERS AND
DISPLAYS DO WE JUST CANNOT DO
LESS THANK YOU AND WE ARE JUST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. I NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM ALL MONTH WHO
WILL ALSO BE USING THE SERVICES
A TRANSLATOR- AN INTERPRETER SO
GO AHEAD I'LL NOT.
YEAH. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE TERMS ARE
HERE. THE MIDDLE LIKE START A
FIRE OR SOMETHING CAMPAñA I
DON'T LIKE. OKAY SHAMEFULLY
THAT'LL THEY KNEW NOTHING
MICHAEL FOCAL. AT A LOT. OF A
LOT OF EXAMPLE LEAVING INCOME
WHEN YOU GOT IT BUT I LIVE ON
THE BILL BY THE END OF. BUT THE
I REQUIRE THAT. IN ABOUT EIGHT
OUT BY THE- A YEAH MEAN THINK.
BOB ON BOTH THE COMMON THREAD
FULLER DATABASE ONE BELMONT
VALUE TO DEMOCRATS EIGHT MOVIE
P. FROM MY THAT NOT THAT OF A
GOAL NOT BEING ACTIVE BUT I FOR
LOVE IT OR FOLKS VALLEY. FOR I
BELIEVE THAT MEDIA HAVING. NOT
BEEN ABLE TO RESOLVE THE FOR
YOU IN ALL. IN A FIFTY FAMILY
BUT I FROM FEDERAL BUT I THINK.
OKAY BUT OKAY ONE PM. THE MAN
ON THE BATTLE NOT THAT I A
QUESTION I THOUGHT. THEY KNEW
NOT ON THE LAST. THEY ONLY ONLY
THAT BUT I FELT. THE NUMBER AND
I DON'T THE ONLY AND I COULD
NOT BE MAKING. HELLOOKAY LET A
FERRY BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
THEY WON'T THE CALIFORNIA YEAH
THAT IS NOT. I AM AT THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT BOTH OF ITS ALMOST.
WHEN I MEAN AT THE END. THE
POINT FIVE EIGHT EIGHT ABA ON
THAT OKAY. YOU THAT I DON'T
KNOW HOW IS A GUY. I BUT AGAIN.
YOU HAVE FAVORITE THAT IT. HE
SENATE ON ON THE COURT EVEN IF
THAT BUT I GET THE BY. OF ON
MEDIA. BUT I CAN'T FOR BOTH
LAST. THE POLITICAL PARTIES
MANY. THAT'S. WE GET A CHANCE
TO LOOK AT MONEY PUT UNDER
EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF THE ABOUT
THE CAPITALISTIC IF I'M GONNA
KALRA OF THE PAPER ONE CAN BE
BY BE TO HAVE MORE TO PAY MY
NAME IS. AND THANK WHAT IF ABLE
TO PUTTING IT ELEVEN O'CLOCK
BECAUSE I WANTED TO GO BACK BUT
LACKS THE RESOURCES AND SHALL
CARE WHICH MAKES VERY TO DO
ALSO MANY FARMERS OF AN WILL
COMMUNITY WERE TRANSFERRED
TODAY TO BE EDUCATION
ESPECIALLY WHEN TAKING AND
EVENING IT IS VERY TO TAKE LIKE
CLASSES WHEN YOU HAVE THE TIME.
ORDER RIGHT NOW. WHAT ONE DAY A
FLAT SCREEN OKAY CAREER TO HAVE
MORE OPPORTUNITY AND LIKE IN MY
CASE I LIKE TO TAKE COURSES TO
MUCH OPERATOR AND I KNOW THAT
MANY OF MY CALL WOULD LIKE TO
VOTE OTHER PROFESSIONAL ABOUT
THAT WHILE WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE BETTER FUTURE AND HOW YOU
COULD LEVELS BOB IN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE WORKING RIGHT NOW ON THE-
AT. SEVEN OO WELL HOW COULD.
JUST GO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SHARE MY STARTING. ONCE AGAIN I
HAVE NONE OF THAT THE TICKER
DIRECTOR OF THE TIME FARM
FUNDING AND WE ARE A- SB IT ON
THREE. THANK YOU THANK YOUR NON
FOR THE FIRST. FOR ALL OF MY UP
NOW WE HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
AND SO ANY IN THE ROOM IN. IT
WILL GO ON TO ANYONE N SUPPORT
OF THE TESTIMONY STATION. AND
THEN THE WILL GO AHEAD TO-
MODERATORS THEY WANT TO SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE AGAIN- NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. OKAY AS A REMINDER
YOU MAKE YOU UP BY PRESSING IN
ONE THAN ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE OF SIX ONE ZERO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE OH SIX WERE
YOU IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MOVE ON TO LINE TWO THREE NINE
NINE TO THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
THIS IS MICHELLE GALA ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF AT THE ONE
ONE ZERO THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE THREE THREE FIVE
THREE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT DOES LOOK LIKE A
VALID BUT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
SUPPORTED THE THOUGHT. THANK
YOU. LINE THREE TO FOUR THREE
TWENTY FOUR AIRLINERS OPEN.
EACH. LINE THREE TWENTY FOUR IS
THIS THE BILL YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK TO. SOME OF ON LINE THREE
THREE EIGHT THREE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE THREE
FOUR THREE NINE THREE FOUR
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
KEVIN AGAINST CO FRIENDS
COMMITTEE AND LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN OH THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE TWO FOUR FOUR
TWO FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THERE REALLY AND ON BEHALF OF
SOUTH BAY COMMUNITY EVERYTHING
IS IN SUPPORT OF THAT THE ONE
ONE ZERO THREE. THANK YOU. PINE
THREE THREE TO THREE THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO KATHY
NEIL ON BEHALF THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR FREEDOM
CENTER WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND IT
BIGGEST PLEASE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. LINE THREE
FORTY FOUR THREE FOUR FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LOWER THAN THAT YEAH I
FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AT ELEVEN
OPERATE. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
THREE ONE ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
MARTY SO GO THE NEXT I LIVE IN
HUNTINGTON PARK AND I SUPPOSE
THAT EVEN BE OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE TWO FOUR THREE
TWO FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE TWO FOUR THREE ARE YOU ON
MUTE. WILL MOVE BONTA LINE ONE
FIVE NINE ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE FIFTY NINE.
DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK TOWARDS
THIS BILL. BOTTOM LINE THREE
THREE FOUR THREE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY YET YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT WE DON'T HAVE A
LETTER IN BUT WE ARE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY ONE EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. EIGHTY ONE DID YOU
WANT TO SPEAK PORTS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AT. WE DO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL LINE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
AND THAT FINAL
COMMENT IN QUEUE COMES FROM
LINE ONE EIGHT EIGHT ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
EIGHT EIGHT DID YOU JUST SPEAK
WITH AN OPERATOR. WE ALSO HAVE
A COMMENT FROM LINE. ONE OH
SIX. ONE OF SIX HAS REMOVED A
LINE. AT AT THIS TIME NO OTHER
LINES ARE IN Q. THANK YOU. I'M
SO NEXT UP OPPOSITION BE OF
KIM'S TO ALMOST ON ADVOCACY.
SO
YOU DON'T LISTEN WE DON'T SEE
HER AT LEAST ON THE LINE RIGHT
AT THE MOMENT SO LONG WE GOAL
TO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION CAN NAME AFFILIATION
A POSITION AND OF KIM. SHOWS UP
WELL GO AHEAD AND GIVE HER TWO
MINUTES OF THAT TIME. AND THEN
ON THE. RICHARD IT ON A START
IN THE FALL YES WHAT WE GOT
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND START WITH
THE PHONE AND THEN WE'LL SEE IF
MR SHOWS UP AND DOT WILL GO TO
PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE WHAT
HAVE YOU BUT IF THERE'S ANYONE
CUED UP MAIS WELL GO HEAD START
WITH THE. THE DONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY HI I CALLED ON THE
WRONG NUMBER I APOLOGIZE YOU
DON'T ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
COULD DEFEND- DEFINITION OF THE
GROUPS OF A PRINT OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD HAVE. THAT PROGRAM-
UNFORTUNATELY EXCLUDE- PEOPLE
WHO WOULD- BENEFIT FROM- PORT
FOR TIME HERE OKAY SIGNIFICANT
IT YOU WERE TO ATTEND ONE OF
pTHAT AFFECTED THE CONTRACTORS
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA PROVIDE
AND SO WE- UNFORTUNATELY. BILL
ONLY ALLOW PREDICTED WHO FOLLOW
THE MULTI CAR COURT TO RECEIVE
THE- BENEFITS AND WE WOULD LIKE
PEOPLE TO ARE KIND OF YOUR- TO
BE ABLE TO REPEAT THE FLOWER
THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT AT RESPECT
OPPOSE THE BILL. INTO TO
INCLUDE OUR FROM WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR. I'M ANYONE IN
THE ROOM. IN A- NOT ANYONE
OBSERVE TO REMOTE TEST ON
STATION. THEN WILL GO AHEAD AND
GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINES
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
FOR POSITION AND IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THAN ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OH SIX ONE
ZERO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
ONE ZERO SIX DID YOU HAVE A
COMMENT. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
THREE FIFTY TWO THREE FIVE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ERIC BARS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION OUR
POSITION HAS CONCERNS- BUT WE
WANT TO REALLY THANK THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS FOR REALLY WORKING
AND BEING RESPONSIVE TO OUR
CONCERNS ON HOW TO MAKE THIS
BILL THE MOST IMPLEMENTABLE AND
BEST THAT IT CAN. RIGHT NOW THE
BILL. COVERS COST IN A VERY
SMALL. OF THE COST OF SUPPORT
SERVICES GREATLY ELIMINATING
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
CAN PARTICIPATE IN THE HIGH
ROAD TRAINING AND OTHER. MORE
WORKFORCE PROGRAM. SO WE ARE
HOPEFUL TO SEE THAT. IN AGAIN
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS FOR BEING RESPONSIVE
TO. THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER. COMMENTS
ALL RIGHT AS BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR ANY FURTHER
COMMENT. FIVE SENATOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- BRING WHEN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM. LIFTING
CHILDREN FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY TASK FORCE AND ALLOW
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECT AFTER DR. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR FROM VICE
CHAIR FOR A SECOND BY SOME
MEMBERS JONES SAWYER. I DO PAST
APPROPRIATIONS FLANAGAN TAKE
ORAL. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA. AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA. FLORA I CARILLO
CARILLO I DEEP. CAN SALAS
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I BILLS THE BILLS
OUT THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT UP NEXT. THE HIGH
SOUGHT AFTER SB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN BY. SENATOR ALSO JUST
REFERENCING OF COURSE THE CALLS
WE'VE ALREADY GOTTEN IN ON THAT.
ALTHOUGH THE OTHER ITEMS FOR
THIS BILL BUT WE ARE HERE NOW.
OF ALL THE VOTES WE GOT OUR- WE
ARE HERE NOW- ITEM FOR SB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN SENATOR DID
ALSO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
CALIFORNIA'S THE OSHA
CALIFORNIA OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH ACT- OF EXCLUDES
HELPFUL DOMESTIC SERVICE
EMPLOYEES THIS BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE THAT EXCLUSION AND
RECENT AMENDMENTS OF ONE. AND
RECENT AMENDMENTS DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION FOR PUBLICLY
FUNDED HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE EMPLOYEES SUCH AS I AGE
AS THE WORKERS. HOWEVER AS WE
CONTINUED TO DIALOGUE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND SOME MORE
CLEARLY THE COMPLEXITY OF
PUBLICLY FUNDED PROGRAMS AND IN
RECOGNITION OF THEIR IMPORTANCE
TO LOW INCOME POPULATIONS WE
HAVE DECIDED TO EXCLUDE
DOMESTIC SERVICE EMPLOYEES
FUNDED BY GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS
FROM THE BILL AS IT ADVANCES
THIS YEAR. WE HAVE REACHED OUT
TO MANY STATE COLD AND- WE HAVE.
BASIC CONSENSUS WE WILL TAKE
AMENDMENT TO THAT EFFECT THAT
THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY TO AMEND
THE BILL WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND
THE BEST WAY TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF ALL PARTIES THIS BILL
REMOVES A HISTORICALLY
DISCRIMINATORY EXCLUSION IT'S
PART OF ADDRESSING A LONG
HISTORY OF EXCLUSION OF
DOMESTIC WORKERS FROM BASIC
LABOR PROTECTIONS AND AS PART
OF OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY OF
RACISM. IN THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES WHEN DOMESTIC WORKER
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY PERFORMED
BY SLAVES WAS NOW STILL BEING
DONE BY AFRICAN AMERICANS
FEDERAL LAWS WERE PASSED THAT
EXCLUDED THIS WORK. FROM BASIC
WORKPLACE PROTECTION THIS YEAR
THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS ENSURING
THAT ALL MEN AND WOMEN HAVE A
SAFE PLACE TO CARRY OUT THE
WORK THIS BILL EXTENDS OSHA
PROTECTIONS TO PRIVATE A
HOUSEHOLD OF A STICK SERVICE
EMPLOYEES. DOMESTIC WORKERS ARE
COVERED UNDER OTHER WORKPLACE
RIGHTS LIKE MINIMUM WAGE
OVERTIME A WORKERS
COMPENSATION. THIS TO THESE
CHANGES ARE MADE SEVERAL YEARS
AGO AND ESTABLISH THE EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIP. CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS ARE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF WHERE HOME IS ALSO
THE WORKPLACE. HERE ARE DUE
PROCESS SAFEGUARDS WITHIN THE
BILL THE BALANCE THE NEED FOR
PRIVACY WITH COMPLIANCE. IN
RECOGNITION OF THE UNIQUENESS
OF A RESIDENTIAL DO WELL IN THE
WORKPLACE. FIRST CONTACT WITH
AN EMPLOYER IN RESPONSE TO AN
ALLEGED VIOLATION RECEIVE FROM
A DOMESTIC. EMPLOYEE WILL BE BY
TELEPHONE. YES OF COURSE THERE
IS AN INJURY. ARE RESULTING.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL CALLS
UPON OSHA TO CONVENE AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO EVALUATE
AND THREE SPECIFIC REGULATIONS
RELATED TO HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE. AND FOR THAT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO BE EQUALLY
BALANCED BETWEEN EMPLOYER
HOMEOWNERS AND EMPLOYEES.
DOMESTIC WORKERS WHO ARE
PRIMARILY IMMIGRANT WORK AND
WORK. WOMEN WORKFORCE ARE
ESSENTIAL TO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND THEY DESERVE
CONSIDERATION JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER WORKING MAN OR WOMAN. WE
CANNOT X. CONTINUE TO EXCLUDE
THIS GROUP OF WORKERS NOT
DURING THE HEALTH PANDEMIC NOT
DURING THE WILDFIRES THAT THE
MASTER WORKERS HELP TO CLEAN UP
NOT IN THE EVERYDAY WORK THAT
PUTS OUR HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
AND THEIR FAMILIES ON THE LINE
DURING THE WILD FIRES THAT
DEVASTATE CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLD
DOMESTIC SERVICE EMPLOYEES.
WERE ASKED TO STAY BEHIND TO
FIGHT FIRES GUARD HOMES OR PETS
WORK IN. SMOKY CONDITIONS AND
CLEAN UP TOXIC ASH EMPLOYERS
ALL FELT IT MANY THEM THAT THE
HOMES THERE WORKING THAT WERE
UNDER MANDATORY EVACUATION
ORDERS. THE CURRENT NINETEEN
HEALTH PANDEMIC HAS ONLY
FURTHER MAGNIFY THE
VULNERABILITIES AND DANGERS THE
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND DAY LABORS
FACE ON A DAILY BASIS. BECAUSE
THEY ARE EXCLUDED FROM
CALIFORNIA'S A FAILED THIS THE
LAWS AS OUR WILD FIRES GROWING
FREQUENCY AND INTENSITY. AS A
PANDEMIC DISPROPORTIONATE TO
WRAP LOW INCOME. OF COLOR IT'S
TIME FOR THE SLIP LECTURE TO
PROTECT THESE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. MY TWO WITNESSES THE
SUPPORT TODAY ARGUED MAY NOT
BECAUSE THE ANNALS DIRECTOR
LOOKALIKE THE WEATHER WILL BE
HEADED AND- GOAL YOSHIHARA.
L'ASSOCIATION I'M EACH. WITNESS
WILL HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES
HOWEVER WITNESSES THAT REQUIRE
TRANSLATION AS YOUR FIRST
WITNESS. APPARENTLY DOES WILL
HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES TO
INCLUDE THE TIME. FOR THAT
TRANSLATION SO WE HAVE GET ME
NOW BECAUSE THE ANNALS OF ALL.
MEDICAL YOSHIHARA. WHAT IS THE
NUMBER OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE MARKET IS
OF A LOT OF FIFTY SAID MR SOME
PRACTICAL. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SOCIAL. CRITICALLY ONCE THERE
OF ALL OF THE COMMUTING I
THOUGHT YEAH. ON THE ARM OF THE
NOT ON THE PROPERTY THAT IS.
LUCKILY QUESTION NUMBER FROM
THE VOTER LOCALLY SO THAT OF
ALL OF THE LOOK UP BECAUSE
BOTTOM. BUT I MY NAME IS YOU
GET ME NEXT THE END OF THE
NIGHT BECAUSE YOU'RE F THE
CALL. OF THE LEARN CAN SERVICES
AND SAN FRANCISCO AND OF
IMMIGRANT WOMEN THE NEXT
WORKERS OF CLEAN HOME CARE FOR.
THAT HELD AND WITH BUT- THE
WOMEN BECAUSE- WITHOUT MEMBER
OF THE CAL. DOMESTIC WORK
CALLING. ONE OF ON THE- OKAY WE
TALK ABOUT HOW THEY LOOK OF
MOTHER THAN THEY ARE YOU BUT
MOST OF THE PEOPLE SIX ONE AND
YOU KNOW WHAT THE **** FOR THE
LEVEL OF ITS ONLINE. THE
WELCOME WILL HAVE ALL OF THE
LOCAL OF BIG WILL NOT LET GUYS
YEAH THIS THIS LIMIT IT DOES
WHAT THE GOAL. SIMILAR FROM
ACROSS THE LAVA IT'S A LONG
SHOT. OKAY GOOD I'VE BEEN.
SPEAK UP COULD NOT. KEEP FOR
THE PUBLIC FIELD. ABOUT THE
TEST YOUR NEW FOR MUCH LONGER
WILL SO WHEN. ACOSTA A LOT.
IT'S THREE GOOD FOR SOME
SPANISH. MEN THREE SIX FOR MORE
ON THEM. TO LEARN A FEW FRIENDS
YOUR. THANK AND I THINK WORKERS
THANK YOU OSHA GREAT. IT MEANS
THAT WE NOT HAVE TO THE PROTECT
A QUICK TRAIN NOR IMPORTANT
ABOUT HOUSE PRESENT IN THE
WORKPLACE. WHICH IS GREAT
DURING MY THE CRY. BUT THE
COMPANY NINETEEN PAN THEM ENTER
WILD BY. OUR AGREEMENT. ONE
THING PERSONAL NOT ONE THAT
I'VE BEEN BEEN THE OFF PUBLIC
SO BODIES BEFORE THE MOVE OF
THE- BUT AGAIN I THOUGHT HOW
ALL OF THE AVAILABLE BE THAT'S
WHAT YEAH EVIL BUT THERE'S A
LOT BUT HE OTHER THAN READING
IN THE WILL. OR MARK A MARCH
WELCOME OF THE- BOX.
CONTRACTING THE VIRUS IN THEIR
WORKPLACE. AND AS MORE HOUSE
CLEANERS ARE RETURNING TO WORK
WE WILL BE MORE THAN EXPLODED
COBIT IN THEIR WORKPLACE.
BROUGH AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE IN
PLACE HERE THANK THE NUMBER OF
PORTS NEW DOT OUR- IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THEY CANNOT NEED
A OF OUR A LOT. THEY DON'T
LAUGH IT YOU DON'T FOLLOW ABOUT
IT MEDICINE SO MORE THAT WOULD
BE THE BIGGER THE LOVE IN THE
GLOVEBOX. NEED TO VOTE IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. UP NEXT MARIE GO YOSHIHARA.
HERE MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MARIE. BUT HE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE SO PROUD DO YOU COOK
BONTA THE CELL ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS WORK STATE AND EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES. SB TWELVE
WOULD BE SENATE WILL HELP
CORRECT ALONG AND JUSTICE IN
OUR HEALTH AND BEAT THE LOG
THAT TREATMENT BACK TO
BLATANTLY RACIST AND SEXIST
EXCLUSIONARY POLICIES. THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ALREADY ADVANCE
THE NUMBER OF AND BILLS THAT
WOULD STRENGTHEN OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY LAWS. THE FRONT WORKER
BECAUSE OF THE DANGERS BY THE
CURRENT PENNDOT. YET DOMESTIC
WORKERS ARMY PROVIDED BY THE
MùT BASS HEALTH SAFETY FOR.
BECAUSE THEIR FROM I'LL KEEP
HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS. EVEN
WHEN WE KNOW ARE SOME OF THE-
ESSENTIAL WORKERS CARING FOR
OUR HOMES AND OUR LOVED ONE.
NEEDS WORKERS HAVE NO CHOICE
MANY DO NOT HAVE A SOCIAL
SAFETY NET TO FALL BACK ON AND
THEY HAVE NO LAW TO PROTECT
THEM IF THEY ARE PRESENTED WITH
THE DRESS ARE HARMFUL WORKING
CONDITION. YOU CAN RECORD.
BETTER AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
EVERY INDUSTRIES WORKPLACE IS
DIFFERENT AND THAT HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS SHOULD REFLECT
THE REALITIES AND CIRCUMSTANCES
OF EACH PARTICULAR INDUSTRY.
BUT THE FACT IS THAT CAL OSHA
NOW CANNOT EVEN PROVIDE ANY
GUIDANCE ON HOW TO PROTECT
DOMESTIC WORKERS DURING FIRES
OR DURING. THE NINETEEN BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NO JURISDICTION OVER
THE TYPE OF IMPORTANT WORK THIS
BILL THAT'S WHAT THE- THAT IS
YOU NEED TO THE MATH. SERVICE
ONE THAT IS NON INTRUSIVE BASED
ON. EDUCATING EMPLOYER WHEN
THERE IS THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
COMPLAINT AND WORKING TOGETHER
WITH THE CLERK TO A- ANY. OTHER
AND- WE THE BILL ALL BY THE.
COMMITTEE THAT CAN HELP CAL DE.
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC I. SO THAT
EMPLOYERS KNOW EXACT WHAT YOU
TAKE THEIR WORK STATE. WE KNOW
THAT THIS MAN MAKE WILL. EXTEND
BE THAT AND THEY WILL AND- BE
MORE WILD FIRES AND NATURAL
DISASTERS SO WE NEED TO ACT NOW
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THESE CRITICAL
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. BY INCLUDING
HELLO SHOULD PROTECTION TO THE
BEACH STRONGLY OR YOUR- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOING TO ELSE
IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM MOVE ON
TO A REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
AND THEN THE MODERATOR WE HAVE
FOLKS IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE.
WE DO WILL FIRST LINE WILL COME
FROM THE LINE ONE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GUESS GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH-
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MEGAN ARE TEETH I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INSTITUTE OF POPULAR EDUCATION
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN LOS
ANGELES WORKING WITH THE LABOR
AND DOMESTIC WORKERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIFTY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI HELLO. YES HI MY NAME
IS CHRISTINA AS ONE CALIFORNIA
I AM A MEMBER OF FILIPINO
ADVOCATE THEY BY THE END OF THE
STICK FOR BOTH COLLISION. I AM
NOT JUST A QUOTE. I LIKE THE
PART INCLUDES TWELVE SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE NEXT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE ONE. TO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD OF IS
OPEN. AND TWO FOUR THREE
CAROLINA OPEN. MOVING ON WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE THREE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES.
HI ARE DIFFERENT IRISH WITH THE
WESTERN ON LAW AND POVERTY ONLY
IN. THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO
THE WIND TWO FIFTY THREE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE. AND MOVING
ON WILL GO TO THE LINE NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE NINETY EIGHT.
HELLO I REMEMBER. YES NUMBER
ONE TRACK BUT THE CALIFORNIA AT
AT AT WORK WHAT. THANK YOU.
NEXT OVER THE LINE ONE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IN MY BELT I AM A
VOLUNTEER FROM. AND THAT THE
PLACE NO I FEEL THE FACT THAT
LIKE- THAT IT HAS HAD ON
DOMESTIC WORKERS I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT IF YOU
TALK WITH THAT. THANK YOU. NEXT
LAW AND ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
MADDIE YANKEE ONE I'M A MEMBER
OF CANDID CAN THAT DOMESTIC
EMPLOYER NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. NEXT AVAILABLE
ONLINE AT ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DIANA MENDOZA AND WITH THE
INSTITUTE OF POPULAR EDUCATION
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AT THE TOP
FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. BACK IN
LINE THREE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CURRENT TRIAL
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
DIDN'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE WORKING WITH
SENATOR D'AMATO DORADO IN THE
BILLS SPONSORS ON THE MEMBER
CATHARINE SENATOR MENTIONED
THAT WILL BE CHECKING AND THAT.
THAT AMENDMENT WILL RECOGNIZE.
THE HOUSEHOLDS WITH PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES AND WHO
RECEIVE SUBSIDIZED BENEFITS SO
AGAIN WE THANK VERY MUCH OR
WORKING WITH THEM AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SAY THAT IF PRINT
THANK YOU. CAN NEXT IS ONE
THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS AND I'M WITH THE
NATO SB WOULD SOMEONE PLEASE
CALL. SO ARE YOU YEAH BUT THEY
WILL HAVE ME THAT HE SB LESS IT
ACCORDING TO THE LEFT THE
HOLIDAY LAST THE CALIFORNIA.
AND YOUR THOUGHT. CLEAR NO NINO
YOU CAN LOOK AT BE ON IT BUT SO
THAT YOU IT IS THEY YOUR FOR
YOUR SINGLE DOCTOR. ALTHOUGH
THERE ARE NO HAN DON'T YOUR FOR
YOUR LONG IT'S AVAILABLE
BECAUSE I IT. AFTER CLASS. NEXT
WE'LL GO THE MIND THREE FIFTY
NINE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
OF ONE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MRS ABIGAIL ABBOTT IS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT OVER THE VINE THREE
HUNDRED NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS RENEE ITSELF HELLO I'M
A PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITH I WILL
NOT. THE WOMEN'S GROUP OF THE
GREAT LABOR CENTER IN CINEMA
COUNTY. AND I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. IS LINE TWO OR
THREE TWO HUNDRED THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BOTH THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MY
THERE ARE RUN AND- I'M MEMBER
OF SHEILA THANK THAT LEAVES ONE
ELEMENT COULD LOOK GOOD WHAT IS
JOHN AND I HAVE WERE OUT THE
HOUSE CLEANER FOR FOUR YEARS
AND I SUPPORT IS THE TWELFTH.
FIFTY SEVEN. DO YOU. NEXT TO
THE LINE. ONE TWENTY FOUR ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHEN I THOUGHT OF IT
THE NUMBER OF MOTOR VEHICLES I
MEAN THAT IN A PLACE EVEN
BETTER NOW THAN IT ECONOMY. UP
UNTIL LAST MONTH SHE. THEY
LIMIT YOUR- A- LOT IN THE LAST
BEING FACT THAT IN BOTH ONE OF
THE- YOU FOR YOU IS IT. IS. BUT
I THINK CLASSES. LINE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS OKAY VERY. YES
HELLO YES THAT A LOT MORE COULD
NOT OPPORTUNITIES WITH THAT
CLEAR GROUP UP WITH THE BEST
WORKERS AND ONE SUPPORT SB
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT IS LAW THREE HUNDRED SO
TWO. THREE SO TWO GO AHEAD. ALL
TAKE. OKAY WHAT ABOUT THE DOWN
ONE OR MORE OF YOUR THE SO I
NEVER THE KID DAY THAT THEIR
LEVEL IF ABOUT A CO HUNDRED THE
COOKIES YEAH A SO YOU NINE YET
I BUT A LOT IT. HE IS GOING A
PROBLEM GOING UP WE ALLOW SAID
THEY LOOK AT THINGS WHEN THEY
GET. CRISIS. AND WE HAVE AN
EXTRA TO LINE HUNDRED AND FIVE
THREE SO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT THERE. THE NUMBER WAS ALL
ABOUT LEVEL THAT THE THANK YOU
SO FAR THEY LOOKED I'M GOING TO
NOT DON'T CALL ME THAT YES YEAH
OF AUTOMATED HE I IT'S A BAD
NOT BUT THEY GET THE WHATEVER
THAT GETS CLOSEST. X. WILL GO
TO THE LINE THREE. SEVEN SO
SEVEN GO A. HELLO YES GOOD WHAT
CAN SEE. SEE WHEN I STARTED IN
ON THE MONEY AROUND THIS MAY
WELL FIND TELL YOU ACTUALLY
MEMBERS IN CHILE THEM COLLISION
COLOR AND ALL THAT. FOR THE
SIGN YOU APPLE YEAH I SAID I
LOVE TO THINK WHEN THEY SEE A
THEY WE CAN REST. ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'LL GO TO
THE NEXT THAT IS LINE ONE ZERO
TWO ONE HUNDRED AND TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. WHAT
YES OKAY HI MY NAME IS IAN IAN
STEINBERG AND I LIVE IN PALO
ALTO I'M A MEMBER OF HAND IN
HAND TO DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS
NETWORK AND ALSO SUPPORTER OF
THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION I HAVE THREE KIDS AND
HAVE BEEN AT THE MASTER. WHERE
MISTER WORKERS FOR OVER YEARS
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AND
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEVEN MADE BY THE
PROGRESS WEARING CHUNK SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. OCTOBER LINE. THREE EIGHT
EIGHT THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
GO AHEAD. PAULA. THREE THREE
HUNDRED AND- MEMBER OF THE-
YEAH ALL YOUR LIFE. GET OUT
CRISIS. NEXT TO A BOTTLE OF
WINE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NOT
VALLEY'S ABOUT REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT OVER THE LINE
THREE HUNDRED SIXTEEN THREE ONE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOR MY
NAME IS YEAH. I BELIEVE IN FACT
I'M GOING TO THINK WELL I AM
AND THEY DON'T LOOK AT IT HE
THAT. HE THAT. I THOUGHT FOR
STATE THREE BUT IT SAID IN.
THANK YOU THANKS YOU THANK YOU.
NEXXAR OUT OF ONE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
NINE SORRY MATE WITH THE
NATIONAL EMPLOYMENT LAW PROJECT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE LINE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY WATER
BUT THAT CALIFORNIA WORK AND
FAMILY COALITION AND WE'RE AND
STOCK. UP THANK YOU. EXT IS A
LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YU
MAY OCCUR WITH A CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IMPORT
THANK. X. WE GO TO THE LINE OE
EIGHTY ONE EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CALL
MARKET WITH. WORK SHAPE WHERE
PROUD CO SPONSOR. AND A STRONG
COOLEY SUPPORT SB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GONNA GO ALIGNED. THREE
NINETY SIX THREE HUNDRED NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I YES.
HI THERE ARE ACTUALLY TWO
PEOPLE ON THE LINE- WE ARE CALL
YOU FROM BALDWIN PARK
CALIFORNIA MY NAME IS DOUG
APPALACHIA AND I AM A DOMESTIC
EMPLOYER AS WELL AS A MEMBER OF
THE THAT. STRONG SUPPORT AT
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THE OPEN UP BUT- THAT'S GOOD
YEAH THREE. HELLO ABOUT A- I
THANK YOU FOR BATES DANIEL.
THEY HAVE A WHOLE YEAH FOR YOUR
EYES SURVEYS BOTH YOU CAN
QUICKLY GET THE- DEREK COLEMAN
CALL ME THAT YEAH. LOOK AT THAT
YES THANK YOU BYE BYE BYE
CRISIS. YOU WILL GO TO LINE
THREE NINE ONE THREE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY
CLIMB THREE NINETY ONE ARE YOU
ON MUTE. FORMER BONTA THREE
SIXTY THREE THREE SIX THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON.
LORI FOR MILD HER NAME WE ARE
IN THE- THANK YOU. I AM. SIX
THREE SIXTY FIVE. WHEN I
FEATHER BED ME NUMBER SEVEN
LOOK BUT ALSO IN THE INCREDIBLE
CRITICAL NEED A FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY UP ALL YOUR LIFE THEY
MAY LOOK AT THE WAY THEY SEE IT
THEY WILL COME THE- CLASSES.
ALIGN ONE SIXTY TWO ONE SIX TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I'M A
CHRISTIAN. SIX SEE OUR OR YOUR
FOR YOU ARE NOT YOUR INCOME
BOTH FROM ALL MY AGE THE OTHER
VEHICLE THAT IS NOT THE
GOVERNMENT THE GOVERNMENT
DANIELS HE DAHLE UP OR YOU'LL
OUR LIFE MAYBE IT'LL BUT THEY
THINK THAT YES. CRISIS. LINE
THREE FIVE SEVEN THREE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS WITH THE THEATER THEA
AND I REMEMBERED- NONPROFIT
STATION LOCATED TO THE LEFT OF
THE US. AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA LESS SUPPORTIVE
COALITION HE AND I'M OPTIMISTIC
MORTAR CUP OF BANK I DO HOUSE
CLEANING OR NINETY. AND I HAVE
PROBABLY A GOOD FOR SB TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I AM THREE FOUR ONE THREE FOUR
ONE NEARLY IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. I WOULD EARLY
I AM A COMMUNICATIONS YOU FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC
WORKERS- AND COALITION AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT AT THAT
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN I HOPE THAT
YOU WILL INCUR. AND HOW AND
TAKE A REGULATIONS AND
PROTECTION THANKS VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE THREE
SIX ONE THREE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. A RESPONSE TO A CHAIR
OF THE COALITION GOVERNMENT
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS ARE STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE THREE
SEVEN THREE THREE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI AFTER
CHRISTINA BUT NORMAL TEN OF
REPRESENTING U. D. W. SORRY I'M
GETTING A REALLY BAD TO BE BACK
ON THE LINE- WE ARE MONSTERS
YOU SB. TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN AND
ARE IN. THE PORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE FOR ALL FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALLOW ME A
MULLIN BURKE ON BEHALF OF WORK
EQUITY IN SUPPORT OF SB- BUT
THE THAT. THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
OH SEVEN FOUR ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH THE GARMENT WITH.
AT EIGHT TWELVE PROJECT HAVE
AND THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WHEN ALL. HELLO LINE ONE
FOUR SEVEN ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT NOW ALL.
SEE THE CONTRACT THREE THANK.
OKAY WHEN I STARTED GOING
LONGER. BOOKED MILLARD AFFECT
THE THAT BUT YOU. YUP BUT AGAIN
THE NC A LOT IT'S A BAY BILL
FIFTY ONE THANKS GET THE- S. S.
I AM THREE TWENTY SEVEN THREE
TWO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MEGAN WHALEN WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION I LIVE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF IT BECAUSE THE D.
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE THREE SIX FOUR THREE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE SIX FOUR IF YOU WANT TO
SHARE COMMENTS. WILL MOVE THE
LINE THREE FOUR FOUR THREE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
HAD A. LINE THREE FORTY FOUR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO STATE YOUR
POSITION. OR MOVE TIMELINE ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT ONE EIGHT EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE. LINE
FOR ELEVEN FOUR ONE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NOT
JUST A LITTLE THE NEXT I LIVE
IN CONSTANT COMBAT I AM A
MEMBER OF THE DAY AND
CALIFORNIA'S DOMESTIC WORKERS
COLLECTION I'VE HAD THE WORK.
AND I SAID IT THE THIRD FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE ONE FOUR FOUR ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ABOUT THIS ISSUE LINE ONE FORTY
FOUR TO JOIN A STATE YOUR
POSITION. THE PROBLEM. WILL
MOVE THE LINE FOR EIGHTEEN FOUR
ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO. ARE THE
YEAH HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
OKAY GREAT MY NAME IS RONALD
WILSON I AM A SENIOR HEALTH
EDUCATOR LIVING IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB FOUR SEVEN AS
WELL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BLIND TO SIXTY FIVE TWO SIX
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOTTOM
LINE TWO FORTY TWO FOUR ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AT THIS TIME.
YEAH. LINE ONE SEVENTY FIVE ONE
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE FOR ALL EIGHT FOUR ZERO
EIGHT THE LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES MY NAME ME
THINK OF IDEA AND REMEMBER
VITAL LOCAL IF YOU WANT
SOMETHING THIS CALL I HAVE BEEN
ON THE WITH THE WORK OF FOR
THREE YEARS AN ACTIVE FOR A BI.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE TWO
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TWO FIVE THREE. ALLOWING
SEVENTY NOTED. THAT AGE SHE LED
THE WILL NOT THANK HIM IS. IT
ABOUT THE OTHER FOR THE INSIDE
OF THE BEND OF THE APPLE YEAH
LEVELS THAT THEY IT IS.
CONVICTED BECAUSE. LINE. FOR
TWO TO FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL. LINE. TWO FOUR THREE TO
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE THE. LINE.
THREE NINE THREE THREE NINETY.
LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE. ONE
SEVENTY DID YOU WANT TO STATE
YOUR POSITION. NEXT TO A LINE
TO FORTY TWO FOUR ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. INTO FOUR ZERO
THAT YOU WANT TO STATE YOUR
POSITION. CHICKEN WINGS YOUR-
LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE ONE FIVE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
IT AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS IN Q. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT AS MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION. HOWEVER LIKE TO
OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT-
ANYONE OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM.
IF NOT WE'LL ONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. I REALLY
HOPE SOMEONE USE THAT SOME
POINT TODAY LET ME FIND. AND
IT'S MODERATOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU IF YOUR POSITION IS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE TWO FIVE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE BEEN
THERE ALL. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WATCH HERE THE PEOPLE. CHIEF OF
THE. WHAT BY AND FOUR THREE
SEVEN YOUR LINE OF THE PARTIES
OUT. THE NUMBER IS AROUND.
THIRTY OF THEM NUMBER BUT
MEMBER OF YUR YOU MUST HAVE A
BETTER FOR THE I KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE NOT A- UP OF THOSE. YEAH
THAT'S- WHAT THE. MARCH THE
SUPPORT IF. THAT'S LOOK NO
FURTHER THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU AND WE IT WAS A
I HAVE HEARD RUNNING ON A
MOTION AS ARE MOST WAS NOT ABLE
FROM. THE WHAT ARE THE WAS ONE
YEAH FROM. AND I HAVE BECAUSE
ALL THREE AS A I'M ANY COMMENTS
FOR ANYONE. THAT CLICK THE
RECORD YES PLEASE BUT I AND I
WANTED SENATOR ALSO THERE A LOT
OF BILLS I VOTE ON I REALLY
WANT TO THANK YOU ESPECIALLY
FOR MY GRANDMOTHER WHO WAS A
DOMESTIC WORKER AND FOR YEARS I
USED TO HEAR STORIES OF HER
GOING TO SOMEONE ELSE'S HOME
SHE RAISE EIGHT KIDS PUSH TO
RAISE TWO OTHERS IN SOMEBODY
ELSE'S HOME. AND FOR YEARS I
WOULD HEAR ABOUT HER HAVING TO
LEAVE THE HOUSE. TO GO REYES
OTHER PEOPLE'S HOMES CLING
THEIR HOMES ROOM BOB I CAN
IMAGINE TO CHEMICALS SHE CAME
IN CONTACT. THEIR ALL THOSE
THOSE DECADES OF CLEAN SOMEONE
ELSE'S ON AN INCOMING THEIR- WE
SHOULD HAVE A POT OF BEANS ON
THE STOVE BUT IT WOULD DECEMBER
FOR EIGHT HOURS. I NEVER
UNDERSTOOD WHY WE DID THAT AND
WAS BECAUSE SHE WOULD BE THERE
DURING THE DAY AND SHE HAD TO
FEED A KIDS. AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE IT NOW I
GET AN OPPORTUNITY ACTUALLY
VOTE ON SOMETHING THAT IS CLOSE
TO MY FAMILY AND TO MY CART.
AND I REALLY WANT ONE THANK YOU
AND IT. AND I'LL LEAVE YOU WITH
THIS LOOK FOR A LONG TIME WE
USED TO EAT. HOLIDAY DINNERS AT
TWO O'CLOCK IN THE AFTERNOON.
AND A TO SAY THIS IS THE
DUMBEST THING I MEAN I'M NOT
I'M HUNGRY LATER WHY WE DOING
THAT I FOUND OUT LATER. IT
BECAUSE SHE HAD TO COOK.
CHRISTMAS THANKSGIVING OR
EASTER AT TO CRESCENTA GULF
COOK FOR SOMEBODY ELSE'S HOME.
AND SERVICE. AT FOUR FIVE AND
SIX O'CLOCK. AND THEN SHE WOULD
COME BACK HOME AGAIN THE CARD
FOR THE NEXT DAY. AND ARE CLEAN
AND SHE KEPT IN IMMACULATE
HOUSE. AND SHE KEPT IN BACK OF
HOUSE OF ISSUES SUPER I DON'T
KNOW HOW. SHE DID IT TO THIS
DAY. CELA ON. I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU ON. BEHALF OF MY GRAD
GRANDMOTHER. COULD THIS IS THIS
IS REALLY KIND OF CLOSE TO ME.
A POOR ME AVOID THE- CLASSIEST
IN A DARK THE RISE OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND TO ANSWER ANYONE
ELSE LIKE TO MAKE COMMENTS
AMERICANS OUT- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US OBVIOUSLY. I'LL GET
TO SEE IT AGAIN AND- I THINK IF
I'M NOT A CO AUTHOR ALREADY I'D
LIKE TO BE ONE- I JUST WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS WHO MIGHT BE
WATCHING THOUGH BECAUSE WE KEEP
GETTING THIS QUESTION- HOW IT
WHETHER IT THERE ARE OTHER
RIGHTS THAT DOMESTIC WORKERS
AND HOUSEHOLD EMPLOYEES HAVE.
AND I KNOW THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE LOOKING FOR PEOPLE TO COME
IN THEIR HOMES RIGHT NOW TO
HELP MAYBE WITH THEIR FRIENDS
AND ALL OF THAT IS GOVERNED
IT'S NOT COVERED BY AB FIVE IT
WAS IT WAS PART OF LAW LONG
BEFORE AB FIVE IT FEDERAL TAX
IRA. BUT GOOD HOUSEHOLD
EMPLOYEES IN ET DE AND THE
RULES OF CLEAR SUCH AS WHAT
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
BECAUSE IN A TUNNEL THERE'S- WE-
WASN'T. A FIVE ALL LONG GOING
TO JAIL WE COULD. IN YOU WOULD
SEE HAVE TO EMPLOY A PRO.
HOUSEHOLD EMPLOYEES AND SO
THANK YOU EVERY TIME YOU. BRING
A BILL I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE-
OPERATE OUTSIDE OF THE LAW IN
THIS. AREA IN RIGHT NOW IS A
REALLY DANGEROUS TIME TO BE
DOING THAT SO. THANK YOU FOR
TRYING TO ADD A- PROTECTIONS
BECAUSE THEY DESERVE FULL
PROTECTIONS LIKE THE OTHER
EMPLOYEES. ARE LAW I KNOW YOU
KNOW. PLACE I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THEM
THANK AT. THE CORPORATE. YEAH
ANYONE ELSE THINK. THE YEAH I
ALSO WOULD BE HONORED A CO
AUTHOR THIS BILL AND AS YOU
INDICATED IN YOUR INTRODUCTORY
COMMENTS SENATOR TO ALSO- THIS
REALLY DOES THIS IS ABOUT HIS
HISTORIC INJUSTICES HISTORIC
RACISM. BUT IT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH FOR US IS TO ACKNOWLEDGE
HISTORIC SYSTEMIC RACISM UNLESS
WE'RE WILLING TO ACT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT TODAY- TO
SUMMER JONES PLAYERS UP
COMMENTS I THINK THAT SPEAKS TO
A LINEAR SYSTEM SOME THAT WE
ALL KNOW HOW TO REDUCE ABOUT SO
I'M VERY GRATEFUL ONE LAST
POINT AND SENT THE- A LITTLE
BIT FROM. THE THIRTY REALLY
APPRECIATE WORK ON THE BECAUSE
I KNOW YOU OF COURSE CLEARLY
THERE IS THERE SOME DIVEST
WORKERS ARE CARING FOR THOSE
THAT. MAY NOT HAVE THE ABILITY.
pCONDITIONS THE ANSWER ISN'T TO
INTRODUCE- DOMESTIC WORKER TO
POOR ROAD CONDITIONS THE ANSWER
IS TO GET HELP. THE PERSON WITH
A DISABILITY TO IMPROVE THEIR
QUALITY OF LIFE AS WELL AND WE
CAN REALLY CREATE A WIN WIN OUT
OF THIS. FOR THE WORKER AND FOR
THOSE THEIR CARING FOR AND I
THINK ULTIMATELY THAT'S WHAT I
KNOW YOU BELIEVE IN AND- SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THAT.
WE DO HAVE A- MOTION AND OF
THIS. PROMOTION FOR FROM THERE
AGAIN SALAS ACTED BY SUMMER
RIVAS. SENATOR RUSSELL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY CLOSING.
COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
IBM THANK YOU. THANK YOU- BUT
THE FAMILY PLANNING FOR CAN
TAKE A ROLE IN THAT. SINISTER
FOR. KALRA HI KALRA AYE FLORA
FLORA I CARILLO CARILLO I DEEP.
AND HARPER- OKAY DEEP HIGH
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER I TOM SAWYER AYE
THREE OF US THREE OF US HI ALL
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
A SANDRA RUSSELL AND THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO BE THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE WHENEVER YOU ARE READY
THANK YOU. SIR ANOTHER GROUP OF
WOMEN TO FACE THANK. BUT THE
FOOTBALL. OKAY SO RIGHT NOW
THESE- PRIMARILY WOMEN THE
GARMIN AND STEER ARE MAKING ARE
A LOT OF OUR PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT THAT WE NEED TO RE
OPEN AND REBUILD AND THEY'RE
DOING THIS WORK AN UNSAFE
CONDITIONS AND OFTENTIMES FOR
AS LITTLE AS FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR THAT'S ONE THE MINIMUM
WHAT. NEIGHBORHOOD OF ALL THESE
THINGS I WON'T GET INTO DETAILS
BUT- LAST WEEK WEEK OR SO AGO-
TWO WEEKS WE LEARNED OF AN LA
BASED FACTORY. THAT EXPRESS AN
OUTBREAK OF ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED
POSITIVE COVERT CASES AND FOUR
DEATHS SO SB NINE NINE PROTECT
WORKERS YES ABSOLUTELY BUT IT
ALSO PROTECTS BUSINESSES. WHO
DO THE RIGHT THING TO DO I'LL
GIVE THE PROTECTIONS TO DO PAY
THE RIGHT THING SO THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR IN THIS BILL ELIMINATING
THE PIECE RATE IN THE INDUSTRY
SOME. WORKERS CAN STILL EARN
INCENTIVE BASED BONUSES ABOVE
THEIR LEGAL WAGES SO. I'VE
HEARD- HOW ARE WE GOING TO YOU
KNOW INCENTIVIZE BLAH BLAH
BLAH. PAY THE LEGAL WAGE AND
THEN YOU CAN HAVE A BONUS ON
TOP. AND FORCING LIABILITY UP.
MORE FORCE MEANT OF LIABILITY
FOR WAGE VIOLATIONS- CREATE A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION AS TO
THE IDENTITIES OF THE
GUARANTORS. BASED ON THE
GARMENT WORKERS TESTIMONY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE INFORMATION
LIKE THEY TAKE THE LABELS THEY
HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION THAT
IDENTIFIES A GROWING TOWARDS
AND THAT'S WHAT. WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO USE. EXPLICITLY
AUTHORIZED THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER OF A BUREAU FIELD
ENFORCEMENT TO INVESTIGATE AND
SITE THE BRANDS. WAS A WAGE THE
DARK REPORT- COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT I THINK OF THAT REPORT
THAT STAND OUT OF. TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN LOST EARNINGS ONE IN
THE THIRD MILLION DOLLARS IN
LOST INCOME TAX. AND FORTITUDE
AND I MILLION DOLLARS IN LOST
SALES TAX REVENUE SO COLLEAGUES
THIS IS THIS IS YOU START OUT
THE WORKERS THEMSELVES THEIR
CONDITIONS. GET PAID WHAT THEY
SHOULD BUT ALSO THE LOSS TO THE
STATE THE LOSS TO MONEY THAT
SHOULD BE COMING INTO THE
STATE- OF MANY MANUFACTURERS
HAVE NO INCENTIVE. ON A TO DO
THE RIGHT THING- AND THE WAY
THE LAW UNLESS THEY FACE
LIABILITY- IT IS THE
LEGISLATIVE WERE CLUB PRICE TO
STAND WITH THESE OF. VULNERABLE
WORKERS A TODAY WE HAVE TWO
EXPERTS ON THE PHONE GARMENT
WORKER FRANCISCO SOON AS WELL
AS MATTHEW D. CAROLUS FROM BED
STATIC TESTIFYING. THANK YOU
SENATOR OF AND ONCE AGAIN-
EACH- WITNESS HAS UP TO TWO
MINUTES AND SO WE CAN START
WITH MR SUIT. HI OUR BUT
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OUR
PRACTICE WHO WITH THE GARMENT
WORKER CENTER I WON'T NOT A
CLOTHING FACTORY IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA EACH A BREAKING
HOWEVER IF THE DAYS HE CAME
BECOME A PRINCIPAL IN IOWA
THERE ARE PERSONAL HAVE TO. THE
PEOPLE ARE. ONLY EARNING A SLOW
US FOR EXAMPLE DOLLARS PER WEEK.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING HE HE-
THAT IS MIKE THREE I GET THANKS
BYE HE- YOU OR ARE BROWN. WHERE
WALKING ONE HUNDRED THEY WE BY
THE BC A BIRTHDAY. IRONICALLY
THE PEACE RATING BUT- MORE
PRINCE ONE MAKE. EIGHT EIGHT.
EASIER TO MAKE THE- HE I AM ONE
OF THE HE HAD THE SEVENTY
EMPLOYEES COOL GUY EFFECT OF
THE A LOS ANGELES UP CAL
COMPANY WHILE PRODUCE MALL. ARE
WE MY A FOR IN ONE OLD A FEW
PLACES THAT AGE MANY WAYS THERE
WERE CERTAIN MEANS. EXPERIENCE
I STOP FOR A LARGE IMPORTANT IN
MY LIFE. IT'LL AND CAN NOW. I'M
VERY FORTUNATE I'M STILL ALIVE.
I'D LIKE SEND MY COME. TO
FAMILIES OF THE WAR THINK HOME
DIED LOT OF WEIGHT I LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO ME. MY OWN STORY
THE BUT THE- THERE BROUGHT ME
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK UP ON
BEHALF OF THE DAY WITHOUT OF
WHO ARE APPLYING SPEAK UP ABOUT
THIS. WHICH IS IN THE
GOVERNMENT IN. YEAH. WELL
GETTING DESPERATE ABOUT IF YOU
TAKE. HE WON'T GIVE ME A SHOT A
HARD TIME DO NOT WANT GROUP
THEORY. ON ALL THIS NOT MORE
THAN SPEND TIME PROGRAM. SHOWN
TO DATE ONE THANKS TO THREE
WHEN HE HE THOUGHT KHôNG
CHANGE OUR OWN FINANCING. OR
THE. OUR WORK OUR SCREAMING I
MOVED DOWN THAT THEY'RE WORKING
WE. APPROVING WELL. BUT ONE
HAVE BEEN FOR THEM IN IMPROVING
THE ECONOMY KEEP FOR HONG HANH.
OKAY. CALIFORNIA GARMENT
WALDRON OUR RANGE OF WON'T. IN
THE HOPE OR OUR LAWMAKERS DON'T
WON'T ON. WHAT ALL IF YOU
LOOKING DO NOT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND DON'T
GET YOUR- THANK YOU. NOTHING TO
MATTER TO CURE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU HONORABLE MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER TO BETTER LIKE
LEGAL SERVICES TO THE NONPROFIT
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
REPRESENTED GARMENT WORKERS FOR
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS WE ARE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL
ALONG WITH GARMENT WORKER
CENTER WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. ANY TWENTY YEARS IN
THE CASE OF HUNDREDS OF CLIENTS
WE HAVE BUT THAT I KEPT SEEING
WHAT MISTER TOOL PRESCRIBED SO
POWERFULLY. USE THAT PIECE RATE
IT'S AN INGRAINED PART OF THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY'S ECONOMIC
MODEL. THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR'S RANDOM INSPECTIONS
HAVE BEEN COVERED AND 85%
VIOLATION RATE. WHICH
DEMONSTRATES THE DEPTHS OF THE
PROBLEMS WITH THE PIECE RATE.
THE PEACE RIGHT NOT ONLY RESULT
IN WAIT STAFF BUT ALSO HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROBLEMS. UNDER THE
PEACE RTE WORKERS DO NOT GET
PAID FOR TIME TO SANITIZE THEIR
WORKSTATION OR WASH THEIR HANDS.
THE THREE THAT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH THREAT FOR THESE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ESPECIALLY IN
THAT COVERED PANDEMIC. IN
ADDITION A CHAIN COMPANIES THAT
USE SUBCONTRACTING THE HOUSE
THEIR CLOTHING MADE UNLAWFUL
CONDITIONS ARE NOT HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. I WORKERS FILE
WAGE CLAIM THESE COMPANIES ARE
NOT FOUND LIABLE EVEN WHEN
WORKERS SUBMIT THE COMPANY'S
LABELED AS EVIDENCE.
FURTHERMORE THE STATE'S HANDS
ARE TIED AS THE BUREAU FIELD
ENFORCEMENT CANNOT CURRENTLY
SITE UP CHAIN COMPANIES IN
WORKPLACE Y. GARMENT
INVESTIGATION. THE TIME HAS
COME TO CLOSE THESE LOOPHOLES
THAT THE GARMENT INDUSTRY HAS
EVOLVED TO EXPLOIT. SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE COMES FULL CIRCLE
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
EXPANDED UP CHAIN LIABILITY IN
OTHER INDUSTRIES SINCE THE
RESULT GARMENT BILL IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA STATE CONTROL
GARMENT WORKERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. RIGHT WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT. RUN ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. AND
FINALLY UP FOR A MODERATOR TO
BE IF ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE AND AGAIN HIS NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND YOUR
POSITION. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL IN
Q. FOUR FULL CLIMB THREE NINETY
THREE THREE NINE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE NINE THREE
ARE YOU IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THREE NINE NINE. HOME OF THE
LINE ONE EIGHT EIGHT.
1-111-811-8911 EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR NUMBER CATALINA
DANCE AS THE CARBON IN KAISER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME IN THE COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE NINETY
EIGHT NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT CHEN MEMBERS. AND
WITH THE HELP AT OUR WORK IN
BUT THANK YOU. LINE. THREE
FORTY FIVE THREE FOUR FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER THAT THEY
WROTE OF WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE THREE SIXTY ONE
THREE SIX ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RESPOND TO THE TERM OF THE
QUALITY THE MAN BANKING STOCKS
BEFORE THANK YOU. LINE ONE
TWENTY TWO ONE TWO TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I GUESS GOOD
AFTERNOON MAKING OUR CHIEF
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OFTHE TO
THE LEFT ON BEFORE THAT GOOD
FOR THE CALIFORNIA EVENTS GOT
BELIEVERS INTERNET THE QUIRK OF
THE STRONG SUPPORT OF GARMENT
WORKERS SB THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE. THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
FIVE THREE FIVE CAROLINA'S OPEN.
SEVEN MEN TEN WITH PLACES FOR
PROGRESS IN FIFTEEN OF BUSINESS
LEADERS WE HAVE A PRIORITY
SUPPORT ON THE BILL. THANK YOU.
I AM FOUR FOUR SIX FOUR FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
KEVIN CANSECO FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE THANKS
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN FOUR FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LAURIE FURSTENFELD SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. XO GO TO
LINE NINETEEN ONE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MICHELLE
DUGGAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION PROBABLY CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL OR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
FIFTY FOUR FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TURN ON YOUR MULLIN
BURKE WITH BURKE EQUITY AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. LINE FOUR FOUR THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM A
FAILURE CALIFORNIA AND BEFORE.
THANK YOU. LINE FOUR TWO EIGHT
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NICOLE MARKETS WITH WORK
STATES IN JOHN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ARE
MADE WITH THE NATIONAL PLAN A
LOT PROJECT IN SPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE THREE SIXTY THREE SIX
THEY'RE ALL YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORALITY BUT I'LL REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. PINE TO FORTY THREE
TO FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO FOUR THREE ARE YOU ON
MUTE. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO SIX
ONE TO SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO JESSICA PARK OVER
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WE ARE IN CONCERT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
340-430-0404 PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OUR. BURGER LINE ONE SIX EIGHT
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PRICELINE THREE
TWO SEVEN THREE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. HI YES THIS IS
AGAIN WHERE AND WITH A
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION WE'RE IN STRONG
SYMBOL FOR AN INVOLUNTARY WITH
THE GARMENT WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE. FOR FIFTY FIVE
FOUR FIVE FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS THIS IS MICHELLE GAYLE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A THREE ONE
TWO NINE NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE TWO THIRTY THREE TWO
THREE THREE IN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A BIGGER COMPANY OF A.
YES. HELLO PROTECTION RING TRUE
THAT ONE YES PLEASE THREE THREE
OKAY YOU FOUR FIVE SIX FOUR
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
NUMBER OR YOUR NUMBER. YOUR
FATHER ON THE PHONE SELECT. THE
CORPORATE BORROWING FAILURES
YOUR PHONE NUMBER. THE
REQUESTED ITEMS UP FOR YOUR
LIFE SEVEN AND ONE THING LED TO.
BUT AFTER. CRISIS WIND OH SIX
ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS MICHELLE I'M AN
INDEPENDENT GARMENT PRODUCTION
CONSULTANT WORKING WITH
MULTIPLE LOCAL AREA BROWN AND
WORN OUT FRONT FOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THREE FIND. THREE
THREE SIX THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK.
OKAY RACKET- THE OWNER OF THE
BRANDS AND THE TEMPO THAT IS
AID IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES I
AM AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. NINE FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN FOUR FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ELI LONG
NECTAR AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
WORKER CENTER NETWORK VOICE ACT
THE COURT FOR AT THE THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT OVER THE LINE FOR SIX
ONE FOUR SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I UNDER ON THE HALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATE AND A
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK AND STRONG SUPPORT ALSO
ON THE HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
THE COURT. THANK YOU. LINE FOR
FIVE POINT FOUR FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
NICHOLAS BRAUN AND THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT FASHION REVOLUTION
USA OUR ORGANIZATION INCLUDES
DESIGNERS MAKERS WORKERS
ACADEMIC BUSINESS LEADERS
BRANDS AND RETAILERS AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE AND HOPE YOU WILL
TOO THANK YOU. THANK YOU. X.
WILL GO TO LINES. FOR SIXTY
FOUR SIX ZERO. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. YES HELLO THIS IS JILL
THOMPSON I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES
AND I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH PUBLIC
COUNSELS WOMEN AND GIRLS RIGHTS
PROJECT AND I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT TO- STATED WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT- THIRTEEN NINETY NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OUR LAST
LINE IN Q. WAS. FOR FORTY NINE
FOUR FOUR NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO EVERYONE DANIEL MOLINA
CALIFORNIA STATE DIRECTOR OF
MISSION TO LIVE OUT THE SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY NINE NINE. THANK
YOU. ALL IGHT SO- WILL MOVE ON
TO A POSITION IN TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE BEEN HAVING
WITH CAL OF CAL CHAMBER BY
PHONE. THANK YOU MISTER. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON BUT
I'VE BECOME HALF WHICH CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE OPPOSE
THAT THIRTEEN A NINE. BUT WE DO
NOT TO KIDDO WHICH THE IN ANY.
HOWEVER THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT BILL THAT MAKES A
NUMBER OF DRAMATIC CHANGES TO
THE REGULATION OF GARMENT
MANUFACTURING THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED OVER TWENTY YEARS
AGO IT AB SIX THIRTY THREE BY
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEINBERG.
NUMBER OF SPECIFIC CONCERT WITH
THIS PROPOSAL AT FIRST THIS
BILL ELIMINATE PIECE COP AND-
THE IS WITHOUT PRECEDENT AND
SHOULD BE CAREFULLY CONSIDERED.
THAT WE GENERALLY DO NOT LIMIT
HOW AN EMPLOYER IN ANY INDUSTRY
MAY COMPENSATE WORKERS BE AT
DOLLERY HOURLY OR PIECE RATE.
ARKANSAS APPLET MINIMAL WAITED
OVERTIME LAWS ARE COMPLIED WITH.
IF WORKERS ARE BEING PAID PIECE
RATES THAT ARE BEING PAID LESS
THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE THAT IS A
VIOLATION OF EXISTING LAW WE
WOULD SUGGEST THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE RATHER THAN HE
NEED TO ELIMINATE A
LONGSTANDING FORM OF
COMPENSATION IN THE INDUSTRY
AND SUCH AN- UNPRECEDENTED
BANNER. SECOND THIS BILL
IMPOSES AUTOMATIC JOINT
LIABILITY ON BRANDS. THIS IS A
MAJOR POLICY ISSUE AND WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH
IMPOSING. LIABILITY ON ANOTHER
ENTITY THAT HAS NO CONTROL OVER
THE WORKING CONDITIONS. A
PREVIOUS BILLS RELATED TO JOINT
LIABILITY ALSO HAVE ALL GONE
THROUGH THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
THAN THIS BILL HAS LOCKED.
THIRD THE BILL ESTABLISHES A
NEW CATEGORY OF BRAND GEAR
TOURS. WHICH IS SO BROADLY
DEFINED THAT INCLUDES ANY
PERSON OR ENTITY IN THE
CLOTHING INDUSTRY. THE DRY
CLEANERS SMALL LARGE RETAILERS
SECOND HAND RETAILERS AND MANY
MORE. FOR THIS BILL IMPROPERLY
CREATES TWO SEPARATE
EVIDENTIARY STANDARDS A
PRESUMPTION OF JOINT LIABILITY
IS CREATED WHERE AN EMPLOYEE
NEARLY PRODUCES A LABEL. BUT
THE PLAYER CANNOT DEFEND WITH
WITNESS DECLARATION. AND
STATEMENTS PROVIDE OTHER QUOTE
COMPELLING AND RELIABLE WRITTEN
EVIDENCE. THIS IS FUNDAMENTALLY
I'M IMPROPER AND VIOLATES DUE
PROCESS TO OPPOSED TO DIFFERENT
EVIDENTIARY STANDARDS. AND
ISSUE HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED BY
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. I MANY
OF THE NEW PER DO NOT APPLY
WHERE THERE'S A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS IMPROPER GREETS
INCONSISTENT STANDARDS AND
LIKELY RUN THE FILE THE
NATIONAL LABOR RELATIONS ACT.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE. AND
ASKED FOR A NO VOTE ON SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE WE
RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST THIS ISSUE
SHOULD BE APPROPRIATE FOR
DISCUSSION NEXT YEAR WHEN IT
COULD BE PROPERLY BY THE BY ALL
OF THE RELEVANT. COMMITTEES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WE WILL
GO ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT ANYONE
IN THE ROOM. WILL MOVE ON TO
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. AND
THEN I FINALLY MODERATOR OF WE
CAN HAVE- OPPOSITION IS ON THE
PHONE AGAIN NAME PHILLIES. AND
THE POSITION. SHARE YOUR
POSITION IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE ONE LINE ONE MOMENT.
LINE THREE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CALLER ONLINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THERE ARE NO OTHER
COMMENTS IN Q. THAT CONTINUE.
OKAY BRING ABOUT COMMITTEE.
SERVICE. THANK YOU I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS- FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
IT'S VERY PERSONAL TO ME I
REMEMBER AS A KID YOU KNOW WE
HAD FAMILY FRIENDS THAT WORKED
IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY AND I
REMEMBER GOING TO THESE
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES THAT
ARE IN MY DISTRICT IN SAN
FERNANDO AND IN WATCHING WHAT
THEY DID AND WHEN I REMEMBER
EVEN AS A KID MATH DIDN'T UP
YOU KNOW LIKE THINKING OF. YOU
KNOW THIS WOMAN THE WOMEN THERE
GETTING PAID PIECE BY PIECE AND
I WOULD MULTIPLY IT BY HOW MANY
THEY CAN DO PER HOUR AND EVEN
THOUGH I WAS REALLY YOUNG IS
LIKE THIS IS NOT FAIR IT'S NOT
A LIVABLE WAGE IT'S NOT EVEN
MINIMUM WAGE- IN SO JUST JUST
REMEMBERING THOSE MOMENTS AS A
CHILD YOU KNOW THOSE FACTORIES
HAVING WALKING THEN AND IN GAME.
AN EXPLOIT IT HEY EN. X. AND
THE OTHER. WELL I'M YES SEVERAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR THE
RAFFLE FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
ECHO MY COLLEAGUE SENTIMENT AND
I WOULD ALSO ECHO THAT AND
STATE THAT FOR MANY OF THE
MANUFACTURERS IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND CLOSE TO DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES WHO EMPLOYEE- THE IS
VERY IMPORTANT AND ESSENTIAL
WORKERS THEY SHOULD BE
INCREDIBLY ASHAMED FOR NOT
PROVIDING THE NECESSARY
PROTECTIONS FOR THE WORKERS FOR
NOT PROVIDING THE SPACE
NECESSARY. THERE WERE OVER
THREE HUNDRED GARMENT WORKERS
IN LOS ANGELES ALONE THE TESTED
POSITIVE FOR THAT IS COMPLETE
UNACCEPTABLE IT HAS BROUGHT
LIGHT ON HOW COMMUNITY THE
LATINO IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THESE
WORKERS ARE MOST DEMOCRATS IN A
WOMEN ARE. EXCLUDED FROM
PROTECTIONS AND SEEN AS-
INVALUABLE BARB LESS THAN AND
THEY'RE PROTECTIONS AND IN OUR
ABILITY FOR SOCIETY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. THE IMPORTANCE OF
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY AND FOR THAT I
AM THANKFUL TO YOU IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
SUPPORT TO THESE WORKERS AND TO
SHED LIGHT AGAIN ON THE
INCREDIBLE INJUSTICE HAPPENS IN
THE WORKPLACE WHEN WORKERS ARE
OFTEN IGNORED OR LEFT ON. SO
THANK YOU. TO LEARN CONSULT.
THANK YOU I'M PROUD TO BE A AT
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR- ON THIS
BILL AND I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK TO SOME OF THE GARMENT
WORKERS IN LA AND I I'LL JUST
NEVER FORGET THE WOMAN'S STORY
OF- HAVING TO GO RIGHT BACK TO
WORK TO MAKE ENOUGH- AFTER
SHE'D HAD A BABY IN BRINGING
THE BABY WITH HER TO THE
FACTORY IN PUTTING THE BABY IN
A BOX- BECAUSE SHE HAD TO SHE
JUST HAD A SO PASSED IN AND GET
SO MUCH DONE. AND THERE WAS NO
OTHER OPTION- THESE ARE THE
KIND CONDITIONS WE HAVE RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S
DEPLORABLE AND YOU KNOW SO MANY
OF US EVER BEING COLLEGE THERE
IS A BIG- NATIONAL CAMPAIGN
ABOUT SWEAT SHOPS IN COLLEGE T.
SHIRTS AND WHAT WE HOW WE COULD
LOOK AT- THE THESE
MANUFACTURERS AND WHERE THEY
WERE GETTING THEIR PRODUCTS AND
THIS IS OVERSEAS AND WE DIDN'T
THINK ABOUT IT HAPPENING RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ME SOME OF
US DID. WHAT YOU KNOW BUT- WE
KNEW IT HAPPENED AND SO WHEN
THESE MANUFACTURERS SAY THAT
THEY HAVE NO CONTROL OF IT.
WE'VE WATCH THEM IN FOREIGN
COUNTRIES GO AND SEND
INSPECTORS AND THIS IS JUST
RIGHT DOWN THE STREET FROM
THEIR OFFICES. SO I THINK THIS
IS THERE'S NO EXCUSE THERE'S NO
EXCUSE FOR THAT THERE'S NO
EXCUSE FOR THIS KIND OF WAGE
THAT. AND IT'S TIME THAT WE
HAVE LIABILITY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE ARE PURCHASING THE CLOTHES
AND JUST SUBCONTRACTING OUT
DOES NOT. IT DOESN'T HELP. WHAT
RIGHT SO. THANK YOU IT'S- ONE
OF MY FAVORITE BILLS OF THE
YEAR IS YOU KNOW. I WAS SO
JEALOUS THAT YOU GOT IT BEFORE
I DID HAVE. BUT I AM PROUD TO
BE YOUR PRINCIPAL- CO AUTHOR
AND A LOOK FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY
PRESENTING ON THE FLOOR. THANK
YOU SOMERS OCTOBER AND I TO
APPOINT A THANK YOU AND I ALSO
THINK WE ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE TO
FIFTY NINE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT OP
THE- LA APPAREL IS IN MY
DISTRICT. LA PERILS WHERE THEY
HAD HUNDREDS OF INDIVIDUAL OF
EMPLOYEES THE HEAD COVE IT. AND
SEVERAL DIED. RESET IT AGAIN
SEVERAL DIED AND SO THAT OWNER
IS NOW. NOT ONLY THE GREAT WORK
OF LA COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
SHUTTING THEM DOWN. PUTTING IN-
THE KIND OF PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE NEEDED OF THIS INDIVIDUAL
PUTTING CARDBOARD IN BETWEEN
EACH PERSON IS STEP PLEXIGLASS.
AND HE THOUGHT THAT CARDBOARD
WOULD KEEP CORONAVIRUS FROM
GOING TO EACH PERSON. OF I ALSO
TOLD HIM THIS IS A CHANCE FOR
REDEMPTION EVEN TOLD OF THE
CHAMBER AND MANY FACTORS THAT
WE NEED TO COME IN TO IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND START WORKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE WORKERS
ARE SAFE. ESPECIALLY NOT IT WE
GOT TO ISSUED UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY AND FORTUNE IS A
TERRIBLE OPPORTUNITY BUT IT BUT
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO CLEAN UP.
THIS THE SWEATSHOPS IN A WAY
THAT WE NEVER HAD BEFORE AND
USE ALL OUR RESOURCES BECAUSE
IT'S A HEALTH RISK IT'S A
HEALTH DISASTER RIGHT NOW AND
IF WE DO THAT NOW STARTING NOW.
AND START TO GET MORE MORE
THESE MANUFACTURERS TO DO THAT-
WHEN WE COME OUT OF THIS I
THINK WOULD HAVE COME OUT THIS
MUCH BETTER YOUR BILL. WILL GET
IS THERE MUCH FURTHER MUCH
QUICKER AND IF WE ALL COME
TOGETHER. TO MAKE HAPPEN AYE I
THINK- FIVE YEARS DOWN THE LINE
WE WILL REMEMBER THIS DAY THAT
WE VOTED FOR THIS. BOOK. BY AND
I WOULD LOVE TO BE CO AUTHOR
ALSO. BUT THEY ONE IN I ALSO
LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S A WONDERFUL
BILL- AND TO- ESTARá CORREOS
POINT TALKING ABOUT. THE COVERT
FATALITIES COVETED FACTION. FOR
EXAMPLE A CO IT IS NOT CREATING
A IS SIX. EXISTING LONG
STANDING INEQUITIES AND JUST
BECAUSE A PRACTICES
LONGSTANDING DOESN'T MAKE IT
RIGHT. AND SO YOU KNOW I'VE I
READ RECENTLY EVEN OF A OF A
NOVEL THAT DEALT WITH GREEN
AMERICAN FAMILY TALK ABOUT THE
HISTORIC ORIGINS OF CREATE
TOWN. AND HOW THIS PRACTICE IS
YOU KNOW IT'S EMBEDDED IN SO
MANY IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES NOT
AND- WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND- IF WE
DON'T- IF THERE IS A LIABILITY
EXTENDED TO THE BRAND NAME ON
THE LABEL- THEY CAN JUST TURN A
BLIND EYE AND I KNEW THEY WOULD
PREFER NOT TO HAVE LIABILITY.
THEY PREFER TO HAVE NO
PLAUSIBLE DENIABILITY. BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT THESE LABELS-
ARE DOING THIS AROUND THE WORLD
AND THE INTERNET. FOR RATIONS-
I'M BUT YOU KNOW WE CAN'T. WE
CAN'T. IN A TELL OTHER
COUNTRIES TO GET THEIR ACT AS A
PREFERRED NOT. THREE WE CAN IN
OUR OWN BACKYARD. AND SO I'M
VERY GRATEFUL TO YOU ABOUT THIS
BILL FORWARD WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR FROM THE
SUMMER GONZALEZ SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS A
SENATOR- THAT ALSO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE SOME CLOSING
COMMENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BEAUTIFUL REMARKS- ON BEHALF OF
THOSE WORKERS- THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH AND RESPECTFUL EFFORT
I WILL. YOUR A MUSLIM CAN TAKE
WILL. MOTION IS TO PASSED
APPROACH KALRA HI KALRA AYE
FLORA FLORA NO CARILLO. I DEEP.
GONZALEZ AND SALAS AYE JONES
SAWYER BY TEN SQUARE HI
THREE OF US THREE OF US I
THOUGHT ALL RIGHT I THAT BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU SENATOR
RUSSELL FOR THE PRESENTATION ON
BOTH YOUR BILL TODAY. UP NEXT
WE HAVE THE- SENATOR JACKSON
WITH SB. NINE SEVENTY THREE.
HE'S SENATOR JACKSON- MAKE YOUR
WAY UP AND WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY TO GO FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU. GIVEN THAT LOVE FEST.
THE SAME OFF. NINE SEVENTY
THREE ALL RIGHT SAID HE IS SO.
A MEASURE THAT. YOU HAVE I
THINK HEARD BEFORE. ARE SIMILAR
TO I THINK- WHAT HAS COME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE TWICE-
IT'S A BILL THAT IS DESIGNED TO
FIGHT PAY DISCRIMINATION WITH
DATA WITH INFORMATION BECAUSE
WHEN IT COMES TO PAY EQUITY FOR
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. I
BELIEVE WE CAN'T FIX WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW. AND WE CERTAINLY
CAN'T FIX WHAT WE CAN'T SHOW.
SO THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE LARGE
EMPLOYERS TO SUBMIT A PAID OUT
A REPORT EVERY YEAR. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING OUTLINING THE
COMPENSATION AN HOUR'S WORK OF
EMPLOYEES BY GENDER. BY RACE BY
ETHNICITY AND JOB CATEGORY. IN
RESPONSE TO BUSINESS COMMUNITY
CONCERNS THIS DATA WILL NOT BE
MADE PUBLIC. BUT IT WILL HELP
FIGHT GENDER AND RACE BASED PAY
DISCRIMINATION IN IMPORTANT
WAYS FIRST. IT WILL ENCOURAGE
EMPLOYERS TO ANALYZE THEIR OWN
PAY DATA. AND PROMOTION
PRACTICES AND ALLOW FOR SELF
CORRECTION IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
IF YOU WILL FOR THESE COMPANIES
TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR. SEE
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS THEY'RE
DOING BECAUSE FOUGHT ONE OF THE
KEY CONTRIBUTORS TO THE PAY GAP
IS WHAT IS CALLED JOB
SEGREGATION. THE CONCENTRATION
OF WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
CERTAIN USUALLY MUCH LOWER. OUR
WAGE POSITIONS IN A COMPANY
OFTEN COMPANIES REALLY AREN'T
AWARE OF THESE PATTERNS AND
PRACTICES- WITHIN THEIR OWN
ORGANIZATION UNTIL THEY LOOK AT
THEM CAREFULLY AND CRITICALLY.
THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING TO GATHER IMPORTANT
DATA THAT ALLOWS HIM TO SEE
PATTERNS OF WAGE DISCRIMINATION
AND IF THEY NOTICED DEVIATIONS
OR OUT LIARS TO INVESTIGATE
FURTHER. THIS DATA WILL THUS
HELP THE FE H. STRENGTHENING
PRIORITIZE THEIR ENFORCEMENT
PRACTICES. THE BILL ALSO STRING
TO. THROUGH STRENGTHENS. IT'S
REALLY HARD TALKING WITH THE-
THIS BILL ALSO STRENGTHENS
ENFORCEMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FAIR PAY ACT BY ALLOWING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING ALSO ENFORCE THE FAIR
PAY ACT IN COORDINATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT. NOW THIS
BILL IS CLOSELY MODELED AFTER
EFFORTS THAT WE STARTED DURING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION BUT
WERE HALTED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION MAKING IT
FRANKLY MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER THAT WE PURSUE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OUR OWN PATH. AND IN
CASE YOU'RE WONDERING IF THIS
X. A DIFFERENCE LAST YEAR INTEL.
VOLUNTARILY RELEASED THE STATUS
THEY HAD DONE THE STUDY AND IT
REVEALED THE FORTY ONE OF FIFTY
TWO TOP EXECUTIVES MAKING MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR FORMAT. AND 37%
WERE WHITE. SO TO THEM THIS
ACTUALLY WAS AN EYE OPENING
REVELATIONS BOTH OF THEM AND TO
THE WIDER COMMUNITY AND LED TO
CALLS AND EFFORTS BY THEM TO
CHANGE. MEMBERS THE PAY GAP
REMAINS A SERIOUS PROBLEM WE'VE
DONE LEGISLATION HERE AND I'VE
BEEN HONORED TO WORK WITH A
NUMBER OF YOU ON THOSE-
EFFORTS- DURING THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS. BUT IT IS A
PROBLEM THAT TO THIS DAY
CONTINUES TO COST AN ESTIMATED
SEVENTY NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN
LOST WAGES A YEAR. FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES WOMEN ARE
BEING ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY
THIS COVERT NINETEEN ECONOMIC
CRISIS EVERY DAY THERE'S AN
ARTICLE THAT TALKS ABOUT. HOW
THIS IS IMPACTING WOMEN AND
THEIR ABILITY TO WORK IN THE
WORKFORCE WOMEN DROPPING OUT-
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THIS IS OVER
AND HOPEFULLY SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER. WHERE ARE WE GOING
TO BE WE ARE GOING TO NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS THINGS HAVE BEEN
BAD EVEN BEFORE THE CALL OVER
TO WHERE IT WILL BE VERY MUCH
IN COMMON UPON US. TO SPEAK THE-
OF THIS GOING FOR. AS WELL.
WITH AN BY MENTIONING WITHOUT
THIS PAY. RE RE T<c.cyan> PRINT</c>
THAT WE WILL NOT FULLY CLOSE
THE PAY GAP. FOR A HUNDRED AND
ONE YEARS. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
YOU BUT I DON'T THINK I'LL BE.
SO I CAN'T LOG AND I SUSPECT
YOU CAN HAVE THEM EITHER AND
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
YEAH THANK YOU YOU HAVE TO
WHICH SAYS WILL JOIN REMOTELY-
JESSICA STANDER WITH EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES. AND PATRICIA
SHOE WHO IS THE FORMER DIRECTOR
OF THE FEDERAL CONTRACT
COMPLIANCE. BOB THANK YOU
SENATOR AND- IT'S ALWAYS IS
EVERY OF WITNESS WILL HAVE UP
TO TWO MINUTES AND WE'LL START
WITH JUST COST UNDER. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER MY NAME IS JESSICA
STANDAR I'M SENIOR COUNSEL FOR
PLATES. AND PUBLIC POLICY EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATE A PROUD SPONSOR
OF SB NINE SEVEN THREE OF THE
CULTURE OF THE FAR CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK FOR WHICH
WITH THE PRIORITY. THEY NEED TO
ACHIEVE EQUAL PAY IS MORE
CRITICAL NOW THAN EVER WOMEN
WORKERS OF COLOR MAKE UP A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
FRONTLINE ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AN
EXISTING INEQUALITIES INCLUDING
GENDER AND RACIAL PAID A THIRTY
HAVE BEEN EVEN FURTHER REVEALED
EXACERBATED IN THE CRISIS. AT
THE COLLECTIVE UP ON COVER PAY
DISCRIMINATION WHICH IS A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE BROADER
RANGE OF GENDER AND RACE WHICH
AT. THAT ARE PRETTY. SIMPLE FOR
WHAT COLOR ON THOSE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE WORST. CAP
COLLECTION FOR EXAMPLE IT WILL
PROMOTE EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT
OF OUR STATE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION AND EQUAL PAY
LAWS AS WELL AS- ON TRAINED.
COMPLIANCE WITH. AS YOU'VE
HEARD ONE OFF THE TO AFFECT AND
FOR OF OUR LAW. THAT DISCOVERED
YET AS A AND HIT A FROM SIGHT.
AND CAN RESULT FROM HISTORICAL
NECK. AND ALSO AS YOU HEARD
OCCUPATIONAL CENTER. WHERE
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
CONCENTRATED IN LOWER PAYING
JOB. IS OFTEN THE RESULT OF
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS AND HE ALWAYS
AWARE OF IT. THIS CALL IN A P.
DATA WILL HELP IDENTIFY THE
GAPS. THAT IMPORTER CAN TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK TO DETERMINE IF
CHANGES ARE NEEDED TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW. IT MAY NOT REVEAL
A DIRECT VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW
THAT WILL HELP THEM LOOK
FURTHER TO SEE IF THEY NEED TO
MAKE SUCH CHANGES. SIMILARLY
MANY EMPLOYERS OF ALREADY
RECOGNIZE THIS NEED INCLUDING
FAILED FOR GAP STARBUCKS. AT
REGULARLY CONDUCTED PAY AUDIT.
WHAT AND IT MADE CHANGES TO
THEIR PAY UPON REALIZING THEY
NEED TO DO THAT COMPLY WITH THE
LAW. FINALLY IT WILL HELP OUR
PA OUR STATE AGENCIES MORE
EFFICIENTLY USE THEIR
RESOURCES. AS I SAID THE DATA
MIGHT NOT TO BE DIRECT EVIDENCE
OF VIOLATION OF THE FAIR PAY
ACT. WILL ALLOW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ATTRACT PATTERNS AND
DETERMINE WHERE THERE MAY BE A
VIOLATION THE WHITE LADY. CAME
FINALLY THE AND FOR. BY THE AT
THE AGE F THE- FAIR PAY ACT.
IS NECESSARY BECAUSE OFTEN. WHO
PAY DISK. BASED ON GENDER RACE
OR ETHNICITY MAY HAVE CLAIMED
UNDER BOTH THE FAIR PATH. IN
THE PEA HALL WHICH IS ALREADY
IMPORTS BY THE SB EIGHT.
THEREFORE ENABLING THE AGENCY
PEOPLE. ON BOTH. ENSURE THE
MORE EFFICIENT USE OF RESOURCE.
CONDUCTED THAT COME TOGETHER.
THIS BILL ADVANCED PAID.
TRANSPARENCY WHICH IS CRITICAL
TO UNCOVERING GENDER AND RACE
BASED WEIGHT GAP. THAT CONTINUE
TO HARM WOMEN AND FAMILIES NOW
MORE THAN EVER WE MUST ENSURE
THAT WORKERS REPEAT EQUITABLE
EIGHT. TO WHETHER THE CURRENT
AND FUTURE ECONOMIC CRISES
THANK YOU THANK YOU. A PATRICIA
SHIP. ALL ALRIGHT AND THEN
RIGHT AT THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS. I JOINED THE APPLAUDED
MINISTRY AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF FEDERAL CONTRACT
COMPLIANCE PROGRAMS THE BILL
RATE BEIJING THE BEACH. WHAT
MADE MINISTRATION IDENTIFIED
PAY EQUITY OF ONE OF ITS TOP
PRIORITY AND CREATED THE WHITE
HOUSE NATIONAL EQUAL PAY TASK
FORCE WHICH INCLUDED LEADERSHIP
FROM THE AIR EIGHT AND ALL OF
THE. DEVELOPMENT OF THE AREA
DATA COLLECTION TOOL IS THE
RIVER OF AN RIGOROUS MULTI YEAR
PROP. ABLE TO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA SIGNED A
PRESIDENT MEMBER TO THE- OF
LABOR THE PROPOSAL WILL WALK
OUT WITH REQUIRE CONTRACTORS
AND SUBCONTRACTORS TO MAKE
SUMMARY DATA ON COMPENSATION
EIGHT. ON ALL CLOTHING ABOUT
ABOUT. BOB DIRECTED SEPARATE
PLEASE REFER TO CASE. OKAY IN A
BACK. OKAY OF YOU WERE LOSING
OVER BIT HERE I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU CAN SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
CLOSELY TO THE MICROPHONE OR
FOR WHATEVER DEVICE USING. THAT
WORKS NOW. EDIT. MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE A COPY OF THE SHOESAT THE
MONEY IF YOU WOULD LIKE ME TO
TAKE OVER FOR THAT YEAH THAT BE
GREAT. OF THE- YOUR- WITH THE
THAT THE CONTENDER AGAIN BUT I
HAVE A COPY OF MISUSED. MONEY
SECOND CONTINUE YOUR THE DERBY
GRAY BMB CALL BECAUSE MUCH OF
OR- EARLY. OKAY AND SO YEAH
THESE ARE JUST INCLUDE THAT IN
THE FILE WILL MAKE SURE TO.
INCLUDE THAT. THANK YOU. I'M
OKAY OF SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE IN THE ROOM ANYONE THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. MS
MODERATOR TO BE HAVE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. NAME
THEY'RE ALL AND WE ALREADY HAVE
SEVERAL THANK YOU MY APOLOGIES
MISS CHAIR WE'LL START WITH
LINE THREE SIXTEEN PLEASED TO
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION. WELL IT THE
VALVE ACTIVATING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
OPERATE ON CHECK THE BILL TRUMP
THE COURT. THANK YOU. I AM
THREE THIRTY FIVE THREE THREE
FIVE REALIGNMENT SO. BUT BACK
IN BALLOT NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKER CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE THREE FORTY FIVE THREE
FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KAREN MEMBERS THAT THE GREAT
WALL AT THE AT THE W. WESTERN
STATES COUNSEL AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE FOR SEVENTY
FIVE FOUR SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVEN AMPS GIRLFRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
NINE SEVEN THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE FOR SEVENTY
SEVEN OR SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS ERIN O'NEILL
MULLIN BURKE VICE PRESIDENT
POLICY LEGISLATION FOR WORK
EQUITY AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVENTY
THREE IS THAT THE PRIORITY SELF
BREAST. THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY
AND FOUR EIGHTY THREE FOUR
EIGHT THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
IN GROUND A FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE NINETEEN ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH STRIKER
WITH A CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WELL I AM FOUR SIX
SEVEN FOUR SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MONICA HE ON BEHALF
WHICH AREN'T CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK AND TRANSPORT
THANK YOU. FULL LINE FOR SIXTY
FOUR SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JOE THOMPSON FROM
PUBLIC COUNCIL IN LOS ANGELES
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVEN THREE. THANK YOU. LINE
FOR SEVENTY TWO FOUR SEVEN TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TURN
OVER THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE FOUR SIX FOUR FOUR
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HEY HOW ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND PRAGUE C<c.cyan></c>
FONT THERE'S OF THE BELL AND
ALSO READ THIS DURING THAT THE
COURT OF THAT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. LINE
THREE EIGHTY ONE THREE EIGHT
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GENYA
CASSIDY A CALIFORNIA WORK AND
FAMILY COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. TEN FOUR FOUR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR FORTY
SEVEN. HELLO THIS IS LAURIE
FURSTENFELD IN THE CHILD CARE
LAW CENTER AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FINAL
COMMENT IN Q. AT THIS TIME IS
TWO SIX ONE TO SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BARTOLO AT THE
LECTERN ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. RIGHT WILL
CERTAINLY WONDER OPPOSITION AND
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE BEEN HAVING WITH CAL
CHAMBER BY PHONE. THE
RESEARCHER MEMBERS THAT HAVE
BECOME A HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE SB NINE
SEVENTY THREE- WE OBVIOUSLY DO
NOT CONDONE PAY INEQUITY IN THE
CHAMBER HAS WORKED CLOSELY WITH
SENATOR JACKSON OVER THE YEARS
ON THIS ISSUE. INCLUDING ON HER
LANDMARK- SB THREE EIGHT WHICH
WE TO SUPPORT HOWEVER WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL I'LL BE BRIEF BE THE DEAD
HORSES DISCUSSED. BILLS OVER
THE LAST YEARS. AS WE SEE IT IN
PRIOR YEARS OUR PRIMARY CONCERN
IS THAT THIS REQUIREMENT
CREATES AN IMPRESSION OF WHAT
DISCRIMINATION ONE NINE MAIN
EXIST NOT ALWAYS DISPARITY IN
FULL THERE ARE BONA FIDE NON
GOODNESS BE READ. DID EDUCATION
EXPIRY LEVELS. YOU MAY HAVE TO
THAT HAVE SAME JOB TITLE BUT
ONE HAS BEEN EMPLOYED FOR. YEAR
AND ANOTHER FOR ONLY SIX
MONTHS- OUR CONCERN IS THAT
THIS INFORMATION WOULD GIVE A
FALSE IMPRESSION OF PAY
DISPARITY. ESPECIALLY THIS
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED TO
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. WE PRESENT
WILL ACT UPON THE INFORMATION.
RECEIVED I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT BRIEFLY ON WHAT IS NEW
IN THIS BILL COMPARED TO
PREVIOUS. VERSION AND THAT IS
THE PROVISION IN SECTION. THE
BILL THAT AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING IN ADDITION TO THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER TO
INVESTIGATE AND ENFORCE EQUAL
PAY ACT CLAIMS. WE'VE TALKED TO
THE AUTHORS OFFICE BETTER
CONCERT WE APPRECIATE THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
CLARIFIES. THAT ONLY ONE AGENCY
WELL THE BEST TO GET THE SAME
SET OF FACTS. BUT NEVER THE
LESS WE HAVE CONCERNED ANY YOU
HAVE TWO DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES AND FORCING THE SAME
BODY OF LAW. AND THE POTENTIAL
CONFUSION AND INCONSISTENT
ENFORCEMENT THAT CAN RESULT. AT
THE CONSISTENT POSITION WE'VE
EXPRESSED ON A NUMBER OF BILLS
IN RECENT YEARS. AND WE THINK
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S A RECIPE FOR
CONFUSION AND CONFLICT. REASONS
WERE RESPECTFULLY TO THIS BILL
AND THAT'S WHERE NO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. NEXT ONE GO TO
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. AND
THEN UNDER THE FAMAS MODERATOR
AGAIN STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU IF
YOU ARE AGAINST THE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL AT
THAT TIME FROM A QUOTE BY THE
THREE THIRTY SEVEN THREE THREE
SEVEN. GO AHEAD STATE YOUR NAME
A LOT OF PHILLY HM. HI WITH THE
STICKER FEE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YU AND NOW TO LINE. TWO
FIFTY FOUR TO FIFTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON AT THE THIRTY YEARS
OF THE CALIFORNIA THEY GET THE
PRODUCERS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
ONE OH ONE ONE OH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN ONE ON ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHAT I NEED. WELL
WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE FOR
SEVENTY OR SEVENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON LITERATURE AND NUMBER
EIGHTY HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION YOUR RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LIVE FOR EIGHTY FIVE OR EIGHTY
FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MATTHEW WELL WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND OUTLINED FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON WITH THIS BIBLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND OUTLINED FOR
SEVENTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER IS NOT A
GREAT AT THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS BUT DOES
THAT EACH CHAMBER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. SO SAID BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS. AS ONE TO MAKE A
QUICK COMMENT THANK YOU-
SENATOR JACKSON FOR CONTINUING
YOUR FIGHT TO END A NARROW THIS
WAGE GAP- I THINK ESPECIALLY AS
A LATINA- YOU KNOW WE ARE THE
FURTHEST RIGHT- THAT WE HAVE
THE WIDEST WHICH GAP IN COMPARE.
TO OUR WHITE MALE COUNTERPART
CITY WE GET FIFTY THREE CENTSON THE DOLLAR- I'M IN EVEN WITH
HIGHER EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
AND YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IT THE
GAP IS STILL VERY WIDE- IN SO I
THINK THAT. BY COLLECTING THIS
DATA WILL BE ABLE TO SEE IT
LIKE YOU SAID IF THERE ARE ANY
PATTERNS AND I HOPE THAT
CORPORATE WOULD USE THIS MAKE
MORE DATA DRIVEN DECISIONS AND
THE RECRUITMENT IN- THEY-
EVALUATE EMPLOYEES ESPECIALLY
OF COLOR SO THANK YOU. REPORTER
SOME REAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON I LIKE TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES SLOWLY THEN GOES-
LATINOS ARE WE DO FACE- CERTAIN
DISCRIMINATION IN THE WORKPLACE
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
WAGES- I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
CORPORATIONS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ALREADY ARE VERY TRANSPARENT AS
YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR OPENING
IN DOING THAT IN PROVIDING DATA
AND IF ONLY ALL CORPORATIONS
AND COMPANIES THAT THAT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO. ADJUST LATE
THEM. FOR THEM TO IS THE
NUMBERS THAT THEY A- IT'S
INCREDIBLE AND- LATINOS ARE NOW
THE- HIGHEST POPULATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LET THE
ENOUGH FOR PASSED THE LATINO
MEN IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO THEY'RE MORE LATINO WOMEN.
THAT OTHER NECESSITIES AND A
AND GENDER- IN THE STATE AND SO
I THINK AS WE THINK ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
THINK ABOUT. WHERE WE AS WOMEN
AND I THOUGHT THE NO WOMEN
SPECIFICALLY ARE ABLE TO LEAD
THE STATE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
BARRIERS THAT PATHWAY AND THE
JOURNEY TO ACHIEVEMENT AND
THROUGH- LEACH EQUITY IS NOT
THE SAME AND SO I THINK THAT
YOU'VE BEEN LEADING THIS WORK
SO LONG AND I AND IF POSSIBLE I
I'D LOVE TO BE A CO. WELL THANK.
DO YOU I'M- THE YES MA'AM
MOTIONS SO IS THERE A SECOND I
GET SO WE HAVE A MOTION SOME
GRIOT SEC AND SUMMER US AND- I
ALSO WANT TO WANT TO THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON AND YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE MADE THERE
THERE REALLY WAIT MAYBE MANY
DIFFERENT REASONS WHY EMPLOYEES
ARE PAID A DIFFERENT RATE BUT-
THREE CENTS ON THE DOLLAR. WHEN
YOU CUT IT A LEGITIMATE THERE
IS A ON YOU YOU YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET A WHAT PATH THERE
UNLESS YOU HAVE CLEAR SYSTEMIC-
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE AN AN-
FOR. WOULD YOU SHOULD ONE. TO
LOOK AT THE PREMIERE SO WE ALSO
WANT TO DO THAT ESPECIALLY
THESE COMPANIES THAT THAT I
WANT TO STRIVE TO BE BETTER.
AND YOU KNOW I'M I DON'T WANT
TO SEE ADDS. CELEBRATING
HUNDRED YEARS OF WOMEN'S RIGHT
TO VOTE OR BLACK LIVES MATTER
UNLESS THEY'RE GONNA HIRE
WOMEN. HIRE BLACK ENGINEERS AT
THE NO ENGINEERS I'M AND
CAPITAL SILICON VALLEY AND SAN
JOSE. SOME OF THE MOST
EGREGIOUS INCOME INEQUALITY. AS
WELL AS PAY GAPS ESPECIALLY THE
PLAN AS A PLACE TO WOMEN AND-
AGAIN IT'S A TIME TO ACT AND SO
I APPRECIATE YOU SENATE JACKSON
CONTINUING. OF YOUR BOARD
ACTIONS IN THIS REGARD AND
CERTAINLY- I RECOMMENDATIONS
SUPPORT THE BILL- AND WOULD ASK
IF YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING TIME.
THANK YOU AND I. THE CONCERN
AND AN THE UNDER. OF WHAT WHAT
THE GOAL HERE I WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY DO EVERY TWO BUT THE
CHAMBER MUST TURN THEIR HEARING.
OFF THIS IS NOT A LOT TO SEE.
WHETHER ONE PERSON IS BEING
PAID. THAN BASED UPON THEIR X.
THERE. THIS IS TO LOOK AT JOB
CATEGORIES. THIS IS TO LOOK AT
NOT AT INDIVIDUAL COMPARISONS.
BUT ON THE BASIS OF DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES CHECK THE LAW PAYING
CASH OUT OF RESOURCES UP. PAY
CASH. IS THERE A- DIFFERENCE
ARE WE SEEING. UP BY IT HERE
ARE DISPARITY AND- I THINK THAT
A LOT COMPANIES. AREN'T.
FINISHED WHERE ARE. BUT IT'S-
THAT IN BY IS HAVE I I'LL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE OF WHENEVER I UP
FOR YOU AT THE GOING TO THE TO
THE MOVIES AT THE END OF THE
FILM MY HUSBAND ALL LIKES TO
SIT MORE. SCROLL DOWN TO SEE.
WHAT WE CAN ALL ALL THE PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN FAR AND SO TO Y. BUT
I DO IT FOR A DIFFERENT REASON
I TRY TO FIND OUT HOW MANY
WOMEN FROM HAVE THEIR BEEN ON
STAFF HOW MANY WOMEN GRIPS ARE
THERE. MANY IN A I THE WOMEN
LOCATED IN HERE'S WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED. THEY'RE LOCATED IN
HERE DRESSER. AND IN. THE
WARDROBE. WELL THAT'S GREAT BUT
I ASSURE YOU THAT THE HIGHER
PAYING JOBS ARE PRIMARILY ALL
MEN AND THEY TEND TO HAVE NAMES
LIKE JOHN SMITH RATHER THAN
JOSE MARTINEZ AND FOR ME.
THAT'S WHAT I LOOK AT. NOW THAT
DOESN'T MEAN WHEN MY HUSBAND
WANTS TO CHIP LOOK AND SEE HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE INVOLVED IN.
THE MAKING OF A FILM FOR
EXAMPLE THAT'S NOT THAT HE'S
INTENTIONALLY BEING. BLIND TO
IT IT'S JUST CITY START
THINKING ABOUT IT AND I WILL
ALWAYS SAY AT THE END I ONLY
SAW TWO OR THREE WOMEN WORKING
ON- ON ON THOSE ON THE FILM
ITSELF OTHER THAN IN HER
DRESSING WITH HIM. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
GO IT'S DESIGNED TO SAY FOLKS
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHO YOU'RE
HIRING AND BY THE WAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS AYE I HOPE
IT'S FIFTY THREE CENTS- TO
EVERY DOCTOR BECAUSE I BELIEVE
IT'S FORTY FORCE. FOR LATINO SO
MAYBE THINGS ARE MOVING UP
ALTHOUGH I WOULDN'T EXACTLY
BOAST ABOUT IT BUT- BUT I MEAN
THE NUMBERS TO REALLY HORRIFIC.
AND WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL TRIES TO DO SO WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU THE SENATOR-
MISSING OF CAN TAKE ROLE ON
THIS WE HAVE A MOTION FROM AS A
MEMBER CARILLO SECONDED. BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA. HI KALRA
BY. FLORA FLORA NO. ON OKAY.
CARILLO CAREER HI DEEP.
GONZALEZ HI VALIS ITEM SAWYER
JONES SAWYER I'VE LIVED.
THREE OF US I PHIL KNIGHT BUT
SO THAT BILL IS OUT AND WE'RE
TWO THIRDS OF THE WAY THROUGH
OUR BILLS WE HAVE THREE BILLS
TO GO HUNTING OKAY JUST UP AND
STRETCH OF YOU NEED TO. AND HOW.
NO THAT'S ON DISK THROUGH THIS
OR NOT BUT I IN SKIN. CHINA
THIS TRYING TO GET US OUT OF
HERE TO READ WHY OUR- AND UP
NEXT SENATOR JACKSON SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. WELL
THIS IS AN EASY ONE- SAID NO
OPPOSITION. OUR BUT THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT A PORTENT
EFFORT THIS IS THE FAMILY LEAVE
IT WAS THE BUDGET BILL AT THE
TIME WE WERE- NEGOTIATING THE
BUDGET IT'S PART OF THAT
AGREEMENT THAT WAS REACHED BY
THE GOVERNOR IN ORDER
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP THIS
BILL IS. THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATION TO EMERGE OUT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PAID FAMILY
LEAVE TASK FORCE. THIS WAS A
DIVERSE OR IS A DIVERSE GROUP
OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT INCLUDES
REPRESENTATIVE FROM BUSINESS
FROM SMALL BUSINESS FROM LABOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
VARIOUS PHILANTHROPY. IT
STRENGTHENS THE IMPORTANT LAW
KNOWN AS THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RIGHT TO ACT WHICH PROVIDES THE
JOB PROTECTION FOUNDATION FOR
OUR STATE'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
WAGE REPLACEMENT PROGRAM. THIS
BILL SEEKS TO CLOSE A CARE
GIVING GAP THAT HAS CREATED AN
UNCONSCIONABLE DIVIDE BETWEEN
THOSE WHO CAN TAKE TIME OFF TO
CARE FOR A NEWBORN OR SICK LOVE
ONE AND STILL KEEP THEIR JOBS.
AND THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ACTUALLY RISK
THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND ECONOMIC
SECURITY FOR TAKING CARE OF
THEIR FAMILY. OR BONDING WITH A
NEWBORN THESE POLICIES ARE EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT DURING THIS
PANDEMIC WE WANT THOSE WHO ARE
SICK TO STAY HOME. AND WE WANT
FAMILY MEMBERS TO CARE FOR EACH
OTHER TO PREVENT
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND NURSING
HOME REPLACEMENT SO FAR MORE
THAN 40% THE COVERT TEAM FOR
THE HE'S HAVE NURSED HOME
RESIDENTS OR WORK. A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTEXT SIXTEEN YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIAN ACTED THE NATION'S
FIRST PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM. THAT'S BOTH SOMETHING
TO CELEBRATE AND SOMETHING
FRANKLY TO BE A LITTLE
EMBARRASSED ABOUT. THAT WE ARE
THE ONLY INDUSTRIALIZED COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD THAT DOES NOT HAVE
OR DID NOT HAVE A PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM AND THE PROGRAM
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO DEVELOP
AND PASSED IS ACTUALLY WORKER
FUNDED. YOU AND I PAY A LITTLE
BIT IN EVERY MONTH AND THAT
KILL MANGAS PAYCHECK WE-
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF.
INSURANCE THAT GOES INTO THIS
FUND FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE WE
PAY FOR YOU WENT ONLINE. AND
PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR A LARGER
EMPLOYERS- ARE ABLE TO TAKE IT
BUT PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR
EMPLOYERS OF TWENTY FOUR LAST
CAN'T TAKE. AT A NEW PARENT
LEAVE AND BE ASSURED THEIR JOBS
GOING TO BE THERE. AND IF YOU
WORK FOR FIFTY OR LESS ARE YOU
ARE KNOLL YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TAKE THAT LEAVE OUR AND BE
ASSURED THAT YOUR JOB IS THERE
WHEN YOU COME BACK SO
ESSENTIALLY PEOPLE PAY INTO A
FUND. THEY DON'T TAKE BECAUSE
YOU'RE AFRAID IF THEY DO TAKE
IT THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE THEIR
JOBS. BASICALLY THIS BILL IS TO
SAY TO PEOPLE LOOK YOU CAN TAKE
BELIEVE YOU PAID FOR. AND YOUR
JOB WILL BE THERE TWELVE WEEKS
WERE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT SIX MONTHS WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE YEAR THAT
THEY DO IN MOST COUNTRIES IN
EUROPE IT'S TWELVE WEEKS AND WE
PAY FOR IT. AND YOU CAN'T TRUST
IT BECAUSE YOU FEEL LIKE IT YOU
HAVE TO TAKE IT BECAUSE OF THE
FAMILY. PHONE IS MOST. TRY SO
FAR. IT DOESN'T ALLOW FOR. AND
THE REIMBURSEMENT YOU GET BY
THE WAY ISN'T A HUNDRED CHANCE
OF EVERY DOLLAR. IT'S LESS THAN
70% IF YOU ARE SOMEONE WHO HAS
MORE THAN A- MINIMUM WAGE JOB.
IF YOU HAVE A MINIMUM WAGE JOB
YOU CAN GET UP 270% OF YOUR
WEEKLY PAYCHECK AGAIN IT'S
MONEY. THAT YOU PUT INTO THE
SYSTEM THAT WE'VE ALL PUT INTO
THE SYSTEM. WELL THAT ISN'T
ENOUGH FOR MOST PEOPLE ANYWAY
SO THEY DON'T ACTUALLY TAKE THE
LEAVE UNLESS THEY HAVE TO TAKE
IT. IF YOU HAVE A PARENT WHO IS
GOING TO THEIR FINAL ILLNESS
AND YOU NEED TO TAKE THAT TIME
OFF TO CARE FOR THEM. A LOT OF
PEOPLE WON'T DO IT BECAUSE
THEY'RE GONNA LOSE THEIR JOBS
OR THEY DO HERE THEY DO. AND
SHOW THAT PARENT GOES WITHOUT
THE CARE THAT THEY NEED OR YOU
WHICH AN INDIVIDUAL MOST
ACTUALLY MOST CARE- FAMILY IF
IT'S TAKEN THIS TAKEN BY THE
INDIVIDUAL FOR THEIR OWN CARE.
VERY LITTLE IS EVEN TAKEN FOR
FAMILY MEMBERS SO. THE BOTTOM
LINE I'LL CUT TO THE CHASE HERE
IS THAT THE OPPOSITION- YOU
KNOW LIKES TO GENERATE FEAR
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO PACK
THIS **** AND EVERYBODY'S GOING
TO LEAVE AND NO ONE'S GOING TO
GO TO WORK IN A TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF THE SYSTEM WE'VE GOT BUILT
IN PROTECTIONS HERE. YOU CAN'T
YOU CAN'T QUALIFY FOR THIS DROP
PROTECTION UNLESS YOU WORK FOR
THE EMPLOYER FOR A YEAR AND TO
BUY AND TWELVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY HOURS SO YOU DON'T TO
START A JOB AND SAY I'M OFF AND
BY THE WAY ARE YOU GOING TO
KEEP JOBS FOR ME WHEN I GET
BACK. TO WORK THAT WAY AND IF
YOU CAN IMPROVE EMPLOYER THINGS
THAT MAKE WASH LACKING IT
REQUIRES LOCAL OF APPROVAL AND
THE CONFIRMATION AND IF YOU
LIKE WHAT THAT ONE DOC THERE'S
YOU ACTUALLY THE RIGHT. GET A
SECOND OPINION. THIS ALSO A
PROCESS THAT IS ABSOLUTE.
DESIGNED TO PROTECT BOTH THE
WORKER AND THE EMPLOYER BUT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY WHEN YOU HAVE TO
IF YOU HAVE AN INTACT FAMILY
YOU ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY THAN
NOT TEND BOTH OF THOSE- PARENTS
WORKING AND YET SHOP BUT HE'S
GOT TO TAKE CARE OF EACH OTHER
AND THEMSELVES. TIMES GET. AND
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT MOST OF
THESE PEOPLE ALMOST ALL OF THEM
WILL GO BACK TO THAT JOB THEY
BECOME MORE EFFICIENT TO
EMPLOYEES AND THEY STAY THERE
MORE LOYAL EMPLOYEES. AND WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN THIS BILL IS WE
BROUGHT IT TO A NUMBER OF FIVE
OR MORE EMPLOYEES. BECAUSE WHY
SHOULD YOU NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE
LEAVE BASED UPON THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES AT A BUSINESS IT IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE YOUR FAMILY
HEALTH YOUR HEALTH ISN'T
CONTINGENT UPON WHETHER YOU
WORK FOR A LARGE EMPLOYER OR
NOT. AND SO- WHAT WE DID IS THE
SMALL BUSINESS. OUR FOLKS AND
WILL HAVE ONE OF THEM
TESTIFYING TODAY THEY'VE DONE
SOME RESEARCH ON THIS AND WHAT
THEY'VE SHOWN IS THAT I THINK
IT'S FIFTY NINE PERCENT. OF
SMALL BUSINESSES OF FAR MORE
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM. BECAUSE
THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE
BUSINESSES. AND ONLY 19% OF
THESE COMPANIES WILL EVEN GO
OUT AND HIRE SOMEBODY ELSE
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
REMEMBER WHEN YOU DO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PAY- A LOT OF THE-
BENEFITS THAT A FULL TIME. AND
PERMANENT EMPLOYEE GETS SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO PAY- LIKE A
PENSION PLAN BECAUSE THESE ARE
NOT THESE ARE TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEES. BUT MOST COMPANIES
FIND THE WHAT DO THEY DO THEY
BAND TOGETHER. YOU KNOW WE'VE
ALL HAD THAT I THINK- WE NOW
HAVE ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES I'M
SO EXCITED FOR BUFFY AS A NEW
BABY. YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE
PENSION AND FOR HER. AND A WE
HAD THAT IN MY OFFICE HAD A ONE
OF MY STAFF NOT ON. LEAVE HER
FIRST HAD THE- TO BE IN THE BE
OF CHOI. AND SO SHE WAS GONE
FOR TO MY- KING BUT- WE IT. MY
CHIEF OF STAFF ENDED UP A DAD
WHO WAS. WHO SUFFERED A HEART
ATTACK WHILE ON A CRUISE IN
FINLAND TWO WEEKS BEFORE
SESSION ENDED. AND OFF SHE WENT
WE FIGURED IT OUT AND THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS AND THESE BECOME
BETTER EMPLOYEE SO IT'S THIS IS
SOMETHING IT'S TIME IS CALM.
CHAMBER I THINK HAS TO COME
INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY-
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AND
THE WORLD HAS CHANGED THIS IS
LEGISLATION THAT SIMPLY
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED. BREAKING ANY GROUND
HERE WHICH HAS RECOGNIZING THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DREW. IN
ORDER TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO WORK-
TO LIMIT ENSURE THE BUSINESSES
CONTINUE TO FLOURISH THERE AS I
MENTIONED ARE THE SAFEGUARDS.
AND THIS IS FOR THE BETTERMENT
OF THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
THE BUSINESSES A CALIFORNIA AND
HOPEFULLY WILL SERVE TO BE A
LEADER IN THIS COUNTRY AS WE
LOOK AT THE WORLD. OUR IN POST
COLD WOULD HOPE. BY THE LATER I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR EYES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR SENATOR JACKSON
AND WE DO HAVE OF WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT YES- SHERRIN TURMAN
LEGAL AID AT WORK BY PHONE AS
WELL AS YAMADA. PENA WITH THIS
BUSINESS JORDY ALSO BY PHONE
UNTIL EACH HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES SO- SHERRIN GERMAN YOU
MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
ELECTRIC CHAIR AND MEMBER
SHARON TERM AND I DIRECT THE
WORKING FAMILY PROGRAM THAT
LEGALLY AT WORK. I'M HONORED TO
TESTIFY IN STRONG SUPPORT AND I
THINK THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
LEGALLY DON'T WORK HERE'S FROM
LOW WAGE WORKERS EVERY DAY WHO
ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP THEIR
JOBS AND INCOME ALL CARING FOR
THEIR LOVED ONES. WE HEARD FROM
HEY. FATHER OF THREE AND BOTH
THE CORNER OF HIS FAMILY. LIVED
FIRED FROM HIS JOB AS A BOXER.
WHEN HE TOOK TWO WEEKS TO CARE
FOR A BABY WHO WAS BORN WITH
HEALTH COMPLICATIONS. EIGHT IN
THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE. BUT IS
EMPLOYER COULD LEGALLY FIRE HIM
BECAUSE IT WAS TOO SMALL TO BE
COVERED BY OUR JOB PROTECTION
LAW. HEY IS AMONG THE- AND WORK
FOR. AT JOB PROTECTED BY LEAVE
AND 40% EXCLUDING FROM LEAVE TO
CARE FOR ONE'S OWN OR FAMILY
MEMBERS OF THAT BASED ON
EMPLOYERS BY THE LONG. A RECENT
STUDY FOUND THAT THOSE THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW WAGE
WORKERS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
FIFTEEN BUT WORKERS OF COLOR
WHICH- BUT I THINK HIGHER PAID
BY WORKERS LEAVE WHILE BEING
UNABLE ACCESS BENEFITS FOR THE
BALLOT. IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC EXPANDING ACCESS TO
JOB PROTECTED LEAVE IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER WHEN PEOPLE
LACK JOB PROTECTION. LESS
LIKELY TO THINK TESTING AND
MORE LIKELY TO GO TO WORK
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID OF
LOSING YOUR JOB. RIGHT THE
VIRUS AND MAKES TREATING IT
CONTAINMENT IMPOSSIBLE. AT A
TIME WHEN PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY DYING OF THE
NINETEEN HEY FAMILY LEAVE CAN
BE LIKE BEARING. AT LEAST
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
WE'VE TO REDUCE HOSPITAL AND
NURSING HOME IT PLACES THAT
HAVE BECOME HOT SPOT FOR
INSPECTION. IMPORTANTLY THIS
BILL ALSO ALIGNED THE
DEFINITION OF FAMILY IN OUR JOB
PROTECTION A- WITH THE MORE
INCLUDES DEFINITION THAT
ALREADY EXIST IN OUR PICKING ON
THE LEAD LAP. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND THE MANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO AND WHAT THE
GENERATIONAL HELPFUL. ONE OF
OUR CALLERS BADLY. BUT THE
SEVENTY FOUR YEAR OLD WOMAN AND
LONGTIME EMPLOYEE OF A LARGE
RETAIL STORE- TWIN SISTER WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH TERMINAL CANCER.
AS THEY BRING WEREN'T COVERED
PROBABLY COULDN'T TAKE THAT LEE
YOU NEED TO CARE. ALL OF THAT
AT SOME IN OUR LIVES WILL NEED
THE LEAVE TO CARE FOR OUR OR
SOMETHING WE LOVE WHETHER YOU
HAVE FIVE CO WORKERS OR FIVE
HUNDRED NO ONE SHOULD BE FIRED.
FOR TAKING TIME TO RECOVER FROM
CANCER AND YOU'RE DYING PARENT
OR SPEND PRECIOUS MOMENTS WITH
THE NEW CHILD I RESPECTFULLY
URGE HERE HI BUT- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. UP NEXT AMADO PENA.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE A LOT AND
IF FAMILY MEMBERS AS
REPRESENTATIVE OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR MILLION SMALL BUSINESS SAYS
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT ATHLETES
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WE ARE
ONE OF THE THREE BUSINESS
SERVING ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE
PART OF GOVERNOR YOU CAN ME
TASK FORCE AND SPENT MANY
MONTHS NEGOTIATING WHAT WE
BELIEVE TO BE A NEW PAPER YOUTH
PROGRAM THAT IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES ALIKE. FOR MORE THAN
A DECADE CALIFORNIA THE PROGRAM
HAS HELP LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
STRUGGLE TO OFFER BROKEBACK'S
BENEFITS BY INSURING THEIR
EMPLOYEES HAVE ACCESS TO
PARTIAL WAGE REPLACEMENT WHEN
THEY NEED TO CARE. HEALTH
MEMBER THE BACK MAJORITY OF
SMALL THIS SUPPORT PUBLICLY
ADMIT. PETE LEAD. AND A WIDE
BODY OF RESEARCH SHOWS THAT JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE BENEFITS
EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS ALIKE
BY IMPROVING MORALE AND
PRODUCTIVITY. REDUCING TURNOVER
AND PROMOTING THAT THE RIGHT.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO REFERENCE AND
ECONOMIC STUDY THAT WE CALL
COMMISSION WITH THE BAY AREA
CALIFORNIA NINE LA TO EVALUATE
CALIFORNIA IF THE PROGRAM FROM
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR TO TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN. USING
DATA FROM. THE ELECT THE- US
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AMONG THE
FINDINGS THAT ILLUSTRATED BUT
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS THE
FAMILY LEAVE RESULT IN
REDUCTIONS IN LABOR COSTS FOR
SMALL. EMPLOYERS WHEN EMPLOYEES
YOU'VE PAID LEAVE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY PAID LEAVE THAT
THEY'RE NOT. GETTING CREEK FARM
EXIT RIGHT. INDEED EXPANDING
JOB PROTECTIVELY CAN LOWER
COSTS BY REDUCING TURNOVER AND
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT IT CAUGHT
UP TO ONE THIRD OF AN
EMPLOYEE'S SALARY TO REPLACE
THEM. ACCORDING TO A POLL
RELEASED THIS SPRING NEARLY SIX
AND TEN SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS A
FIFTY NINE PERCENT.
CALIFORNIA'S SUPPORT EXPANDING
DOC PROTECTED PARENTAL LEAVE
AND 54% OF THE- TICKET AT THE
AT THE WORK THE WORK IN THE-
WICKS. PLEASE SURE THAT'S- WHEN
I WORKED LEAD TO BUDGET DID
CREATED PROGRAM THAT THE
TRAINING AND RETAINING WORKERS
THIRTY THREE IN MY APPLICATION
AND WEBER THE- EIGHT PROGRAMS
THE DECISION TO THE LATE
TOUCHING FIRST TWENTY ONE THE
TEMP FILE BUT RELATED BELIEVE
PROVISIONS EXPIRE ALSO TAKES
INTO CONSIDERATION THE
UNPRECEDENTED MOMENT SMALL
BUSINESSES FIND THEMSELVES IN
AS A RESULT OF THAT PANDEMIC IN
AND RECLUSION PAID FAMILY LEAVE
IS THAT FOR EMPLOYEES AND IT'S
GOT FOR SMALL BUSINESS THE
FOLLOWING ARE JUST PART. THANK
YOU. OF HI THIS SEE IF THERE'S
ANY COM ON THIS YOU IN THE ROOM.
WHEN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. WE'LL GO AHEAD MR
MODERATOR TO BE HAVE ANYONE IS
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. IF YOU
ASK AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE ALL. AND FIRST
REPORTED LINE FOR NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD FOR NINETY. MARK
CHUCKLED. CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
FOR EIGHTY SIX OR EIGHTY SIX.
YEAH THE DOCTORS IN OUR CANYON
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND JUNK THE COURT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
OUTLINES SIXTY SIX. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR TO GRUMBLE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND OUTLINED.
THREE SIXTY THREE SIXTY. WHY
THE DAHLE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND OUT OF LINE FOR FORTY SEVEN
OR FORTY SEVEN. HELLO THIS IS
LAURIE FURSTENFELD IN THE CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER AND WE'RE IN
FRONT SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
NOW TO LIVE. THREE THIRTY FIVE
THREE THIRTY FIVE. SECOND
BALLOT NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER EXPORT. YOU. GOOD ALIVE
THREE EIGHTY ONE THREE EIGHTY
ONE. TEN A CAVITY A CALIFORNIA
WORK AND FAMILY COALITION WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR OVER
TEN YEARS THE WORKS CITED AND
THEN BURIED. THANK YOU. AND OUT
OF LIFE FOR FIFTY NINE OR FIFTY
NINE. YES LEAD ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH BACK WITH CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND PROVIDE
NINETY EIGHT NINETY EIGHT.
HELLO CHEN MEMBERS FEDERAL
TRAINED WITH AND AT THE TOP
BURKE TRUMP'S. THANK YOU. GET
OUT ALIVE. FOR NINETY EIGHT
FOUR NINETY EIGHT. HI THIS IS
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE
STRONGER CALIFORNIAN ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND OUTLINED. FIVE
OH ONE FIVE OH ONE. THIS IS
KEVIN IN SCOPE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORTER
THAT BE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND OUTLINED ONE THIRTY FOUR.
HELLO THIS IS ROBBIE GONZALEZ A
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BREASTFEEDING COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
NOW TO LINE FOR SIXTY SEVEN. AT
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN. THANKS FOR
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS GONNA
BE ON MUTE. WILL MOVE ALONG THE
LINE. THREE FORTY FIVE THREE
FORTY FIVE. SORRY ABOUT THAT ON
YOU THIS IS BAD YOU VERY WELL
AT THE AT THE W. OUR STATE
COUNSEL AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND OUTLINED FOR
EIGHTY THREE OR EIGHTY THREE.
MY ANGER ON A CELLULAR
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND LINE FOR FIFTY THREE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON LISA
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH CENTER FOR JUSTICE WE'RE
IN THE WRONG SUPPORT OF THAT
THE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IT IS A
MORAL BILL THAT WILL HELP US
ACHIEVE QUALITY. THE QUALITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND LINE
TO SIXTY ONE WE GO AHEAD. BUT I
AND TWO SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JESSICA
BACK BOTH THE LEFT AND CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND OUT OF LINE FIVE
TWELVE FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. STATE AND LOCAL WITH
REBA GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING THE MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CHAPTERS IN
THE VIETNAM THAT IS AMERICA
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND OUR TO LINE NINETEEN
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH
DUGGAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AN OUTLINE FOR SIXTY FOUR FOUR
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BREAKER YOSHI HIGH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS INSTANTIATION ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THAT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND OUTLINED FOR
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO
THAT THE FAMILY NOT FOR ME
FAMILIAR VOTER AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANDOUTLINED FOR SIXTY TWO OR
SIXTY TWO. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISRICT
NINE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
OUTLINED. FIVE HUNDRED FIVE
HUNDRED. JACKIE FINAL WITH THE
CONSUMER TRYING TO CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GIVE AN OUTLINE. FOR SIXTY FOUR
SIX. HI THIS IS JILL THOMPSON
ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC COUNCIL IN
LOS ANGELES I DIRECT WOMEN AND
GIRLS RIGHTS PROJECT AND WE
SUPPORT AND PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES TO LOW WAGE WOMEN
WORKERS AND THIS BILL IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL FOR THEM
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND OUTLINED.
FIFTY THREE FIFTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIN EVENTS
ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
OUTLINED FIVE OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OUR THE CAPRI O BEHALF
OF RESPECT CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IT OUTLINES FIVE OH TWO.
YOU'RE ABOUT TO HAPPEN MARKET
ON THIS BOX FOR. THANK YOU. AT
OUTLINED FOR NINETY TWO OR
NINETY TWO. BUT DAVID FIBER
REFUSING THEY ARE P. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
OUTLINED. FIVE THIRTEEN FIVE
THIRTEEN. I FIVE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AT FIVE THIRTEEN
IS YOUR FOR NINETY. IF THE
PENCIL IS NOT FUN IN BEHALF OF
FEDERAL FUNDS DEFECTED IN
COLLISION AND WE'RE IN A STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND OUTLINED FIVE OH
NINE FIVE OR NINE BY HAD. TURN
ON YOUR MULLIN BURKE WITH BURKE
EQUITY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AB LINE FOR NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AT FOUR NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL HAVE
TO MOVE ON THAT WOULD BE TO
FIND FOR NINETY NINE OR NINETY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
THAT MATT REGAN FROM THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. YOU AN BY.
FOUR FIFTY TWO FOUR FIFTY TWO.
HI THIS IS ELECTED A FIGURE ON
THE CHAIR THE ORANGE COUNTY
EQUALITY COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT THAT THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
OUTLINED FOR FIFTY EIGHT OR
FIFTY EIGHT. HI THIS IS MARIA
WITH A RUSSIAN OFFICIATED
CENTER SOME OF THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY UP SB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND OUTLINED
SIXTY EIGHT PORTS BECAUSE THE
EIGHT. JEFF IN ROWS ON BEHALF
OF WITH THE CHANGE ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YOU AN OUTLINE FOR EIGHTY EIGHT
OR EIGHTY EIGHT. VIDEO ONE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
OF A MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION WE ARE
JENNIFER PEREIRA WITH CAL
CHAMBER BY PHONE AND KATIE
HANSON OF THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION ALSO BY
PHONE BUNDLE EACH OF UP TO TWO
MINUTES SO- JENNIFER BROWN YOU
MAY BEGIN. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JENNIFER UBER
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. WE ARE IN
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY WHERE
THERE'S AN ONGOING PANDEMIC
THAT IS DESTROYED OUR ECONOMY
AND THAT THE STATUS QUO
BUSINESS I'M SURE EVERYONE IN
THAT THEY OVER HALF WITH SMALL
BUSINESS THAT PERSONALLY SHUT
DOWNFOR GOOD AS A RESULT OF
THE PANDEMIC WE CAN BE IN
COMPANIES SAY THAT THAT 20% OF
A SMALL BUSINESSES. DOWN LOWER
POLICEMEN YOU WE AND BUT SHE
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT'S GOING
AND THAT TO. SO UNDER THE-
CONDITION THIS IS THE OUTCOME
THAT WE'RE HAVING A- BIT. AND
SO ATTY THE NEW. ON BIT THAT
TIME WHAT COMPLY DEAF ON. AT
THE- EIGHTY THREE. A TWELVE
WEEK LEAVE ABSENCE MANDATORY NO
CAN. FOR BUSINESS OPERATION ON
ANY EMPLOYER WITH THE MORE WE-
FOUR. TO A TIE RIGHT OF ACTION
NOW I HEARD THAT ABBOTT THEY
THIS IS THE- FRAMEWORK AND THE-
pAFTER REMEDY WITH YOU CAN GO TO
SEND A LETTER. THAT'S TRUE BUT
EXHAUSTION OF ADMINISTRATIVE
REMEDY TAKES ABOUT ONE MINUTE
WHEN YOU GO ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING WHAT. AND THEN YOUR
ALLOWED TO GO THREE. GATE IT'S
NOT. JUST PROVIDING TWELVE
WEEKS OF LEAVE AND IT AND THAT
THAT. THERE ARE BOOK. HE DID.
LEAST. THE MEDICAL CERTIFICATES
THAT THE CLOAK ABOUT EARLIER.
HE DID THE REGULATIONS WITH
REGARD TO HOW AND WHEN YOU CAN
AFTER THE MEDICAL CERTIFICATION
FROM THE EMPLOYEE ONE MISTAKE
AS A RESULT OF IMPLEMENTING THE
LEAVE AND A SMALL EMPLOYER
GOING TO BE FACING LITIGATION
NOW. I'VE WORKED WITH DEFENDER
JACK ON THE ISSUE FOR MANY
YEARS. AND THERE'S CAN COMMENT
THAT WOULD COME UP IN
RESPONSIBILITY CATION ONE.
FAMILY MEMBER TO COMPLETE YOUR
TAKING TIME OFF TO CARE FOR A
CHILD OR ARE CARING FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
DOING WELL THAT ACTUALLY IT'S
NOT. ABOUT THE DATA FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING. ACNE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CASES FILED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN APPROXIMATE TWENTY
SEVEN. KEEP IT OUT AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NOT THE MOST RECENT
DATA FROM THE TO GET THE H. AN
OUT OF THOSE CASES THAT WERE
FILED OVER HALF. AFTER. THEIR
YOU'RE RIGHT YOU TO GO. AND
THEN I. TWO HUNDRED THERE ARE A
LOT OF HEAT IN LITTLE FOR CARE
THINK BE GOING UP IT LOOK TO
GET THAT AGAIN HELLO EMPLOYERS
HAVEN'T MARIE KIRK MINUTE HELP
COUNCIL TO ASSIST THEM AND IF
YOU EXPAND THE WE NEED TO FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW EMPLOYERS.
WHICH WILL IS WHAT IT WOULD BE
BUT- FIVE EMPLOYEES AND FORTY
NINE THAT LITIGATION IS GOING
TO GO UP EVEN MORE THE SECOND
COMMON OCCURRED IN
RESPONSIBILITY GAUGE AGENT.
EMPLOYMENT AND HELPING CAN'T
HANDLE WHAT COMPLAINT THAT
WOULD COME IN WELL THAT BACK
NOT TRUE IN THE- ALLEGED THAT
THE GET THE H. PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND WHILE. ABOVE
ALL THEIR COMPLAINTS WITHIN ONE
YEAR THERE IS NO BACKLOG THAT
THE AT THE AGE HAS EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW. TO
INVESTIGATE AND RESOLVE THE
COMPLAINT IN A TIMELY FASHION
SO I'M NOT SURE WHY DURING A
PANDEMIC. LET'S NOT BUSINESSES
ARE ALREADY PEPPERING BUT-
THREATEN THEM WITH LITIGATION
THAT COMPLETELY PUT HIM OUT OF
BUSINESS. AT TIME I ALSO WANT
TO TALK FOR A MOMENT. ABOUT THE
BUSINESS OF THE GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE. THE ONLY BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S CAP FOR THE OTHER
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND THE
ACTUAL QUOTE. MEASURE RIGHT NOW
THE SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY IS
NOT ACTUALLY A MEMBERSHIP.
ORGANIZATION THEY DON'T HAVE A
MEMBERSHIP. AND FOR THEM
DIRECTLY THAT BUSINESS. ARE
BOARDED BUT DE. BUT WILL GIVE
YOU DON'T ASK ANY WOMAN AND-
THE. FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS THAT BOOK. EXPANDING
FAMILY MEDICAL LEAVE ON THE
QUALITY. AT FEDERAL. MEDICAL
LEAVE WHICH IS. WITH THE- AND
THEY ACTUALLY INDICATE THAT IT
WOULD. THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS MON
AND DEPUTY THEN GET BACK. DID
OCCUR. RECENT MORE ARE. THAN
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
THAT THING THINKING AS PER A
KID HAS. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER I'M HERE SOMETHING
WITH IT HOW RUSHED AT THE- HERE
IN RESPECTFUL UP WITH. TO JEAN
PUBLIC HEALTH BUT HE BUT STATE
TOOK A BREATH OF NECESSARY
STOCK. ATTACK THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF OUR STATE
PRESIDENT. FORTUNATELY THE
TRADE OFF FOR THE PROTECTIVE
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES HAVE
BEEN IN YOUR DEFINITION OF OUR
STEAK RESTAURANT INDUSTRY.
OTHER THAN FOR THE MERGING THE
ECONOMIC SHUT DOWN I'VE BEEN
INCREDIBLY HARMFUL TO A
RESTAURANT IN CALIFORNIA. EVERY
DAY WE SEE NEW HEADLIGHT
DEMOCRAT ABOUT PERMANENT
RESTAURANT CLOSURES. RECENTLY
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S ECONOMIC
APERTURE COURT FIGHTING THE TOP
FIFTEEN RIGHT CITIES WITH HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF PERMANENT
RESTAURANT CLOSURES. EIGHT OF
THE CITY ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
PRIOR TO HAVE A NINETEEN THE
RUSSIAN COMMUNITY WITH THE
LARGEST PRIVATE EMPLOYER
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD. WHICH IS
GENERATOR AT STATE AND LOCAL
SALES TAX. WHICH COMMUNITY FOR
THE PENTAGON NOW MORE THAN EVER
AS WE HOPE TO EMERGE FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. BUT BY
DEFAULT I'M JOB. ANY OTHER
INDUSTRY. RESTAURANTS REFLECT
THE. GREAT DIVERSITY STATE
SIXTY. I PUT THAT. MANAGERS
ARMOR ARE AND 80% OF SHE OUR
MAIN OR ADDITIONAL RESTAURANT
LIKE MORE MANAGE ANY AND INTO
WE NEED OUR RESTAURANT BY
PANDEMIC THAT THEY CAN HELP IT
HE BACK TO WORK AND GENERATE
TALK OUR STATE AND LOCAL.
BREAST FOR SMALL BUSINESS AND
DO NOT HAVE AN MEET OUR ABOUT
TO TRY DOC EACH HOUR AND TAKE
OFF FOR THE THAT PARTLY
IMPORTANT AT EIGHT THIRTEEN
THREE YOUR CREDIT RATING ACTION
ONE MOMENT STATE THE MINISH
THAT EXPOSES MALL RUSHED TO THE
HOSPITAL. WHICH IS NOT TO
PERMANENTLY CLOSED OUR
RESTAURANT TO STRUGGLE TO
SURVIVE THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. WE
REQUIRE NO VOTE ON THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU ANOTHER
TAKE PUBLIC COM FOR THOSE OF
AGAIN JUST YOUR AFFILIATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL IF YOU'RE
ON THE PHONE DON'T FORGET TO ON
MUTE WHEN YOUR NUMBER'S CALLED
IN THE ROOM ANYONE. ANYONE IN
THE REMOTE TO MONEY STATION. SO
NEXT FOR A MISTER MODERATOR TO
BE HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE. DO AND ARE FIRST
PERSON AND ONLINE FOR NINETY
SEVEN OR NINETY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
FORMER TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND OUTLINED. FOR NINETY
FOUR NINETY. FRIDAY
REPRESENTING NFIB WERE SMALL
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING FIFTEEN THOUSAND
SMALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND NOW TO THE LINE OR.
THIRTEEN FOR THIRTEEN. BUT BILL
GIVENS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICT ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
OUTLINED OR NINETY SIX OR
NINETY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
LOOKED AT JUSTIN HIGHER ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LIVE OR
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FRIDAY TO BUY TACKY WITH
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITY DISSERTATION
RESPECTFUL UP THAT SHOULD.
THANK YOU. GET OUT ALIVE. THREE
THIRTEEN THREE THIRTEEN. KAREN
STILL VERY REPRESENTING THE
GATEWAY CHAMBERS ALLIANCE
THIRTEEN LOCAL CHAMBERS OF THE
GATEWAY REGION- LA COUNTY AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
AND OUT LINE. THREE SEVENTY ONE
THREE SEVENTY ONE. GOOD EVENING
FORGET ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
BUSINESS SB NATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA.
I WORK WITH THE READY. WITH A
PEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE FOR SEVENTY FOUR OR
SEVENTY FOUR. DOWN ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS CONTRACTORS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
RESPECTFUL UP IN THE PHONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW TO
LIVE ONE A ONE ONE A ONE. ALL
RIGHTS WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NOW
TO LIVE FIVE TEN FIVE TEN.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS GET
THE MILLION ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA A
FARMERS THE CALIFORNIA BEING.
CHIPPER DISSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT THE OF THE
CAL STATE FOR A LESSER A TRIP
AND ALL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND OUR TO LINE. THREE FORTY
NINE THREE FORTY NINE. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS DAVE BUT
LET REPRESENTING THE UNITED
CHAMBER ADVOCACY NETWORK A
COALITION OF. SEVEN LOCAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ORGANIZATIONS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
FIVE THOUSAND. MEMBER
BUSINESSES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. AND OUTLINED FOR TWENTY
ONE. MR KERRY MEMBERS WRANGLING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
OUTLINED FIVE ALL THREE FIVE
ALL THE. THIRTY BOILED IN
BEHALF THE AMERICAN NATIONAL
GROWERS NOT POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OUTLINE OF TWO FIFTY
FOUR TO FIFTY FOUR FOOT BUT
HADN'T. THE VAN THE THIRTY HERE
THE CALIFORNIA THEY GET THE
PRODUCERS IN OPPOSITION STAFF
THANK YOU. AND OUTLINED FIVE
FOURTEEN BY PORTAL BUT IF YOU.
BELIEVE WHAT THE BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
IN CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
FOR SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MELANIE GRIFFITH BUT THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. AT THE OUTLINED FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT. COURSE EIGHT
WEEKS AHEAD WELL. THIS IS TRUE.
THANK YOU. I FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO. CLOSE POINT LITTLE
CAL FUND BUREAU FOR AND
RESPECTFUL OFFICE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. IF AND OUR. FOR TO
FOUR ZERO TWO. HI MY NAME IS
MICHAEL THE CAL ASSOCIATION OF
WHY CREEK WE RESPECT OPPOSE AND
ALSO WHAT OPERATE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES WILL BE
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL DOCTOR
STATED THAT THE OPPOSITION
FRONT CHEN UP HERE THERE'S NO
GETTING UP HERE ON THIS BILL
THE PEERS REAL AND I BUT I'M
HAPPY TO LOOK AT THE COMMITTEE
AGREES JUST ABOUT. TROUBLING TO
STEP IN BUSINESS. EXTRA MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NOT BY
FOR NINETY FOUR OR NINETY FOUR.
BUSINESSES ARE YEAH THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF A COMMITTEE THAT
PATRICK'S WORKED OUT WITH THE
GREATER COACHELLA VALLEY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
REPRESENTING FIVE CHAMBERS AND
FOURTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. A GOOD OUTLINE OF THREE.
THIRTY SEVEN THREE THIRTY
SEVEN. HI THIS IS A KEY FIGURE
SAY WHAT THE CALIFORNIA GRIFFIS
IS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND OUTLINED FOR NINETY THREE
OR NINETY THREE. AARON CAREER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONS AND PARKS
ASSOCIATION ALL ABOUT THE
TEXAN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
CLEAN UP THAT LINE FIVE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. DONNA DO
PERON TORRENT AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. Q. AND NOW WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE OKAY THANK YOU SO OVER
HERE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
EMOTIONS AS A MEMBER CARILLO-
BUT SURE FLOOR. THANK YOU CHAIR
SENATOR. YEAH THERE'S A THERE'S
A COUPLE THINGS THAT THAT ROB
REALLY CONCERNING AND WE'VE HAD
A FEW BILLS TODAY AND YOUR BY
QUALITY HAVE SPOKE ABOUT. THEIR
EXPERIENCE ON WHY THOSE BILLS
WHY THESE BILLS ARE IMPORTANT
TO THEM. AND SIMON SPEAK FOR
JUST A FEW MOMENTS ON MY
EXPERIENCE- WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. I FAMILY'S
BEEN IN BUSINESS IT'S SOME
ASPECT IN OUR CULTURE FOR. MANY
YEARS. AND WHEN YOU START A
BUSINESS. YOU DON'T START WITH
ONE OR TWO THREE EMPLOYEES
ESPECIALLY WHERE IN OUR CULTURE
YOU START WITH FIVE TO TEN
SOMEWHERE RIGHT IN THERE
BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE TRYING
THERE'S GROUND THAT YOU HAVE TO
COVER THERE'S THINGS THAT HAVE
TO BE REPAIRED. AND IF WE START
DOING THIS WE START HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY. AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT. YEAH IF
SOMEBODY GOES OUT ON FAMILY
LEAVE THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND I WOULD SAY THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY. OF
BUSINESSES ALLOW FOR THAT. I
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
THAT THOSE STAY IN PLACE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO. BUT WHEN WE HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE TO
EXPAND THIS. WE HAVE GIVE THEM.
FOR WEEKS LEAVE. IT IN THE IT'S
IN THE- WELL IT'S IN THE TWELVE
SET UP TO TWENTY FOUR WEEKS OF
ANNUALLY. SO MAYBE THERE'S
SOMETHING I'M MISREADING BUT
THAT'S WHAT IT SAYS HERE. THE
WHEN WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
AND WE'RE STEP IN THERE.
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE
PROTECT. THE EMPLOYEES WHEN THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY SHUTS THEIR
DOORS. AFTER CO THAT ONE IN
THREE WILL NOT REOPEN IN THE
SMALL BUSINESS COMMITTEE WHEN
THE REST OF THE BUSINESS ME
SAYS YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN'T DO
THIS ANYMORE WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
HIRE MORE PEOPLE. WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO HAVE THAT MANY PEOPLE
OFF AT ONE TIME. IT'S NO LONGER
WORTH IT. NOW WHAT WE HAVE WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
UNEMPLOYED. AND I FIND A FAST
NEED TO SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY
WHO HAS SPOKE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS- SAYS THAT THEY REPRESENT
OVER YOU'LL FOUR MILLION
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
THEY HAVE NO MEMBERSHIP. I
THAT'S FASCINATING TO ME
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW THAT YOU
CAN REPRESENT SOMEBODY. IF YOU
HAVE NO MEMBERSHIP. SO WHEN YOU
SAID ON THE GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE YOU HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS LIKE. THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THAT IS IN
OPPOSITION THOSE RE THE ONES
THAT ACTUALLY PLOY PEOPLE.
THEY'RE NOT JUST A SHELL
COMPANY. THEY'RE NOT JUST A
CHAU ORGANIZATION THAT YOU CAN
HIDE BEHIND AND SAY WE
REPRESENT THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY WHEN YOU ABSOLUTELY
DO NOT. THE ONLY CHAMBER. IS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS. AND THERE
WAS STUDIES THAT WERE PUT OUT
IN THE BAY AREA COUNCIL. A
STUDY AND I WOULD LOVE- AND I
AM IN ASKS FOR THE BUSINESS
THREE TO RESPOND TO THIS. BUT I
LOVE BECAUSE ANY STUDY. THAT
SAYS THAT THIS IS BENEFICIAL TO
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY. IS
FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG YOU MAY
LIKE IT YOU WE MAY ALL BE ABLE
TO AGREE THAT PAID FAMILY LEAVE
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND I
BELIEVE THAT AS WELL. BUT THE
FUNDAMENTAL FLAW IS TO SAY THAT
THIS IS GOOD. FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY. IS WRONG. IT'S
FACTUALLY INACCURATE IN FOR
SOME OF THESE FOLKS TO COME IN
SUPPORT POUNDING THEIR DROP
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE REPRESENTING
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IS QUITE
FRANKLY IRRITATING. BECAUSE I
CAN TELL YOU MAIN STREET
AMERICA. IS GETTING DEVASTATED.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE THAT WERE
IN SUPPORT COME FROM THE ROLE
COMMUNITIES. NONE OF A AND THAT
TOO IS GOING TO GET JUST
HAMMERED WHEN YOU DRIVE. DOWN
MAIN STREET MY DISTRICT
EVERYTHING'S BOARD UP. DOES IT
ARE BOARDED UP ON THE RAGGED
EDGE. THEY WERE WITHIN DAYS OR
WEEKS OF NEVER RE OPENING THEIR
DOORS AGAIN. AND SO THIS KIND
OF BILL THOUGH IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE PROTECT
FAMILY LEAVE AND I CAN SUPPORT
THAT. I THINK THE OVERWHELMING
SCOPE OF THIS PARTICULAR PIECE
OF LEGISLATION- IS
PARTICULARLY- QUITE FRANKLY
REGIS AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL DO. IRREVERSIBLE HARM
TO THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
BECAUSE WHEN NOBODY OPENS OUR
DOORS AGAIN BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
DEAL WITH ALL OF THE NEW
REGULATIONS THAT WE AS A
BUILDING PUT ON TOP IT'S NOT
JUST ONE OR THE OTHER IT'S NOT
LIKE THIS IS THE ONLY BUILD
WE'VE DONE THIS YEAR THAT
AFFECTS THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
AND WE MAY ALL OF THEM IN THE
TYLER. STACK THEM ONTOP OF
EACH OTHER. AND WE SAY NEXT
YEAR THE BUSINESS THREE IS
GONNA HAVE TO ALL OF THESE
THINGS. PEOPLE ARE GONNA SAY WE
CAN'T DO THAT. AND THEY'RE
GONNA SHUT THE DOORS IN THE
REST OF THE EMPLOYEES ARE GOING
TO BE OUT OF A JOB. SO I WOULD
ACTUALLY I DO WANT THEM THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY WHOEVER WANTS TO QUEUE
UP. TO RESPOND TO THAT BAY AREA
COUNCIL STUDY BECAUSE I THINK
THEY WILL HAVE A VERY UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT PARTICULAR
STUDY. THROUGH THE CHAIR PLEASE
SURE- THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR IS A- JENNIFER PEREIRA
ONLINE OR ANYONE ELSE- JENNIFER
BERKEY HANSON WHO ARE THE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES. AT AROUND
HERE THIS IS JENNIFER OKAY GOOD
GO AHEAD JENNIFER IF YOU WANT
TO OF ANSWER THE QUESTION. THE
VICE CHAIR. YEAH THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR AT THE
DAIRY COUNCIL STUDY- AND THEY
WOULD BRIEFLY BUT THE MENTION
LOOK AT THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM WHICH IS NOT WHAT THE
BILL'S ABOUT THE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM TO THE WEIGHT
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM. THAT PRIOR
TO JULY THIRD PROVIDED SIX
WEEKS OF WEIGHT REPLACEMENT NOW
IT PROVIDES EIGHT WEEKS OF
WEIGHT REPLACEMENT- IT IS NOT.
A MANDATORY LEAVE WITH A THREAT
AT PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IF
YOU DO ANYTHING WRONG WITH IT
IT IS A OPPORTUNITY WHEN AN
EMPLOYER PROVIDES HIGH MARKS
FOR AN EMPLOYEE TO GET WAGE
REPLACEMENT BENEFITS FOR THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL LOOK AT THE
KEY TO FAMILY. PROGRAM IN IN
HEARING AFTER THE ORANGES HERE.
AND YEAH SAID YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN THAT. THIS IF YOU WERE
ABLE GET THAT. OFF DIDN'T
HAPPEN IT VICTOR EXCEPT FOR
REFERENCE TO AND IF I EAT THAT
IN THAT THEY MAY. THE IF I'D BE
STUDY I THINK THE COP AT THE
MINT COURT STANDING. HEATHROW
OR- WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY THE
SAME THING. THAT THERE COULD BE
300-005-0000. DOLLARS AND
COCKED TO A SMALL BUSINESS.
HERE AT THE MALL. THE
REPRESENTATIVE MAY. COST BUT
AGAIN THE BAY AREA COUNCIL WAS
NOT LOOKING AT THE CORRECT VAN
IN WHICH- THE- PUBLIC TO DO.
THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU THANK
GOODNESS FOR SURE A SUMMER
CARILLO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I UNDERSTAND THE GOAL OF THE
BILL SENATOR JACKSON'S- MANY
MANY YEARS AGO- WHEN I DID NOT
HAVE THIS INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE THE STATE
I HAD A REGULAR JOB NINE FIVE
IN OFFICE MY GRANDMOTHER GOT
WELL AND I DID NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE FAMILY
LEAVE BECAUSE A GRANDPARENT
WASN'T A PART OF THE LANGUAGE
IN WHICH I COULD TAKE LEAVE AND
KNOW THAT I WAS GOING TO COME
BACK. AND HAVE JOB SO- TAKING
EXUM CATION TIME AND THINGS
LIKE THAT TO BE ABLE TO BUY THE
THEM ON WHETHER NEAT. THOUGHT
HE- SUN SUPPORT THE IDEA
SPENDING. OUT FAMILY IS BECAUSE
WE ALL HAVE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
FAMILIES THE NUCLEAR FAMILY IS
NOT THE SAME ANYMORE IF IT WAS
ONCE DESCRIBED BUT- AND
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO
CARE FOR THEIR FAMILY MEMBER
ESPECIALLY. DURING THIS TIME I-
HAVE DIVED A LITTLE BIT DEEPER
INTO OUT WHAT TRADITIONALLY IS
NOT MY SCHOOL AND THAT IS THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY ONE BECAUSE
I HOPE UNDERSTAND A BETTER
BECAUSE I REPRESENT A DISK THAT
IS TWENTY PERCENT. THE NATIONAL
POVERTY LINE AND A WAY TO GET
OUT OF POVERTY IS TO HAVE A
GOOD JOB- AND HOPEFULLY GOOD
WAGES AND COLLECTIONS WILL BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT. I WAS
CARRYING A BIT. A BIT THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX AS A FOOD
SAFETY DELIVERY BILL THAT
SIMPLY WOULD HAVE. MADE IT
THAT- ANY RESTAURANT THAT HAS
OR USES A SERVICE FOR DELIVERY.
HAS THE UP TO DATE. CLOSE DOES
THE THANKS. AND IF YOU'RE USING
A THIRD APPS LIKE AT YOUR FOOD
DELIVER THEY TO YOUR FOOD IS
NOT TAMPER. I BRING THAT AYE
AYE CHAU THAT WITH THE BECAUSE
ONE THAT IS MAIN. ON THE THINK
SHOULD MOVE FORWARD BUT I WAS
ABLE TO REALLY GET MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SMALL
RESTAURANTS IN MY COMMUNITY-
MOST OF WHOM ARE SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY CALL OF IT. MOST OF
THEM ARE OWNED BY A THEIR SMALL
MOM AND POP RESTAURANT CREDIBLE
FOOD AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE- BUT CLOSE TO SEVEN
THOUSAND SMALL RESTAURANTS AND
MY DISTRICT THE MAJORITY OF HIM
EIGHTY PERCENT. EMPLOYEE LET
THE NINE PEOPLE. I'M AND I'M
THINKING ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHTS ACT- IN
COMPARISON TO. PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PAID FAMILY LEAVE DOESN'T
HAVE THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. AS THE US THE FRONT US
AND SO WHAT I WOULD WANT TO
AVOID IN MY COMMUNITY AND
REALLY ACROSS THE STATE IS FOR
THE SMALL MOM AND POP SHOPS TO
BE UNDER UNNECESSARY
LITIGATION. BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A HUGE HUMAN RESOURCE
DEPARTMENT. IT'S A FAMILY
MEMBER THIS TAKING CARE OF THE
DAY TO DAY PAYROLL THEY'RE
TAKING CARE OF THE NECESSITIES
OF THE RESTAURANT- SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS IF YOUR
GOAL IS TO ALIGN. AND TO EXPAND
AND PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE ACROSS
THE STATE TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
THEIR JOBS WOULD YOU CONSIDER.
TAKING AN AMENDMENT THAT
REMOVES A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION TO THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION YEAH YOU KNOW TIS
THIS WHOLE NOTION ABOUT A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION CREATES
TERRIBLE PROBLEMS FOR EVERYONE
IS JUST NOT ACCURATE. IT IS
THIS BILL WILL BE- INCLUDE IT
WILL BE WITHIN AN EXISTING
FRAMEWORK WE DON'T SEE THESE
LAWSUITS THE WAY THE CHAMBER
TRIES TO BRING IN FACT WE HEARD
THE SAME THING THREE YEARS. WE
DID THE BILL ON PARENT LEAF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THE- DOES
TO ALLOW A PER. RIGHT OF ACTION.
THE RIGHT OF ACTION- CAN ONLY
OCCUR AFTER ALL REMEDIES ARE
EXHAUSTED AND IF AN EMPLOYER
HAS- IT'D VERDANT LEE DENIED
SOMEONE THAT RIGHT TO TAKE THE
LEAVE IF THEY TAKE THE EMPLOYEE
BACK THERE'S NO LAWSUIT THERE'S
NO DAMAGES SO BASICALLY. TO
PROVIDE THEM THE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE THIS ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS WHEN THE SMALL BUSINESS
PERSON CAN BE ADVISED THAT THE
LAW GIVES THAT EMPLOYEE THE
RIGHT TO TAKE THE LEAVE IF THEY
ARE SICK THEMSELVES. AND
REMEMBER. WHAT WE'RE HEARING
NOW IS I THINK THE SUGGESTION
IS THAT BUSINESSES ARE GOING
UNDER NOT BECAUSE A COVERT BUT
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE ARE TAKE
LEAVE THAT THAT ISN'T IT IN
FACT IF I'M AN EMPLOYEE AND I
HAVE COLD BUT I BETTER GET THE
HECK OUT OF THERE WORKPLACE
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO AFFECT
EVERYBODY ELSE. I WANT A MODEL
THAT WORKPLACE PEOPLE LARGEST
LEAVING THEIR WORK PLACES IN
DROVES BECAUSE OF COLD. THE
RESTAURANT CHARGE SUFFERING
BECAUSE EMPLOYEES ARE WORKING.
PEOPLE THAT RESTAURANTS ARE
SUFFERING BECAUSE PEOPLE AREN'T
GOING OUT AND BECAUSE I CAN'T
WORK THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
TO BE ABLE TO GO TO THE
RESTAURANT. AND HAVE DINNERS
OUT. I MEAN IT THAT'S NOT THE
CARS HERE AND I THINK WHAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT LEAST LET'S
LET'S REVERSE THAT LENDS A
LITTLE BACK. AND LOOK AT THE
FACT. THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK.
SHOULD NOT BE AT WORK BUT YOU
KNOW IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE HAVE ONLY BY LAW THREE
PAID SICK DAYS A YEAR. SO
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS. THAT
PEOPLE ARE TAKING THEIR NOT
LEAVING WORK THEY'RE NOT
GETTING TESTED IF THEY'RE ILL
THEY'RE NOT DOING WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO TO PROTECT THE REST
OF US BECAUSE THEY NEED THAT
JOB. THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO
WORK EVEN IF THEY'RE SICK. SO
WHAT WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE. WHEN THEY ARE
SICK OR WHEN YOUR GRANDMOTHER
IS CHICKEN YES YOU CAN'T JUST
TAKE THE LEAF YOU CAN BE
REQUIRED TO USE UP TIME THAT
YOU'VE MADE HAD AVAILABLE TO
YOU. AT CHECK FOR. IT BASICALLY
CHURCH SAYS. YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO GET PAID AND I THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT YOU'RE NOT BEING
PAID. SO THE EMPLOYER CAN BRING
IN TEMPORARY HELP. DURING THAT
PERIOD OF TIME BUT THAT
ACTUALLY ONLY HAPPENS IN THE
SMALL BUSINESSES. 19% OF THE
TIME. WHAT HAPPENS IS EVERYBODY
WORKS TOGETHER. THE NOTION THAT
SUDDENLY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ALL THIS LITIGATION IS THE
CONSTANT CLAIM THAT THE CHAMBER
MAKES IT'S NEVER. BEEN PROVEN
CORRECT. WE HAD TO- I THINK
WITH NEW PARENT LEAVE WE HAD
AVAILABLE TO US. TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE NOW HAVE
THE RIGHT TO TAKE THAT LEAVE.
THE TOTAL AFTER THE FIRST YEAR
WHEN COMPANIES WERE ARGUABLY
JUST LEARNING ABOUT IT THERE
WERE SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
RIGHT TO TWO LETTERS. THERE
WERE ISSUED OUT OF TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE ABLE TO
ACCESS THAT LAW. SIX SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY RIGHT TO OTHERS
NOW THAT THERE IS NO WAY SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY PEOPLE FILE
LAWSUITS. WELL DON'T SUE FOR
THIS THEY WANT THEIR JOBS. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SO IT IS I THINK IMPORTANT THAT
AT SOME POINT IN TIME WE ALIGN
ALL THIS. SO WE DON'T HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHT CHECK
THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE ACT AND
THEN THE ABILITY TO HAVE JOB
PROTECTION. THEY SHOULD ALL BE
IN ONE SYSTEM THIS MEASURE
TRIES TO START MAKING THAT
ALIGNMENT. THE PEOPLE WE DON'T
WANT PEOPLE SHOULD GET SHOWING
IN BEING SUED WE'VE GOT TO HAVE
GREATER CLARITY ON WHAT THE LAW
IS THAT PART OF WHAT THIS BILL
THE AND I UNDERSTAND THAT ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT- I SLIGHTLY
DISAGREE WITH. YOU IN TERMS OF-
YOUR STATEMENT THAT COLD IT IS
NOT THE REASON WHY RESTAURANTS
ARE NOT ONLY THE REASON MARK IT
IS THE REASON WHY THE.
STRUCTURE MUCH TO. IN THIS BOOK
IT'S THAT THEY'RE AND- ARE
WORKING. WHILE WORKING AS A OF
IT WE HAVE SHUT DOWN OF COURSE
SO THAT OBVIOUSLY IMPACTING
RESTAURANTS THE DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE PATIO
DINING RIGHT ALREADY THE ONLY
OPTION IS REALLY TAKE OUT
DELIVERY YEAH LISTEN I'M A BIG.
DATA PERSON SO I'M BUT I'M TO
USE IT AT ALL BUT BUT THE POINT
IS THAT IT'S NOT BECAUSE PEOPLE
WANT TO WORK. THAT THAT'S NOT
WHAT YOU KNOW. PEOPLE WANT TO
WORK AND THEY'RE DESPERATE TO
WORK AND THEY DON'T WORK THEY
DON'T GET PAID AND THEN THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY AND THEN
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT BEING
EVICTED I MEAN. THAT THIS THIS
BILL IS NOT THE PROBLEM. ARE AT
AN AYE I THINK WE HAVE TO.
REALIZE THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
IN FACT. WHEN YOU'RE IN A SMALL
BUSINESS I CAN TELL YOU ACT
LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLOOR AYE
I HAD A SMALL BUSINESS. AND I
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO WORK
REALLY HARD. BUT BUT- YOUR
EMPLOYEES IN A SMALL BUSINESS
REALLY YOUR FAMILY. THEY SPEND
MORE TIME WITH THEM PROBABLY
THEN YOU DO YOUR OWN FAMILY AND
YOU'RE RIGHT PEOPLE SHOULD BE
MAKING THIS AVAILABLE. BUT IN
THOSE INSTANCES WHEN THEY DON'T
OR THEY WON'T. THIS BILL CHOSE
GIVES PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CARE FOR A LOVED ONE. UHHUH IT
GIVES SOME DOCTOR BOND WITH A
NEWBORN. IT GIVES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE HER CELLS
WHEN THEY'RE SICK. THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES THIS BILL ISN'T.
AN ATTEMPT TO RIP OFF AN
EMPLOYER. THIS IS A BILL THAT
SAYS. AS I CAN BEING I HAVE.
THESE NEEDS. AND I TRUST WANT
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM. WITHOUT COST YOU A PENNY
IN TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT YOU MAY
NEED TO GO OUT SHOP. BUT TO DO
THAT AND I WILL TELL. THAT IT
VERY. THAT WAY COMPANIES FOR
THIS SHOULD THE- AT THE TIME
FOR THE FOR PEOPLE TO WHAT THEY
NEED DO IS FROM BEINGS THEY
SAVE MONEY SAY DON'T. TRY TO
TAKE OVER JOB THEY COME
TOGETHER YOU KNOW COMPANIES ONE
OF THE THINGS ARE WHICH WERE A
LITTLE BIT MORE POSITIVE ABOUT
SMALL BUSINESS SMALL BUSINESSES
A REALLY VERSATILE WE GET OUT A
SMALL BUSINESSES TAXABLE IF
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO TAKE ON A JOB
THAT JOE WAS DOING BUT CHOSE
BEEN OUT SICK- OR WAS IN A CAR
ACCIDENT BUT- FELL OFF HISBIKE
OR SOMETHING. BUT HE STEPS IN
WE BACK TO THAT FIRST PEOPLE
BUT WE GIVE CHAU THAT TIME TO
KEEP. YOU SAY. WE SEE SOMEBODY
WHO'S GOING TO CANCER TO FOR A-
I'M SORRY BUT YOU HAVE TO BACK
TO WORK BUT YOU CAN'T TAKE CARE
YOURSELF OR YOU CAN'T TAKE THE
TIME YOU NEED IF YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH CHEMOTHERAPY. YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN THERE AND I'LL TELL
YOU NOT VERY FUNCTIONAL FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME AFTER THAT
HAPPENS YOU NEED THAT TIME TO
REST YOU NEED THAT TIME TO
HEAL. TO NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE TO
MAKE THAT HOBSON'S CHOICE DO I
GO TO WORK. OUR OR DO I STAY
HOME AND TAKE CARE OF MYSELF
BECAUSE IF I STAY HOME AND CARE
OF. TAKE CARE OF MYSELF I'M
GONNA LOSE MY JOB. BUT YOUR
PEOPLE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO MAKE
THAT CHOICE. COMPLETELY AGREE-
MY CONCERN IS. FOR THAT SMALL
MOM AND POP RESTAURANT MY
DISTRICT THAT'S RUN BY AN
IMMIGRANT FAMILY WHO'S TRYING
TO MAKE ENDS MEET. WE CAN
PROVIDE ALL OF THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES TO THE EMPLOYEE. BUT
THERE AREN'T AS MANY RESOURCES
FOR THE OWNERS OF THAT SMALL
REST. TO HAVE. SOME IT KIND OF
THAT OUT OUR STATE IS THERE
AREN'T THAT MANY LAWSUIT
BECAUSE PEOPLE AREN'T FILING
LAWSUITS THEN WHY NOT REMOVE
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION BUT
LET ME ALSO FINISHED ON THE
CONTRARY IT'S ALSO IF WE DON'T
HAVE THE PRIVATE LAW THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION THEN
HOW DO WE ENFORCE THE LAW I I'D
LIKE SHE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
FROM BOTH SIDES OF POSSIBLE
MISTER CHAIR NOT THAT I WANT TO
LAY THE- THE COMPANY ANY
FURTHER I DO THINK IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BILL. THAT
NEEDS A LITTLE BIT MORE
DISCUSSION AND I WOULD HOPE
THAT YOU ARE OPEN TO THAT
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING AT IT ALL
THE SMALL PRESS IN MY COMMUNITY
THAT ARE DOWN. THEY'RE JUST IN.
LIKE ALLOW OF SUFFERING LIKE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA SAID AND
I'M LOOKING AT THREE ONE
PERSPECTIVE AND I'M SURE THERE
ARE MANY OTHER PERSPECTIVES
ACROSS THE STATE. IN TERMS OF
HOW DO WE BOTH. HELP THE
EMPLOYEE WHICH IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BASED ON. THE EXAMPLE
THAT I GAVE YOU ARE BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE AS A YOUNGER. AND
HOW. MAY I HELP. THIS OF. AND
NOT HAVE TO SHUT DOWN AND NOT
HAVE TO FEAR. LYTIC SO IF
POSSIBLE I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
ALL STATES BUT- OKAY. WE HAVE A
YEAH I DON'T KNOW SHARON
TERMINAL DELAYED WORK. ORIGIN
OF REP FROM CAL CHAMBER ON THAT
POINT REGARDING PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION. IF EITHER OF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK TO EITHER SIDE OF
THAT WOULD THIS BE FOR JANET
JENNIFER STATE OF STANDARD OF
THE MY FIRST WITH IF. MAKE MAY
BE THE BEST PERSON TO ANSWER
THIS. IN THIS ONE WE HAD SHARON
TERM INSURANCE YEAH SURE
INTERNAL LEGALLY DON'T WORK.
YES SO I DON'T KNOW SHARON'S
ONLINE. YEAH I'M HERE I'M HAPPY
TO SPEAK TO THAT POINT UNLESS.
YES SO AS AND SENATOR JACKSON'S
BINGE AND ON THIS BILL DOES NOT
ADD A NEW PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION THIS IS THE WELL
ESTABLISHED ENFORCEMENT SCHEME
THAT IN PART. I MEAN HELPING
OUT WHICH IS ALREADY TO
EMPLOYERS WITH FIVE OR MORE
EMPLOYEES. FOR DECADES AND IT'S
THE SAME ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
THAT ALREADY EXIST UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHT BACK.
AND IF THIS IMPORTANT HE
REQUIRES EMPLOYEES TO BOX
REMEDY IS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING. OR
THEY FIND A LOT. AGENCY OUR
FIRST WE NEED. AND TOOK BOTH
PARTIES IT CHARGE WITHIN THAT
CLAIM AND ON THE POINT OF THIS
YOU KNOW THE LAW IT YOU DO NEED
TO HAVE A PRIVATE RIGHT ACTION
ARE A BACK THOUGHT IN ORDER TO
HAVE THE MEANINGFUL ENFORCEMENT
BUT- I CONSIDER JACKSON
MENTIONED BUT THE LOW WAGE
WORKERS BUT WE WORK WELL THAT
WE HEARD FROM EVERY DAY.
THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED IN A LOT
BUT THEY WANTED TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND THEIR HEALTH AND
THE HEALTH OF THEIR FAMILIES
AND. THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR-
WITH THIS IS ABOUT IT'S ABOUT
ALLOW WORKERS TO CHARACTER.
WITHOUT HAVING TO FACT. THEIR
ACT THE- AND WE READ. THAT
CHALLENGES THAT BUSINESSES ARE
FACING RIGHT NOW BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO KNOW THE BUSINESSES ARE
COMPRISE OF HUMAN BEINGS WHO
GET. AND HAVE CHILDREN I NEED
TO CARE FOR ELEVEN ONES AND YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO SACRIFICE
THEIR ECONOMIC SECURITY. AND
OUR LIVELIHOOD TO DO SO. AND WE
NEED GOES HAND IN HAND WITH
DOCTOR JACKSON BENNY'S HAVE
SHOWN TIME AND TIME AGAIN THAT
WITHOUT THE JOB PROTECTION.
WORK PARTICULAR LOW WAGE
WORKERS IMMIGRANT WERE AND
WORKERS OF AMERICA. DO NOT
BELIEVE AND ASSEMBLY THEY'RE
PAYING FOR OUT OF EVERY
PAYCHECK THEY ARE PAYING FOR
THESE BENEFITS. THEY CANNOT
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE BENEFITS
THAT THEY HAVE EARNED. IF THEY
DON'T HAVE. AT THAT THE
INSURANCE THE INSURANCE THAT
THEIR JOB WILL BE WAITING FOR
THEM WHEN THEY COME BACK. FROM
TAKING THE EXTENSION LEAD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR A
NUMBER JENNIFER JENNIFER GOING
AHEAD ONE IN A- YEAH THANK YOU-
SO A COUPLE OF POINTS IN
RESPONSE TO THAT- BUT WAS JUST
THAT THEY ARE THERE THE
SUGGESTION IS THAT WITH THE
PART OF AN EXISTING FRAMEWORK
WITHIN THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT. AND THAT IS TRUE
BUT IT IS NOT AN EXISTING REPO
MANDATE ON SMALL EMPLOYERS SO
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
ACT DOESN'T CONTAIN A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION BUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE IS EXPANDING A
TWELVE WEEK MANDATORY LEAVE OF
ABSENCE ON FROM PLAYERS WHO
HAVE NEVER IMPLEMENTED BEFORE.
AND AGAIN THERE FORTY PAGES OF
REGULATIONS ON HOW TO IMPLEMENT
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHT
BACK SO IT IS A NEW BEAT FOR
THOSE EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE NEVER
DEALT WITH IT AND IT IS A NEW
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION THAT
THEY'VE NEVER HAD TO DEAL WITH.
ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDY. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOW THEY- WHAT DID YOU HAVE
TO GO OUT. MANY RECORD YOU CAN
LITERALLY. ON HE DID THE AT THE
AGE WEBSITE. THE LATTER
COMPLAINT AND REQUEST AN
IMMEDIATE RIGHT WITH YOU. AND
THAT GIVES YOU THE TICKET
BASICALLY TO GO STRAIGHT TO
DOUBLE COURT. DOING THAT
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS TAKES
APPROXIMATELY ONE MINUTE THE
COMPLETE IT IS NOT A NET THIRTY
TERMS OR AT KIND INTENSIVE
REQUIREMENT IT TAKE THE COCKNEY
ONE MINUTE. ONCE YOU HAVE THAT
IMMEDIATE RIGHT. YOU THERE IS
NO FURTHER EIGHT INVESTIGATION
THERE IS NO FURTHER MEDIATION
AND AT THAT RECORDED EARLIER.
THE DATA SHOWS. THAT OUT OF ALL
THE COMPLAINTS FILED OVER HALF.
OF THE COMPLAINT WITH THE AT
THE AGE. THE CURTAIN REQUEST AN
IMMEDIATE RIGHT THAT.
LITIGATION BUT THE MEDIATION
PROGRAM THAT WOULD THREATEN.
NEVER UTILIZED IF YOU REQUEST
THAT IMMEDIATE RIGHT WITH YOU
THE THREE TO COURT. THE OTHER-
COMMENT THAT WAS MADE. IS THAT.
THERE CAN BE NO DOUBT CAPTION
WITHOUT LITIGATION. JUST THAT'S
JUST NOT TRUE I MEAN THAT. THE
POINT IS THAT YOU CAN AND THE
THAT. THEIR JOB. IMPORTANT
THING THAT EMPLOYER WILL NOT
FOLLOW THE LAW AND WHAT YOUR
THREATEN THE A LOT AND I'M SURE.
I CAN COME UP NOT OFF THE TOP
MY HEAD RIGHT NOW. BUT WITH A
TON OF UP. A COULDN'T SECTIONS
AND LOTS THAT DON'T HAVE A
RIGHT ACTION AND THE LESS WE
HAVE. LEGAL COMPLY BY THE END
CAN BE BECAUSE THEY FOLLOW WITH
A LOT. WHAT WE DON'T NEED AT
THE- BUT IT. EVERYTHING WILL
KIND OF THE STATE IS MADE AND
IT IS NOT ACCURATE THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE A LOT. OF THE
EMPLOYEES RETURN TO WORK THAT'S
NOT THE BASIS FOR THE LOT. THE
LOCKET IS WHETHER OR NOT YOU
WANT IT IF YOU AT. NIGHT IN A
RAPID DISCOURAGED OR INTERFERED
WITH THE RIGHT TO TAKE THE LEAD
AND NOT THAT THE FIGHT THE
LACKEY THAT HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH WHETHER OR NOT YOU BRING
THE EMPLOYEE BACK. THE OTHER
POINT WAS THAT LOW WAGE WORKERS
ARE INTERESTING ALLEGATIONS AND
WHY DO YOU NEED A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION. IF LOW WAGE WORKERS
ARE NOT GOING TO GO FILE A LOT.
THE AGENT. YOU HAVE TO. AT FOR
THE LOW WHICH WERE MAKING GO TO
THE OF EMPLOYMENT IN THE AGENCY
CHARGED IMPORTING THAT CAN HELP
THEM IF THEY NEED TO GO THROUGH
THE- AND THEY CAN FILE PROTECT
THE EMPLOYEE THERE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION IN ORDER TO HAVE DROPPED
PROTECTION. OKAY THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER PAUL QUESTION COMMA THE
SOME. ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBER WELL YES ACTUALLY YES. I
JUST TO AGAIN JUST TO CLARIFY
SENATOR JACKSON THIS WILL TAKE
IT. IF WE CONTINUE HAVING THE
CONVERSATION WHICH I'M SURE
YOU'RE VERY OPEN TO. THIS IS
NOW CHANGING IT SO THAT IT'S
SOME. FROM FIFTY EMPLOYEES TWO
FIVE EMPLOYEES WHICH IS WHERE
THE SMALL BUSINESSES COME INTO
PLAY WHICH IS MY BIGGEST
CONCERN WHICH I'M SURE AND
WHICH IS WHAT MR FLORA HAS ALSO
EXPRESSED THIS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CONCERNS. I THINK
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO GET TO WHERE YOU WOULD LIKE
TO BE ON THIS BILL- AND- THIS
IS NOT A OF POSITION THAT I
OFTEN FIND MYSELF AND BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN AGREE WITH A LOT OF
THE ADVOCATES FOR SUPPORTING.
THIS BILL. MY CONCERN IS THAT.
THE SMALL BUSINESSES ALSO
EMPLOY THE VERY PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY AND IF WE- AT THE
CONTINUED REGULATIONS ON SMALL
BUSINESSES JUST MAKE IT HARDER
FOR PEOPLE TO GET JOBS. EVEN
THOUGH I UNDERSTAND. I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THAT THE
GOAL OF WHAT IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE
ESPECIALLY. IN EXPANDING THE
DEFINITION OF FAMILY ACROSS THE
STATE. I'M JUST I'M HOPING THAT
YOU'LL- TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHAT
HAS BEEN SAID. IN TERMS OF. THE
STRESSES AND LACK OF RESOURCES
TOWARD SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN IN THIS POSITION
BEFORE. I'M GOING T HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH A SMALL
BUSINESS COUNCIL MOST OF WHOM
ARE RESTAURANTS IN MY COMMUNITY
AND THEY'RE GOING TO ASK ME
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO PROTECT
US. AND I'M NOT SURE I HAVE
THAT ANSWER. WELL I DON'T THINK
THIS IS AN EITHER OR I DON'T
THINK THIS IS A ISSUE OF NOT
PROTECTING BUSINESSES WE'VE HAD
THE- PREGNANCY DISABILITY LAW
IN EFFECT FOR. MANY MANY YEARS
AND IT ARE ALL CALLS FOR AN
EMPLOYER OF FIVE OR MORE TO
PROVIDE THAT PREGNANCY
DISABILITY LEAVE SO THIS ISN'T
REALLY A STARTING NEW WHAT THIS
IS DOING IS THE SAME WAY WE ARE
WITH EXPANDING DEFINITION
FAMILY. CREATING WITHIN AN
EXISTING FRAMEWORK SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL CRITERIA WHICH WE
NEED TO REFLECT THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY IT WITH IN WHICH
WE LIVE YOU MENTION
INTERGENERATIONAL ALIKI YOU
WERE CARE GIVER. OF YOUR
GRANDMOTHER. WITH THE SECOND
LARGEST INTERGENERATIONAL
STATE. IN THE COUNTRY AND YET
THE DEFINITIONS THAT WE USE
DON'T REFLECT THE FACT THAT WE
CARE FOR GRAND KIDS AND
HOPEFULLY OUR GRAND KIDS OF
CARE FOR US WHEN WE'RE IN OUR
DOTAGE- AND THAT'S WHAT
CALIFORNIA IS. SO I THINK THE
FACT THAT THAT THAT THIS IS NOT
A WHOLE NEW SYSTEM WERE
CREATING. WE'VE DONE THIS WITH
OUR PREGNANCY DISABILITY- AND
THE YOU KNOW THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IS
KIND OF LIKE A- A RED FLAG THAT
GETS THE FLOWN. BECAUSE I THINK
BUSINESSES. IF YOU KNOW THEY
THEY THEY DON'T LIKE THE NOTION
THAT THEY COULD BE SUED IF THEY
DO NOT DO WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED.
THIS IS PART OF AN AND-
MECHANISM AND I HAVE ALL THE
RESPECT IN THE WORLD FROM HIS
BARRERA WE HAVE WORKED TOGETHER
AND WE'VE BEEN ADVERSARIES FOR
QUITE SOME TIME AS WELL. THE
FACT IS THAT YOU HAVE TO GO TO
DE FE H. YOU HAVE TO GO AND YOU
HAVE TO. WHAT DO YOU
IMMEDIATELY CHICA OR RIGHT TO
SHOW ORDER. THAT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU YOU ARE GOING TO SHOOT.
BECAUSE IN ORDER LAWSUITS
REQUIRE THAT YOU HAVE DAMAGES
THERE ARE SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE.
THAT ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO RECOVER
FEES AND COSTS. IF SOMEONE
FILES A FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT ON.
AND YOU KNOW YOU TALK ABOUT THE
PEOPLE IN YOUR COMMUNITY. I'M
YOUR PEOPLE THAT'S WHAT CHAU
AND THEY WERE GET PAID FAIR.
AND THEY WANT THE WORKING
CONDITION TO BE TECH OF THEM.
AND THEY WERE. PART OF WORKING
FACE. THE JUDGE TO THAT MOST OF
THOSE. YOU ABOUT IN YOUR-
COMMUNITY FEEL THE SAME WAY
ABOUT EMPLOYEES. THERE ARE
FAMILY. AND THE AND THEY HAVE
TO BE IN ORDER FOR BUSINESS TO
BE SUCCESSFUL AND I SUSPECT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLOOR WOULD GET
WOULD AGREE. IF YOU TAKE GOOD
CARE OF YOUR EMPLOYEES THEY'LL
TAKE GOOD CARE YOU. AND THAT'S
WHAT TALKING ABOUT HERE WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT CREATING.
GENERAL WILD ALLEGATIONS
BETWEEN PEOPLE IT'S JUST THAT
YOU KNOW I'M SICK MIKE FOR
EXAMPLE MY GRANDMOTHER I GOT TO
TAKE CARE OF MY GRANDMOTHER AND
EMPLOYERS GONNA SHADY YOU LET'S
WORK TOGETER WILL LET WILL
MAKE IT HAPPEN. AND INSTEAD
THIS IS FOR- SIMPLER SWITCHED
SORRY CHARLIE BUT IF YOU IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE THAT LEAP THAT YOU
PAY FOR YOU'RE GOING TO BE FOR.
AND REALLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT HERE SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERN HAPPY TO TALK WITH YOU
FURTHER ABOUT THIS BUT- OF MY
**** IS A WE STAY FOCUSED ON
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. AND THE
FACT THAT SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
HAVING PROBLEMS NOW IS THE IN
NOT IN DISPUTE. NOT IN DISPUTE
AT ALL BUT MIGHT MARK WHAT I AM
SUGGESTING IS THAT ALLOWING
YOUR EMPLOYEES. IF AND WHEN
THEY GET SICK NOT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE WORKING BUT IF
THEY ARE SICK OR A LOVED ONE IS
SICK OR THEY HAVE A NEW BORN.
THAT THEY WANT TO BOND WITH
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE
THAT TIME. AND THERE ARE FIVE
OTHER STATES BY THE WAY THEY DO
THIS ACTUALLY THE GO DOWN TO
ONE OR MORE EMPLOYEE- NEW YORK-
OF RHODE ISLAND I BELIEVE LET'S
SEE NEW YORK RIGHT AYE THAT
COULD. HAVE THE RIGHTS OF ONE
POINT. ARMED SEVERAL MAJOR MAIN
STAGE YOU KNOW BIG STATE. DOING
IT AND I'M NOT SURE. TO GO
SERVICE THAT THE OTHER THING
THAT BUSINESSES ARE NOT. AWFUL
FAILING BECAUSE- THERE IS
FAMILY LEAVE. ARE BECAUSE WE
ARE PROVIDING THIS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO SEEK REDRESS.
THE SAME THING HAPPEN AGAIN I
MENTIONED EARLIER WITH NEW
CURRENTLY THE WORLD WAS GOING
TO FALL LAWSUIT YOU'RE GOING TO
BE THOUSANDS A LAWSUIT. THAT
HASN'T HAPPENED. SUBMIT TO YOU
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR BUSINESSES
TO CHANGE THE WAY THINGS ARE IS
REALLY MORE- REFLECTIVE OF WHAT
ONCE WAS AND I SUBMIT THAT WE
CAN. MAKE THESE CHANGES AND THE
BUSINESSES WILL CONTINUE TO
FLOURISH AND TO THRIVE AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS THESE STUDIES
BY THE WAY. THE START IT WAS
DONE BY THE BAY AREA COUNCIL.
DIDN'T REALLY PRODUCE ANYTHING
KNOW WHICH HOUSE WAS CUT IT%
CONFIRMED STUDIES THAT HAVE
BEEN GOING ON FOR YOU THERE'S
ABOUT BENEFIT TO PAID. WEEKLY
AND THE BENEFITS OF HAVING JOB
PROTECTION TO GO WITH THAT
LEAVE. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS. SO THE- BILL IT'S A
CHALLENGING TIME BUT I SUBMIT
TO THE BUSINESS ARE CA OF
FAILED. EMPLOYEE WHO ARE SICK
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
THAT TIME OFF. BUSINESSES ARE
GOING TO FAIL BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
IT LICKED THIS PROBLEM THAT
WE'VE GOT AND WE'VE GOT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT BUSINESSES ARE
FAMILIES. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL CALLS FOR AND WITH THAT. I
WOULD PASS THROUGH YOUR CABLE
SUMMARY JONES SAWYER AND
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE A LOT.
SHORTER BOB IT'S UP WENT UP
WHEN I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
INVOLVEMENT IN GET THIS MOVING
ON SO WE CAN CONTINUE UP THE
DISCUSSION AT AND DIVE DEEPER
INTO THIS I THOUGHT IT JUST TWO
THINGS I WOULD LIKE WHAT IS ONE
THING I LIKE YOU YOU TO DO AND
THERE'S ONE THING THAT I WOULD
DO IT I'M JUST GONNA LET YOU
KNOW UP FRONT BOB ON THE KEEP
YOUR TWELVE WEEK TO TWENTY FOUR
WE THERE'S GOT TO BE. THE IS
THE LANGUAGE. IN THE TO BE
TWEAKED STILL WE HAVE CLARITY
LET'S. LET'S AT LEAST GET THAT-
THAT'S THAT'S ALWAYS REALLY
FRUSTRATING FOR ME WHEN ONCE I
SAID THAT THIS ONE AND I. WE
ALL. WE ALL CAN WRITE SOMETHING
THAT. VERY CLEAR SAID WE
UNDERSTAND IT. IT'S TWELVE. AND
NOT TWENTY FOUR- THAT HAS A-
AND THEN ON THE SMALL BUSINESS.
ASPECT MY SMALL BUSINESS MAY BE
UNIQUE AS- MY COLLEAGUE TO THE
NORTH AND SO WHY WE MAY BE
TALKING BRICK AND MORTAR BOB I
HAVE A LOT OF BUSINESSES THAT
ARE ABLE TO BUY CARS IN YOUR
KIDS TO COLLEGES AND THEY ARE
ON THE DISTRIBUTOR. AND I DON'T
AWARE DATE INTO THAT AND SO I
WILL BE I ALSO DIDN'T SEE MY
CHAMBERS. ON EITHER SIDE OF
THIS DISCUSSION AND SO I WILL
BY THE DISRUPTING I WILL DO I
WILL PERSONALLY HAVE DISCUSSION
WITH MY CHAMBERS ON THE IMPACTS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES. AND HOW
THIS LEGISLATION WILL IMPACT
THEM. I'M I THINK MANY OF THEM
ESPECIALLY THE SIDEWALK WITH
VENDORS. MAY NOT EVEN FALL INTO
THIS THIS MAY BE. FIVE THEY DID
NOT FIGHT THEY MAY BE FOUR
THREE. BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
THAT. THEY WOULD BE IMPACTED BY
THIS BUT IF THEY ARE AT A FULL
HEAD OF- BY PERSON LEVEL SUPER
SEVEN. I WORK WE'RE GOING TO MY
STAFF AND ARE GOING TO GO OUT
PERSONALLY ASK. HOW DO YOU
HANDLE THIS MADNESS AT LEAST
TALK ABOUT YOUR BILL BUT HOW DO
YOU HANDLE THIS- AND I KNOW
IT'S NOT THE MOST RIGHT PICK
WAY. OF DOING THINGS BUT AT
LEAST GET SENSE OF THIS BILL
WILL IMPACT THE SMOG THIS IS.
ACTUALLY MY DISTRICT AND
TALKING TO INDIVIDUALS- WILL
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS AND MAY
HAVE THE STAFF. IS A LOT
CONTINUE THAT WERE DISCUSSED.
BUT EAST. BUT I GET TO LEAVE IT
THERE SAY. THE NAME. THEY CAN
BRING PEOPLE IN AND OUT THE AND
IN THE PERSONAGE THAT. THEY'RE
NOT THERE PERMANENTLY AND
INOTES IT. AT LEAST FIGURE OUT
COULD PEOPLE DO GET SICK AND I
THINK MOST OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES I DISTRICT MAKE
ALLOWANCES FOR THAT NAY DIG
INTO IT WITH A FIGURE THAT OUT.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE AND
OBVIOUSLY TALKING TO CHAMBERS
OF MY DISTRICT AND GET A SENSE
OF THAT. AND THEN WE'RE WE'VE
BEEN GOING. DOING COLD IT.
RELATED THINGS WITH THE
BUSINESSES IN MY DISTRICT AND
WE HAVE SEVERAL ALLIES THAT WE
COULD TALK TO. TO GET A SENSE
OF THAT AND SO ON AND IN OUR
REPORT THAT BACK TO YOU. AND
THEN YOU CAN. YOU CAN DECIDE
HOW WE CAN PROCEED. I WOULD
LIKE TO IF I MAY IN RESPONSE
FOR THAT IS A CLOSE- ORIGINALLY
THIS MEASURE CALL FOR ONE OR
EMPLOYEE. AND THAT THAT CREATED
A LOT HANGS. SO IT'S SO WE
MOVED TO FIVE FOR MORE. AS I
MENTIONED THERE ARE NUMBER OF
OTHER STATES THAT ARE DOING
THIS. I ALSO WANT TO BE REALLY
CLEAR. THAT WHEN AN EMPLOYEE
GOES OFF ON THIS. JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE FOR TWELVE WEEKS. IT IS
ON PAGE. SO AS THE EMPLOYER.
AND YOUR SMALL RESTAURANT. IN
IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
SISTER YOU'VE NOW GOT THAT
SALARY. THAT YOU CAN THEN
OFFERED TO SHOP IN THE COMING
TO WORK PART TO WORK A
TEMPORARILY WHILE THAT OTHER
EMPLOYEES SOFT. AND IF YOU HAVE
A IF YOU KNOW MOST RESTAURANTS
THEY CAN'T REALLY DO A LOT WHEN
IT COMES TO BENEFITS. BUT IF
YOU ARE WITH YOUR FULL TIME.
HERS AND YOU'RE PAYING BENEFITS
YOU BRING IN A YOU BRING IN
SOMEONE WHO IS- TEMPORARY YOU
DON'T HAVE TO PAY THOSE
BENEFITS EITHER. SO IF YOU
CHOOSE TO BRING SOMEONE IN TO
FILL THAT OTHER PERSON SPOT
YOU'RE NOT PAYING TWICE. AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
RECOGNIZE YOU'RE NOT PAYING FOR
THE EMPLOYEE WHO IS OUT ON THAT
LEAVES. ITS JOB PROTECTED WHICH
ON PAID THE ONLY PAYMENT THAT
THE EMPLOYEE GETS IS FROM THAT.
PAID FAMILY LEAVE THAT THEY
PAID INTO THEMSELVES. SO THAT'S
SOMETHING I THINK THAT'S REAL
IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES TO
SMALL EMPLOYERS THEY'RE OT
PAYING DOUBLE IN FACT THEY'RE
NOT PAYING IT ALL AND WHAT
HAPPENS IS IN THE REASON THAT.
THE DATA SHOWS THAT COMPANIES
ACTUALLY CAN FINANCIALLY
BENEFIT DURING THAT. TIME IS
BECAUSE THEY CAN SAVE THAT
MONEY IN ONLY 19% OF COMPANIES.
WILL GO OUT AND HIRE A
REPLACEMENT THEY FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MAKE IT WORK YOU KNOW MAYBE
YOU GOT TO WORK A COUPLE EXTRA
HOURS. THAT'S THE SIX ABILITY
WE SEE SOME BUSINESSES SO I'D
BE VERY INTERESTED. AS LONG AS
WE'RE CLEAR ON WHAT THE BILL
DOES AND DOESN'T DO. RAN I
THINK THAT THAT IS THE PART OF
PART OF. OUR CHALLENGES I MAY
BE TALKING ABOUT BUSINESSES.
THAT MAY NOT SHOW UP AND
SURVEYS. BECAUSE THEY'RE
IMMIGRANT POPULATION AND THEY
DO NOT. SELF REPORT A REPORT A
LOT OF THINGS AND SO. THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL IN THEIR SURVEY
AND I'M FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHAT GOES ON IN BAY
AREA MAY NOT BE APROPOS WHAT'S
GOING ON IN OUR DISTRICT AND SO
I. JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE
REVIEWING APPLES TO APPLES
RIGHT AND SO THAT I. DEBT THAT
I TAKE CARE PEOPLE OF MY
DISTRICT AND A TICKET IN RAT
POPULATION MY DISTRICT BECAUSE
OF THE REPORTS I GOT. ABOUT
SMALL BUSINESSES. IT THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO THEY'RE GOING
TO SUFFER BECAUSE THE CALL OF
IT YEAH. MAYBE AT A RATE OF 50%
OF THE MAY CLOSE. IN MY
DISTRICT A MAY BE 60% OR MORE.
AND SO HOW DO I. HOW TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T FURTHER
EXACERBATE THAT BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE LARGEST EMPLOYER. EVEN
THOUGH MY ALMA MATER USC TRIES
TO CLAIM THAT THEY ARE. BY FAR
SMALL BUSINESSES- EMPLOYED MUCH
MORE MANY MORE PEOPLE- DAN DAN
DAN U. S. C. SO- I THINK
THERE'S A- THERE'S A PLACE I
THINK THIS THIS IS IMPORTANT WE
NEED TO DO THIS- WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE. IT DOES HAVE. A NECK
PACKED. INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY BE
KIND OF IN A BIT INVISIBLE. TO
THIS ALL THESE DATE IS A
STUDIES EVEN THOUGH DISRESPECT
MY COLLEAGUE OVER OVER HERE-
MISTER FORD IT IT IT MAY NOT.
IT MAY NOT FALL IN THAT
CATEGORY THESE BUSINESSES THAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT THAT. DEBT OF
ISRAEL'S TALKING ABOUT THIS
MADE GROUP THAT FALLS TO THE
CRACKS AND THEN WE DON'T WANT
THIS BILL. TO DRIVE. DRY
FURTHER. CAN AND I THAT IN WITH
CERTAIN LOOK AT AT A LOT OF
THESE ARE PROBABLY BUSINESS
THAT ONE OR TWO EMPLOYEES BUT
IF THE BUT AGAIN EIGHT IT I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE REAL CLEAR
THAT THERE IS NO FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON THE SMALL BUSINESSES.
THEY'RE NOT BEING THEM AT THEIR
NOT BEING ASKED TO PAY FOR THAT
PERSON'S LEAVE. FACT THEY DON'T
PAY AT ALL SO I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION AND I'D
LOVE ACTUALLY I'D LOVE TO COME
DOWN AND THE TAKE A WALK
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE
RESTAURANTS BECAUSE I'M ALWAYS
UP FOR A GOOD MEAL. AND HAND
WITH A ONE. ENDLESS SO EXPLAIN
MORE BUT YOU KNOW LISTEN. I
GUESS I HEAR. SO THAT THIS THIS
BILL IS SOMETHING THOSE STUDIES
HAVE BEEN DONE THEY'VE BEEN
DOING SIMILAR STUDIES FOR
DECADES THERE THAT THAT THIS
THESE MOST RECENT ONE SIMPLY
CONFIRM. PRIOR STUDY SO THIS IS
NOT NEW INFORMATION- AND DIE I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION. YOU
KNOW CHANGES HARD- BUT I THINK
WHAT WHAT ARE WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER IS THAT THE CHANGE
ALREADY OCCURRED WHICH IS. KIND
OF PUT INTO PLACE. THOSE
GUIDELINES THAT WILL REFLECT
THE CHANGING WORLD IN WHICH WE
LIVE AND WITH THAT I WOULD
ACTUALLY LIKE. THE SENATE A
WANTED TO YOUR POINT ON AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. THIS DOESN'T.
DESERVE INVOLVED IN AN IN DEPTH
CONVERSATION AT THE COMMITTEE
LEVEL SO. I HAVE NO PROBLEM
WITH THE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
FOLKS TAKE BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT- AND THE- POINT OF
STUDIES I DON'T KNOW WE DO
HAVE. UP ANY WITH THIS. STORY.
TO ON THE PHONE. I'M A IF. BUT
SHE IS IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT
ON THE BAY AREA COUNCIL STUDY
TO SEE THERE'S A PROCESS THERE.
LET'S NOT BE CAN MOVE ON FROM
THAT. YEAH THE PMR OPINION WITH
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY I'M
HAPPY TO COMMENT ON FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE ARE NOT MEMBERSHIP
OF AN ORGANIZATION AS MENTIONED
EARLIER- AND WE DO THAT SO THAT
WE CAN BE AS INCLUSIVE AS
POSSIBLE AS WE ARE SERVING VERY
SMALL MICHAEL BUSINESS OWNERS
THERE ARE RESEARCH ADVOCATES IN
EDUCATION WORK. ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IN
SEVERAL OTHER STATE. ON THE
SECOND ON THE RESEARCH. BUT
DURING THAT COALITION AND EIGHT.
WHICH GET DIRECTLY AFTER
QUESTION AROUND SHOP
PROTECTIVELY. CALIFORNIA WHICH
FOCUSED ON TWO DIFFERENT
QUESTION ONE QUESTION WAS
AROUND THE PORT OR OPPOSITION
FINDING STOP PROTECTED LEAVE
WHEN INVESTMENT HAS MORE THAN
ONE. AT LEAST. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS LIKE AROUND. A GREEN
UP HOW OR SUPPORT A DROP
PROTECTED AMENDMENT THAT WAY
OUR DOCTOR. I BRING THAT NUMBER
DOWN TO FIVE ANNIE BOTH T.
FIFTY PERCENT- THERE WITH OVER
50% OF SUPPORT BURKE. REDUCTION
IF THAT AND THEN IT. WE FIGHT
EMPLOYEES THAT'S SUPPORT WITH
57% AND IN THE CASE WHERE. YOU
EVER ACTUALLY. BACK WAYS AT 59%
OF TOTAL SUPPORT AND THEN IN
TURN- ECONOMIC STUDY THAT WITH
COOK. AND I'M ALSO HAPPY TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE TOP
TWENTY EIGHT. HE. QUITE BUT
WHEN EIGHT THE COMMISSION ALSO
BROUGH THE FAN UNIVERSITY- JOE
NATION WHO REPRESENT UNIVERSITY
AND OTHER PHD WHO WERE ABLE TO
FIND AT THE FINDINGS THAT I HAD
MENTIONED EARLIER. ALL REFLECT
FIRM AND- THERE IS NO INCREASE
OUR- EIGHT NINE EIGHT WE ARE IN.
WE FELL IN. THAT OKAY THANK YOU
NO I THINK FOR THE PER OF
GETTING A LOT OF GOOD
PERSPECTIVES OF FROM ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM OF THAT THIS EVENING
AND I THINK- IT'S APPROPRIATE
SO PROBABLY SO AND I'LL SAY
THAT LOOKING OTHER THERE'S NO
OTHER COUNTRIES OF THEM AS PAID
FAMILY BY A PLAYER SIZE
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ONLY FALLING
BEHIND THE REST WILL BE NOW
FIVE OTHER STATES. HAVE PASSED
TO A PEAK I MEAN THE LAW TO
PROTECT THE JOBS OF ALL WORKERS
BECAUSE ONE PLAYER SIDE SIZE
40% OF CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS DO
NOT QUALIFY FOR JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE UNDER THE CURRENT STRICT
STANDARDS OF THESE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW WAGE
WORKERS OF COLOR WHO ARE OFTEN
MORE VULNERABLE OF YOU SEE IN
TO COVERED- BECAUSE OF PRE
EXISTING SYSTEM SYSTEMATIC
BARRIERS TO HEALTHCARE. THESE
BECAUSE OF THE JEWS AND GOING
TO WORK ON LOSING THEIR JOB.
KEEP UP A LOT OF WORKERS AND
FOR PER A BLOCK OR ARE EMPLOYED
IN FRONT MY ESSENTIALS. A ARE
OVER REPRESENTED IN MANY
FRONTLINE ESSENTIAL INDUSTRIES.
MAKING 90% OF FRMWORKERS 70%
OF THE SOCIAL WORKERS. 15% A
COOKS AND SIXTY FOUR PERCENT.
OF PREPARES. BUT CAN I GET A
COMMUNITIES FACE OF STANGEL
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS ADEQUATE
HEALTHCARE. BEFORE COVER
NINETEEN AND NOW PARTICULARLY
ARE VULNERABLE. AS WE'VE SEEN
OF THE EXPOSURE AT WORK. OF MY
DISTRICT ALTHOUGH SILICON
VALLEY MY DISTRICTS A 50% PLUS
LATINO. WE HAVE THE POOREST.
ZIP CODES AND CENSUS TRACTS IN
THE IN THE BAY AREA. THE
HIGHEST RATE ABOVE IT SO I WANT
TO. DISPEL THE MYTH THAT
EVERYBODY IN THE BAY AREA IS
RICH AND IS DOING JUST OKAY.
DOING FINE. IT'S NOT THE CASE
AND I HAVE A LOT OF WORKERS MY
DISTRICT THAT. BECAUSE
CERTAINLY TELL YOU OTHERWISE SB.
THIRTEEN PARTICULARLY AND- I'D
ARE UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS PAID
FAMILY LEAVE IS AVAILABLE. TO
ALL WORKERS BECAUSE IMMIGRATION
STATUS BECAUSE THEY ALL INTO IT.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE THINGS LIKE
SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE THAT
HAVE PAID FAMILY LEAVE HUNDRED
PERCENT. FOR LONGER PERIODS OF
TIME AND HOW THEY'RE DEALING
WITH THIS PANDEMIC LET ALONE.
EVEN OUTSIDE OF A PANDEMIC
ENVIRONMENT HOW WELL THEIR
FAMILIES ARE TAKEN CARE OF HOW
THEIR FAMILY CENTERED. AND
REALLY WHO'S IN THE BEST
POSITION TO ABSORB PAIN. AND I
THINK THAT WE COULD HOPEFULLY
AGREED TO WORKERS IN THE IN THE
LEAST BENEFICIAL POSITION TO
ABSORB THAT PAN. SMALL
BUSINESSES WOULD BE. TO THE
NEXT LEVEL UP WHERE WE HAVE TO
DO WE CAN TO PROTECT THEM AND
SUPPORT THEM BUT AS- THE
SENATOR SAID THIS IS UNPAID
LEAVE. IT'S PAID BY US WE PAY
INTO IT. BUT THE WORKERS UNPAID
SO THEY DO HAVE TO MANAGE THE
TIME WHETHER SIX WEEKS EIGHT
pTO MANAGE OPERATIONS DURING
THAT TIME. AND THAT'S AND
THAT'S VERY LOW BUT THEY CAN
USE THAT SAME MONEY THEY WOULD
PAY TO BRING IN SOME
TEMPORARILY OR- FIGURE A MAN
WITH THE WORKFORCE IF THEY HAVE.
BUT THAT WERE TO A WORKER
BASICALLY YOU GET SICK YOU HAVE
TO TAKE CARE OF A LOVED ONE
YOU'RE OUT OF A JOB AND THEY'RE
JUST UPON IT IN HIS MACHINERY.
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY A JOBS
UBER BECAUSE IT SAVES THAT
INDIVIDUAL THEIR JOB. AND IT'S
SOMEONE THAT THE EMPLOYER
ALREADY LIKES AND HAS ON THEIR
SPOUSE OR NOT TIME TO HIRE
SOMEONE. THEY DON'T WANNA HAVE
WORKING FOR THEM IT'S IN SO
IT'S GOOD PUBLIC POLICY FOR A
SOCIAL CONTRACT. THAT ACTUALLY
SUPPORTS FAMILIES. AND IT
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S EASY. UP
PLAYING CATCH UP. WITH THE REST
OF THE WORLD. IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING AND CARE OUR
FAMILIES ISN'T EASY AND I THINK
WE DO HAVE TO RECKON. GROWING
SPECIAL SMALL BUSINESSES AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD. YOU HARD THINGS
TO. AND I KNOW EVERYONE THAT'S
ON THIS COMMITTEE IS UP TO THE
TASK- AS AS I'M A CERTAINLY THE
AUTHOR CENTER. JACKSON IS AND
SO- WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM
SOME NUMBER GONZALEZ SECONDED
BY AS A MEMBER RIVAS. A
SERGEANTS AT CENTER JACKSON
WHICH IS TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS NO I CHOSE TO. OTHER
THAN TO SAY THIS IS NOT AN EASY
CHOICE. QUESTION ABOUT BUT I.
YOU THAT WHEN IT COMES. SMALL
BUSINESS THIS IS NOT. AT AND
WEIGHING THE AND BASS. PEOPLE
SOMEONE BEING SENT NEEDS AND
WEARING BUSINESSES. ARE THE
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE KIND OF
SHOW. FROM THIS BECAUSE ANY.
LOSS I THINK OF THE DATA DE
SHOW THAT CA. CHECK DO. WHEN
THOSE EMPLOYEE COME BACK. THEY
ARE THE THEY'RE LOYAL. THEY PRE.
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY HAD
TO DO OTHER THINGS ON THEIR-
OTHER THAN CHEST BE EMPLOY.
IT'S A WIN WIN. AND SO WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I CALLED. THANK YOU.
LISTENING TO ME TO FOR ON THE
ON SB THIRTY EIGHT. MOTION IS
TO PROBE. KALRA FIVE KALRA FIVE.
FLORA NO CARILLO. CAREER I DO.
CAN JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
FIVE WAS THREE WAS RIVERSIDE.
RIGHT SO THE BILL IS OUT
SENATOR MAY THAT'LL THE LAST
YOU MAY PRESS IN PRINT THIS.
WELL I THANK YOU FOR YOUR MANY
YEARS SERVICE IT'S NOT OVER YET
BUT IN TERMS OF BEING FROM
COMMITTEE IT MAY BE SO THANK
YOU WELL IT'S BEEN PLEASURE I
CAN THE- YEAH THE HOPEFULLY WE
WILL GO ON ENOUGH AND ALL THE
AND PROUD THE WORK WE DO THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU YOU. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE SIR
MONICA. YOU GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
EVENING. YES OVER A HAVE A BILL
NOT FOLLOW EIGHT AND MONEY ARE
TOO FOR BILLS FOR THIS YOU IS A
THANKS PAY I HOPE YOU'RE THE
AND OF COMMERCE ON ON A PRETTY
INVOLVED THAT WE JUST HAD BUT
ALSO HAVE A BILL BEING BROUGHT
TO US RIGHT NOW IS BE A OF SO.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR MONEY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
WELL YEAR SLIGHTLY MORE TWENTY
THREE. FOUR FARM. WERE IMPORT
BY ROUGH ONE HUNDRED K. GROWERS.
IN FARM LABOR CON. ON THE
FEDERAL TO VISA PROBE. THIS
NUMBER HAS IN. IN EACH YEAR FOR
THOSE WHO YOU UNFAMILIAR THE H.
TO A PROGRAM IT HAS MANY OF THE
SAME PROVISIONS AND PROBLEMS
THAT THE EMPHASIS INFAMOUS
BRACERO PROGRAM HAD. THE H. TO
A FARM WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE LARGELY RECRUITED IN MEXICO
ARE TIED TO A SINGLE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYER WHO MUST PROVIDE THEM
WITH HOUSING MEALS AND
TRANSPORTATION TO WORK SITES.
MANY H. TO A WORKERS HAVE NEVER
BEEN TO CALIFORNIA BEFORE AND
ARE BELIEVED TO NEITHER SPEAK
NOR READ ENGLISH. IF THEY ARE
FIRED FOR ANY REASON THEY'RE
SUBJECT TO IMMEDIATE
DEPORTATION WHICH IS A POWERFUL
DISINCENTIVE TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
ANY ABUSE OF WORKPLACE
CONDITIONS THAT THEY MAY BE
SUBJECTED TO. THE COMMITTEE HAS
PROVIDED EVIDENCE OF CURRENT
ABUSES IN THIS PROGRAM. MANY OF
THESE ABUSES ARE ALSO
VIOLATIONS OF CALIFORNIA LAWS
WHICH H. TO A FARMWORKERS
GENERALLY KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
BECAUSE NEITHER THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. NOR THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT GOOD MINISTER THE
PROGRAM REQUIRE WORKERS TO BE
TOLD OF THIS IS FINANCIAL BODY
OF CALIFORNIA LAWS THAT PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS GREATER THAN THE
FEDERAL H. TO A PROGRAM. IN THE
LAW IS CLEAR IF YOU'RE WORKING
IN CALIFORNIA YOU'RE PROTECTED
BY CALIFORNIA LAWS AS WELL AS
THE FEDERAL. SB ELEVEN OH TWO
BILLS THAT IN GAP BY REQUIRING
H. TWIN TO PROVIDE EACH TO A
FARMWORKERS ON THEIR FIRST DAY
AT WORK WITH A SHORT
COMPREHENSIVE WRITTEN SUMMARY
OF KEY LABOR. HOUSING HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND OTHER CALIFORNIA
LAWS IN SPANISH AND IF
REQUESTED IN ENGLISH. THE BILL
DIRECTS THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
TO HELP THE TEMPLATE.
CONTAINING THIS SUMMARY AND THE-
THANK. T. USED TO. WITH THESE
NEW DISC OF. THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED ALONG WITH THE FEDERAL
NOTICE PROVISIONS. SB ELEVEN-
TO CREATE A SAFER LEGALLY
COMPLIANT WORKPLACE FOR H. TO A
FARMWORKERS AND REDUCES ANY
INCENTIVE UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS MAY HAVE TO HIRE
WORKERS WHOM THEY CAN UNDER PAY
WERE MYSTERY. BECAUSE THE
WORKERS DO NOT UNDERSTAND THEIR
RIGHTS OR HOW THEY MIGHT
ENFORCE THOSE RIGHTS. I WILL
HAVE WITH ME TODAY IT'S
WITNESSES. REMOTELY CYNTHIA
RICE AND MARK SHOCKED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE OTE.
AND THROUGH THE CHAIR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO BRING IN
OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANKS THANK YOU UP. THANK
YOU SARAH MINING AND- AS ALWAYS
EACH WITNESS WILL HAVE UP TO
TWO MINUTES AND- CYNTHIA RICE
FOLLOWED BY MARK SHOCKED. THANK
YOU MISTER CARE AFTERNOON NAME
IS CAN BE AWRY AND I'M WITH THE
CAL RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE. WE
PROVIDE LEGAL SERVICES TO RURAL
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
PROVIDING LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO
FARMWORKERS INCLUDING TO A
WORKERS. THE NUMBER OF A TO A
WORKER AND CAL HAS INCREASED AT
AN EXCEL RATE THANK ALL THE
NINETEEN. ONCE THOSE WORKERS
ARE AND CAL. THEIR EMPLOYERS
WHETHER WHERE THEY LIVE COULD A
RUMOR CAR. WHAT THEY- THEY ARE
TRYING TO BLACK OR VAN TO GET
ON IN THE MORNING AND OUR IN
THE FIELD UNTIL THERE ARE SPEND
THE- TO PICK THEM UP AT THE END
OF THE DAY. YEAH AGE A WORKERS
COME TO OUR OFFICES. BECAUSE
THERE. BEFORE THE DATE. COULD
STATED IN OUR COUNTRY. HOWEVER
IN NEARLY A CASE. THAT ISSUE IS
JUST ONE OF SEVERAL VIOLATE.
MOST OF WHICH THEY HAD. ALL
ABOUT AND ARE YOU NEED TO CAL.
ON. THESE INCLUDE ON. TIMES ON
A CONTROLLED. THE FAILURE TO
PAY TIME. THE NYLON ADDRESS
PERIOD. DEDUCTION TOOLS SAFETY.
THE LACK SHANE WATER AN NOT
COME WITH OTHER HEALTH AND
SAFETY. WHICH ARE COMMON PLACE
AND HOW. BUT NOT SO OTHER. AND
LAW UNKNOWN THESE WERE. AND
WITHOUT EVEN BEING ADVISED THAT
IT EXISTED. THESE WORKERS ARE
ROBBED OF HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO PAY
OVER THE TERM OF THEIR CONTRACT
AND OFTEN DON'T EVEN KNOW IT.
THIS BILL PROTECT TAKES TO WAY
WORKERS BYENSURING THAT THEY
KNOW THEY'RE RIGHT. IT ALSO
PROTECTS DOMESTIC WORKERS WHO
WORK ALONG SIGNED THEM AND
MIGHT BE HESITATE HESITANT TO
DEMAND THEIR RIGHTS BECAUSE
THEY FEAR THEY'LL BE REPLACED
BY ANOTHER H. TO A WORKER WHO
DOESN'T KNOW OUT AND THEREFORE
CANNOT MAKE SIMILAR DEMANDS.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
THE EXPANDED PROTECTIONS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS EXTENDED TO
WORKERS OVER THE LAST A HUNDRED
AND TEN YEARS ARE KNOWN TO. AN
ENFORCEABLE BY EVERY WORKER WHO
LABOR IN OUR FIELD. AND PUT
FOOD ON OUR TABLES. WE ASK FOR
YOUR EYEBALLS THANK THANK YOU.
HI MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MARK SHOCKED WITH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION THAT SPONSORED THE
BILL VERY SIMPLY AS THE SENATOR
AND MS RICE HAVE. HAVE
REFERENCED SB ELEVEN- TO PULL
TOGETHER INTO A SINGLE DOCUMENT
TO BE PROVIDED TO H. COOLEY
WITH FARMWORKERS AND SPANISH ON
THE FIRST DAY OF WORK
INFORMATION ABOUT SEVERAL DOZEN
CALIFORNIA LABOR HOUSING HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND OTHER LAWS THEY
NEED THAT THE US DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REQUIRED TO BE
DISCLOSED. ESSENTIALLY A
CAPTIVE WORKFORCE FOR EXAMPLE
NOTHING IN THE FEDERAL AGE TO A
CONTRACT GIVEN TO WORKERS BY
THE EMPLOYER. REQUIRES THIS
SPECIFIC STATE LAW INFORMATION
TO BE DISCLOSED AND I'LL JUST
TOUCH ON A FEW OF THE IMPORTANT
PROVISIONS. THAT ARE IN SB
ELEVEN OR TWO. WHERE AT. OR
STATE EMERGENCY OR DISASTER HAS
BEEN DECLARED IN THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTY WHERE THEY WORK. HOW TO
DETERMINE EVERY YEAR BETWEEN
NOW AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE
PROPER STAYS IN STATE OVERTIME
GREAT THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
RECEIVE EACH YEAR. OR THAT
THEIR TITLE COULD BE PAID A
RITE AID TO A WRECK A PAID REST
PERIODS TO PAY OF TEN MINUTES
FOR EACH FOUR HOURS WORK. IF
THEY MAY NOT BE CHARGED FOR
MEALS NOT TAKEN. TITLE TO
TRAVEL TIME CONVERSATION AT THE
REGULAR RATE OF PAY FOR TIME
SPENT WHILE BEING TRANSPORTED
BY THE EMPLOYER. FROM HIS
HOUSING TO WITH THE WORK SITE.
RIGHT THAT TENANTS WHILE
RESIDING IN THE EMPLOYERS
HOUSING AND CAN REALLY RECEIVED
GAS OF THEIR CHOOSING AND SHALL
NOT BE SUBJECTED TO UNANNOUNCED
SEARCHES OF THEIR HOMES. THAT
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO RECEIVE
TRAINING IN SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION AND HAVE REPORTED
THAT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT THE
TOILETS HAND WASHING FACILITIES
AND COOL POTABLE WATER AT EACH
WORKSITE. REPAIRED TITLE TO BE
TRAINED IN RECOGNIZING AND
PREVENTING DETAILED US DURING
HIGH KEEP WORK PERIOD. BETTER
FAIR EXPO TO PASS. THEY HAVE TO
BE PROMPTLY TRANSPORTED TO A
MEDICAL FACILITY THAT IF THEY
WORK BETWEEN SUNSET SUNRISE AND
SUNSET. THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
HEADLAMPS WERE AFFECTED
GARMENTS ARE TO BE PROVIDED
OTHER LIGHTING SAYS WELL
ATTENDED DALY SAFETY BRIEFING
AT EACH WORK SITE. AND THAT THE
INJURED THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
GIVE IT A WORKERS COMPENSATION
CLAIM FORM WITHIN ONE DAY.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
CRITICAL DISCLOSURES SB ELEVEN
OH TWO REQUIRES. THAT WILL
ALLOW THE FALL OF THE WORKERS
TO INDEPENDENTLY DETERMINE
WHETHER THEIR EMPLOYERS COMPLY
WITH THE FOOTBALL CALIFORNIA
LAWS. AND WE ALSO URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU.
ON ANYONE. IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. IF NOT MISS
MODERATED WE HAVE ANYONE
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. AGAIN HIS
NAME AS ASIAN POSITION. THANK
YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT
AND A LINE IS. FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN FIVE TWENTY SEVEN. THE
CHAIR MEMBER MAKES ALL GALA ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. YOU AN OUTLINE
OF. FIVE THIRTY TO FIVE THIRTY
TWO. KEVIN AND GIRLFRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
WORN OUT AND CONQUER SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL SHANKLY THANK YOU.
FIVE FIVE THIRTY. WITH A
PICTURE MEMBERS SNIDER WITH CAL
WITH CENTER ALSO FOR THANK YOU.
TO THE LINE OF THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE THREE THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND OUT OF
LINE OF. FIVE THIRTY THREE FIVE
THIRTY THREE. FIVE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN WE DON'T HEAR
YOU. THANK YOU KAREN ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER TRYING TO
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
OF FIVE THIRTY FOUR FIVE THIRTY
FOUR. THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBER IF
THIS IS ACTUALLY WALKER WITH
NOT AND THEN ON BEHALF OF THE
MONTEREY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND NOW TO LIVE. FIVE
FIFTEEN FIVE FIFTEEN. ECHO
CHAVEZ THE AFTER UNITED
FARMWORKERS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. RIGHT
THANK YOU OUR NEXT UP WILL MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION AND TO TESTIFY
ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE MATTHEW ALAN WITH THE
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND
BRIAN LITTLE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOR. A MISTRIAL. ARE
EITHER BUT IF YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
THE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CURRENTLY WE
DON'T. HAVE MISTER ALLEN OR
BRIAN. ON A HILL LINE CURRENT.
BRIAN LET ARE YOU RUNNING LINE
GOVERNOR FARM BUREAU. BUT IF WE
IF WE CAN MOVE TO THE PHONE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER.
INDIVIDUALS IN OPPOSITION-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO STATE THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THE RECORD AND WE CAN COME BACK
AND SEE IF MATTY ON A BRAND
LITTLE GET ON THE PHONE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. A TEACHER CAN
YOU. AND LINE FIVE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AT FIVE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THAT CHAIRMAN SYSTEMATICALLY
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD EVENING THIS IS
MATTHEW WITH THAT WESTERN
GORE'S ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
THE BILL AT TODAY WE ARE
OPPOSED TO ELEVEN OH TOO
BECAUSE THAT- FRANKLY
REPRESENTS MORE THAN JUST A
BILL OF RIGHTS IT SUBSTANTIALLY
CHANGES THE LAW AND TO-
CRITICAL AREAS THE FIRST IT ON
TRAVEL TIME- THE SECOND IS ON-
HOUSING. ON TRAVEL I AM THE
BILL ATTEMPTS TO ACTUALLY
CHANGE THE BOB BYE BYE THE
FAILING TO DENOTE CRITICAL
DISTINCTION BETWEEN MANDATED
INVOLUNTARY TRAVEL TIME. WHEN
THE TRAVEL TIME IS MANDATED
THAT IS COMPENSABLE TIME BUT
WHEN IT VOLUNTARY- IT NOT
COMPENSABLE AND WE BELIEVE THE
BILL SHOULD ACTUALLY MADE
STATIONS THAT THIS CLAIMING TO
BE A BILL OF RIGHTS. HAVE CAN
YOU TO ASK A THE OPPOSITE
SPONSOR TO MAKE THAT. AND IF
NOT THEN THEN THE BILL SHOULD
JUST BATTLING WHICH SHOULD BE-STRICKEN OUT- SO THAT WE ARE
EXISTING LOT IS THE SECOND
ISSUE IS ON H. TO A EMPLOYER
PROVIDED HOUSING AND THEN
MAKING. THE AGE TO WAY EMPLOYEE
AN ACTUAL TENANTS. UNDER
CALIFORNIA HOUSING LAW- THAT'S
EXTRAORDINARILY PROBLEMATIC-
GIVEN THAT THE- HOUSING IS
PROVIDED AS PART OF THE
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIP AND- WE
DON'T BELIEVE. THAT THAT- IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO. SIMPLY MAKE A
BLANKET- POLICY THAT THAT THAT
THAT EMPLOYEE NOW HAS TENNESSEE
RIGHT IN CALIFORNIA SO FOR
THOSE REASONS AND OTHERS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK YOU
I BELIEVE WE HAVE BRIAN LITTLE
COMPANY FORMER ALLY NOW. YES
BUT YOU'RE TERRIBLY BRIGHT
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY THE THANK. YOU VISION
TO THE ISSUES THAT MISTER ALLEN
REYES RESPECT TO THOSE TWO WE
THINK ARE IMPORTANT CHANGES THE
LAW THAT DESERVED TO BE DEBATED.
RIGHT I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT ONE OF THE PROPONENTS OF
THE LEGISLATION. THE DETAIL THE
WHOLE WITH THE THINGS THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE THAT. ARE
SUPPOSEDLY DID NOT INFORM THEIR
EMPLOYEES ABOUT MOST THINGS ARE
NOT TRUE- WE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU PROVIDE FIVE LAMINATED
POSTERS- TOO MANY OF ITS
MEMBERS THAT THIS WAS A GREAT
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
DESCRIBED IN THE TESTIMONY. IN
ADDITION MANY TO THINK BIG THE
TESTIMONY ARE TWENTY TWO
REQUIRED THAT CULTURAL WORKING
CAL. ARE REQUIRED TO TRADE THEM
FOR ABOUT HE BUILT. AND NIGHT
WORK OUR TO EXAM THAT. TOLD ME
OF THOSE THINGS YOU'RE EITHER
REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE THE MINUTE.
SHOULD IS REQUIRED THIS THE-
EITHER AT THE STATE LAW AND
FEDERAL. WITH TRADE REQUIRE THE
BILL ALONG WITH OF THOSE THINGS.
AS WITH THE THAT IN FOR YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY I. TO BE ABLE TO
OUR THIS OF ACT. AT FOR THAT
REALLY WE HAVE. IN ADDITION
VERY MISTER. UNDERRATED WE BOTH
A BE A LOT IN A TIP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
NEVER ON THE LINE AND NOT. A
NAY COOLEY ATION POSITION. FIVE
FIVE OR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HAVING COME AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA J. OF. HOLD ON LET
ME TURN OFF TURN UP MY HEARING
AID CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY
GET OUT WE ARE ALSO GOV THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
NOW TO THE LINE OF MATTHEW
ALLEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK
WE HAVE MISTER ALAN AND THE
TESTIMONY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
AND WE WILL GO TO LIVE FIVE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE CARD NUMBER WE CAN'T
GUARANTEE WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REDUCE
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NOW TO LIVE FIVE
THERE SIX WE AGO. KEVIN
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF ONE
MAKERS POWER AND OPPOSITION
THINK DEAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU I'M ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM. THE COMMITTEE
pWE DO HAVE A MOTION- I WANT TO
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD AND PRICKLY
IN REGARDS TO- THE HOUSING
COMPONENT OF IT BECAUSE- YES
THERE MAY BE AN UNPLANNED
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIP.
THAT ARRANGES. THE HOUSING BUT
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THERE IS
GOING TO BE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS OF TENANCY INPUT INTO
THE IMPLIED WANTING
HABITABILITY AND OTHER
TENNESSEE RIGHTS. SHOULD APPLY
TO EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
ARRANGEMENT CONTRACTUAL
ARRANGEMENT IS THAT CREATES
THAT HOUSING THE END OF MY
MIGHT JUST COMMENT ON THAT
MISTER CHAIR YEAH. THE BILL
DOES NOT CREATE TENANT RATES
FOR H. TO A GUEST WORKER SOME
OF THOSE HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED
BY OUR COURTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EXTENDS. TENANT
RIGHTS TO ALL WORKERS INCLUDING
GUEST WORKERS. THE GUEST WORKER
PROGRAM PROVIDES THAT THE
EMPLOYER PROVIDES
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING- AND
SO IF I CAN JUST ADDRESS THE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUE AS WELL.
AGAIN THERE'S A LAW IN
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT THE ROYAL PACKING CASE
THERE'S BEEN CASES LITIGATED
THAT HAVE SETTLED FOR MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS- BUT WHAT'S UNIQUE
ABOUT EACH TO A WORKERS. AND
IT'S WHERE I THINK THE
OPPOSITION ISN'T BEING TOTALLY
TRANSPARENT. THE FEDERAL
CONTRACT THE EMPLOYER PROVIDES
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
WORKERS ARE BROUGHT IN BUSES
FROM MEXICO FOR THE MOST PART.
THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR OWN
VEHICLES THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SO
WHERE SOME OF THE LITIGATION
HAS LOOKED AT WHETHER.
TRANSPORTATION IS MANDATORY OR
OPTIONAL THAT DOESN'T EXIST FOR
AN H. TO A GUEST WORKER THEY
ARE HOUSED BY THE EMPLOYER THE
EMPLOYER UNDER THE FEDERAL
CONTRACT PROVIDES
TRANSPORTATION TO THE WORK
SITE. SO THIS SEEKS TO CLARIFY.
THAT OBLIGATION AND THAT IT'S
INCLUDED IN THE NOTICE THIS
BILL ULTIMATELY PROVIDES NOTICE
TO WORKERS INDIVIDUALLY NOT A
POSTER THAT'S POSTED. IN A
HOUSING AREA OR IN A BUS OR ON
A- TOILET NAM IT GIVES EACH
WORKER. SOMETHING THEY CAN READ
ON HIS OR HER OWN TIME IN BE
MADE AWARE OF THEIR RIGHTS
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW- IN. ALL
MAKE THAT MY CLOTHES INVESTORS
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT ENTERTAIN
OTHER QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THAT
WORKS AND WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO SECONDED
BY SOME MEMBERS JONES SAWYER.
SALINAS COULD TAKE LONG A
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA FLORA NOW CARILLO.
CARILLO BY DEEP. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI THREE OF US
THREE OF US I SO WHAT THE BILL
IS OUT AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR
FINAL BILL OF THE EVENING SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR SENATOR
BUNNING. THANK YOU AGAIN MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE I APPRECIATE THAT
MOTION. I WILL JUST BE BRIEF
AND SAY SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR PROVIDES AN OPTION-
IN THE LABOR COME SAID. THAT
WILL SAVE TIME IN OUR COURT
SYSTEM AND IT WILL BENEFIT BOTH
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES BY
ALLOWING REPRESENTATION AT THE
ARBITRATION LEVEL THERE HAS
SOME INFORMAL OPPOSITION FILED
I WOULD ASK FOR YEAR I VOTE.
RIGHT THANK YOU THERE IS SO IS
THERE ANYONE THERE THERE'S NO
WITNESSES EITHER SIDE BUT IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE- AS
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN JUST LET
US KNOW EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION BECAUSE IT ALL ONCE
WHAT IF THERE'S AN ONLINE.
ONLINE AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR
SUPPORT. OPPOSITE GET ONE
THEY'RE ALL. WE HAVE KNOWN
CLEAN UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT- SO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
VICE CHAIR FOR A SECOND BY
SUMMER RIVAS. PLAINTIFF CAN
TAKE LONG THAT. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA HI
KALRA BY FLORA. FLORA I CARILLO
CARILLO BY DEEP. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH THAT'S THE
BILLS OUT AND- THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER MONEY FOR YOUR MANY
MANY YEARS A SERVICEMAN IS
PROBABLY THE LAST TIME YOU
APPEAR BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
AND- YOU LEFT TO THE WAY YOU
CAME IN FIGHTING FOR
FARMWORKERS FIGHTING FOR.
FIGHTING FOR WORKERS OF THANK
YOU WELL IT'S BEEN AN HONOR AND
A PRIVILEGE I'M GONNA MISS YOU
GUYS I'M GONNA MISS MOST OF
THIS I HAVE TO BE HONEST THERE
BE A FEW ASPECTS I WON'T MISS
LIKE. LIKE FOLLOWING MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE. SENATOR JACKSON'S
JUST GETTING. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR MONEY ALL RIGHT AND WE
STILL. YEAH SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
pWANNA THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY AND I WANT TO
THANK A CHIEF CONSULTANT WHO
ACTORS SECRETARY ON AND IN THE
ROOM TODAY- MAKE A LAME BUT WE
ALSO TO THANK OUR SECRETARY
LAURIE ALVAREZ'S BUT ALSO
HELPING WITH ALL THE SPEAKERS
AND ALL THE STUFF THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON- AND THEN OUR OF
PRINCE WILL CONSULT JUSTIN
DOING CRUISE ON A THINK BY
LIMITING STUFF FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT THEY DID IN A VERY
CONTRACTORS TIME. TO MAKE TODAY
HAPPEN IS ONE OF THE FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARINGS OF SINCE
RETURNING SO THAT THANK YOU TO
MY STAFF FOR THAT. AND I THINK
THAT WORLD TO GET DONE WE'LL
JUST GO THROUGH. I THINK I
THINK IT'S AN ORGANS ALL THIS.
HAS A ONE. BILL TO VOTE FOR AND
A SUMMER YES THAT'S A- AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE OR SB
THIRTY THREE. AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP. I HAVE A
LOT I. BUT NOT THIRTY EIGHT
THREE. ON NO NO OKAY SO THAT'S
THIRTY THREE AS A RESULT YOU
ARE FREE TO GO. A AND THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DEEP BUT WE
STILL HAVE SIX MORE BILLS SO
ITEM ONE SB TWO SEVENTY FIVE.
YES SO THAT'S NICE WITH THE
MEN- ON ITEM TWO SB SEVEN
TWENTY NINE. YES I ARE YOU OF
THAT ITEM THREE SB ELEVEN OH
THREE. HI ALL RIGHT. AND I SO
SB NINE SEVENTY THREE. NO. ITEM
EIGHT SB ELEVEN OH TWO. BUT THE
FIRST MONEY WONDERING YEAH NO.
AND THEN- FALLEN NINE SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. SEVEN MIL.
FOR NINE RIGHT THAT'S LAST LAST
ONE FOR. WHAT'S THE ROLE OF
RESERVOIR OR NO OKAY ALL RIGHT.
WE HELD VERSION ARE ALSO THING
SO DESEO STAFF SERGEANTS OF AS
WELL- AND ARE REPUBLICAN
CONSULTANT AS WELL THANK YOU
ALL SO MUCH FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU PUT IN AND WE'RE DONE
SO RETURNED LAST.